Yep, he's ready. I'm ready. Okay. All right,
it is 4:01, Tuesday the 18th, and we welcome
you here as we start our work session.
Thanks for coming out, and for all those that are joining online and virtually,
we appreciate you helping us out and joining the process. So we'll
start with the first item,
discussion on the Pony Express Business Park. And I believe it's
Steven, and he is ready.
All right. So we've actually— we've been working on this project for several months
with the applicant. As always,
some background. A few months ago, this did come to the Planning Commission.
There was a variance tied to these properties that was ultimately denied
based on just not meeting the criteria there for that one. So as
a workaround of that and trying to get their site to work, they're now proposing
a development agreement. And before we made them go too far along in the process,
they wanted to speak with city council members to see if that's something that they're
willing to entertain and what specific aspects they need to focus on as
they draft that agreement. So this
is the site overlaid here.
So it's 3— so these 2 lots here— I'll go back here.
So it's these 2 lots in question. There is a plat amendment
that they have right now to move this lot line up to about here.
So this would be the site. It would be 3 buildings across the 2 lots.
Here's a zoom in a little bit.
As part of the application, they— and this is part of their variance application.
I took this to help you see it.
One of the main exceptions they're seeking is a setback exception from the
wash, where we have now in our code where they have
to have a 50-foot setback from the top bank of the wash or 75-foot
from the center flow line, whichever one is greater. So they proposed— this
one is light blue is where they said is the center flow of
the wash, as well as the top bank of the wash is that outer shading
of that blue. A few months ago
when I went out there and looked at it, I mapped what I thought was
the actual top bank of the wash. So I outlined that in blue here,
and then the red lines are just their buffers that they made.
So you can see there's a— depending on which flow
or top of the bank you actually follow, those lines would actually change.
Ultimately, it's our city engineer who determines what that top bank of the wash is
and then ultimately what those setbacks would be.
So these are the requests. The first one we mentioned
is the ability to work within and construct buffers or
buildings within those buffers. They do propose
along here to have retaining walls to make their site work, which would go
up to— I think they're around 10 or 11 feet
in height. So that wouldn't be any staggering or tiers. It would just be a
sheer wall. And then they also want exceptions to not have to
construct the drive-through escape lanes. So again,
there's the site. So I feel like they don't have enough room to To
put those in, so that's really what they're asking for.
And ultimately, they want to know: should they spend the
money to design those walls if that's something that is going
to be acceptable in this development agreement, or any other feedback you're willing to provide
them so they don't they don't waste their time or staff
time, and we can move forward with this.
Are we able to chime in as the applicant?
Yeah, I don't mind, uh, if there's some questions. Do you have some context
you want to add? Yeah, I think there's just some added context.
Um, you'll notice, uh,
on the plans you were shown a different sheet. I don't know if
we can go back to show that, but it shows a green border around
this whole project. You still
have that? No, not that one.
Actually, that one works. That one works. Go back to that one.
Um, when we, when we first started this development,
um, I think it's important to note that we actually gave up
2 acres of the, the project. It's a pretty small project,
so 2 acres was a lot. Um, part of that was along
the main road, as you see there, that setback to the yellow line.
Um, but then also part of that was to mitigate Or
to provide the city room,
um, and a buffer to mitigate any concerns with the
Tickville Wash. As a part of that giving or
that taking, um, you know, that left us much smaller lots
here, but workable lots. Uh, but that also, you know, as we
come back now with our plan, um, it,
it feels a little bit like, you know, They need more and more
and more. So we took this to Planning Commission. I think an important thing to
note, Planning Commission was actually very supportive of working
with us, knowing the history of this
giving and the specific giving to mitigate any
concerns with the Tickville Wash. So I think that's an important thing
to note. The reason, if I'm not mistaken,
that it was denied is because within the code there wasn't an option necessary
to accept accept them under the— under how they were presented.
So they— so, so that we then moved
to development agreement, which was the, the secondary
option to do it. But I just want to highlight, we've not felt as we've
come, and we've not felt in our continued partnership with Eagle Mountain,
in addition to us giving up land, that there hasn't been an appetite to work
with us. In fact, it's been stated, um, by Planning Commission
and really everyone we've talked to that, hey, we want to make this we want
to work with you. The challenge we have now, now that our lot lines have
been pushed back, now that we have given already land so that, so the city
can mitigate concerns with the wash, there's not a lot
we can do with the lots. They're really small now in a retail sense.
They're really small. So we're just trying to make it work and make it work
in a way that it brings a great building to, you know, some great
commercial buildings to the city and And whatnot.
So those were the 2, call them variances or items in the development agreement we're
hoping for City Council support.
Okay, and I just had one question actually as a point of
reference for Vince. Is it even— I don't know
because of the natural aspect next to the park that we try to preserve there,
but could this even be piped and what size and Or
is that just not even— it could be piped.
If you've seen the culvert underneath the roadway, it would
have to be that same size. And so I would think it would be pretty
cost prohibitive to do that. Well, that's what I'm looking for. I don't know
there's an appetite for that. I just wanted it to be out on the table
that if it was, what that would be, so the council would know
if they could mitigate that flow line. It would be expensive.
It's possible, but expensive. And it would have to be a 60 plus.
Is it bigger than 60? It's probably a square. I think it is a square,
and it's yeah, it's bigger than 60 for sure.
Okay, I just throwing out context for that.
We've heard the presentation. Is there any questions for the applicant or for Stephen?
You guys. Oh, sorry. This is
probably Stephen or Marcus. Do we
know with a two-acre strip the frontage?
Fronting on Pony Express, if that was compensated or
if it was just dedicated to the city?
I don't know the answer to that question. I'd have
to— yeah, I didn't look at the exact— I
can speak to that. Those were given to the city. There was no compensation
for the 2 acres.
It was a 6-acre site and we ended up with 4 acres. Can we
switch to the overhead that shows where the building
would be for the site plan?
That one, or do you want a different one?
Is there one that's see-through that just has the outlines of the buildings?
No, I wasn't that nice.
I, I'm just going to be really frank. I think the thing for me that's
concerning isn't about the city mitigating the wash.
It's about whether or not that terrain is suitable
for building a commercial entity on.
And I've driven by that wash
multiple times a day for almost 2 decades, and I know
that there's changes and you can walk by it
now and see where there's some erosion and different things that
are taking place. So I'm a little hesitant
to say go for it, 'cause I feel like in a lot of ways we'd
be like the city of Draper letting a home developer
build on a hill and then having the homes fall into a pit.
I just, I'm concerned about how close it is to the wash.
And just because we can do it doesn't mean we should. So to
quote Jurassic Park,
I want these businesses to be able to grow here.
I'm just wondering if maybe Vince,
you could speak to what will happen
there because even the wall or fence that's behind
Cascade Collision and then Burt Brothers.
I just— it's right there and it always
feels like it's not in a safe place. Can you talk
about that? Yeah, it's a natural channel and the banks do
shift over time. And as we've
looked at this in different reviews that we've done, I have expressed
concern. Even if there's a retaining wall there, what are they doing
to protect the base of that retaining wall? Because it is going to be in
a flow line. And that's
nothing new. Those concerns have been expressed in the past.
But it can be done engineering-wise.
And I've expressed that to the applicants that yes, we can do
this. We have to do it the right way. But yeah, those banks do shift
and they will have to be protected. Follow-up. I think
we're becoming more astute and savvy when
it comes to grade and what's going on on a site plan.
I think we've often looked at the site plan and said,
yeah, that fits there. But is there anything
about the grade or the slope of this particular place
that is going to need to be mitigated?
If you're referring to like the 25% maximum,
I think The grade into the wash itself from
the top of the bank is definitely steeper than that.
In fact, there's some sheer, very sheer areas,
and I think that's why they were going to the retaining wall idea.
That would be the only real way to do that.
Can you switch to the diagram that shows,
like, the top of the— the 2 different comparisons? So,
Steven, will you tell us again what the red lines mean?
So the 2 red lines are the buffers that come off of this really light
blue line. So the
first, the inside one is 50 feet from the flow, or 75, no, 50 feet
from the top bank, and then the one outside
of that is 75 feet from the flow line. And the
blue lines represent what, where the top of the bank is? The blue line is
when I went out and walked the wash. Well, I didn't. I wasn't down in
the wash. I was on their side, and that's what I estimate is the
actual top bank of the wash.
Okay, thank you. Could I, as the applicant, provide a little more
context as well?
Sure.
So we we've heard Eagle Mountains.
Concern with the wash. And we too don't want— these,
these are buildings actually, we don't, um, there's no turn and burn
on these. We as a builder, we actually keep most of the assets
we build. So we're going to be the owners of these buildings. Um, not as
though we'd want to build something for a client and then run away and watch
their building, you know, have some challenges with any sort of elevations
or washes. But we're particularly interested in making sure these last the test, you know,
stand the test of time. And so we have already contracted with the engineers.
They've provided us a letter which I can send over to you guys that
speaks to not only in the design of
the wall, you know, making sure the grades and the soils
are all sure, sure, you know, sure soils to
provide a sure foundation, but also that the wall is built in
a way that can withstand any changes
in the bank. So, so that is all being
thought through. We, we hear the city— actually, the city's concerns
on that are our concerns. We, we want to make sure this withstands the
test of time, and we want to make sure it's engineered in the right way,
which, which frankly,
um, should, should be better than
a moving bank in a lot of ways. An unsecured bank,
unsecured hills. Um, You know,
soils, you know, you will have that side of the bank that's really shored
up for the future as well. Really? Is it okay if I
ask another question, Mayor? Okay, so Stephen,
there's the northernmost building on this diagram right now. Is that
set back as far as it is because of commercial setback requirements, or is that
the applicant's preference?
I can't speak to their preference, but yeah, it would meet the setbacks for that.
For the zone, I guess for me, I'd much rather see that
get closer to the edge of that front property line as
opposed to almost an entire building
in the no-build zone to the
south of that. And I'm just wondering if there's any appetite to make
adjustments there. I just feel like it's so close to the wash.
Mayor, can I just jump in? I'll just— I'll share a 30-second opinion. I mean,
I think that the code Surrounding the wash and the setback
requirements is there for a reason. I, for one, am going to really struggle to
want to enter into a development agreement to remove those standards.
In particular, in a space that is obviously impacted by
the wash. I mean, there's a city park directly south
of this, and that's an integral part of the
park where we've got some signage and some trails that are already
functioning in that area. So For me, it's unfortunate.
It's a tough piece of property to develop. My hat goes off to
you as a developer in trying to figure this out. But for me,
I'm going to err on the side of maintaining
those code standards on this piece of property.
And I think I feel the same as well as Councilmember Wright.
Yeah, I would echo that. We have other areas in our city where this wasn't
really followed, and the embankments have shifted, and homeowners have had
foundations crack. In fact, we had a resident that a couple
months ago I went out to, to look at that, and it's just created issues.
And, um, I, I think I'm probably going to
fall within the lines of the code that, that exists. And I would say
not to mention our area, but other areas where they didn't follow this and
houses get swept away. But I just wanted maybe a quick yes or no.
If the reason I asked that question before, if there was say gabion baskets or
piping, would that change anything? It's— I don't
know that it's even possible. I was just curious. Probably for me, the answer would
be no. I'm just— they're looking for direction. I just want to make sure that
we've exhausted. I could easily give on the drive-through
escape lane. That part, I'm not married
to that aspect.
Didn't change anybody on— OK. I'll take that as it does. Just so that the
applicant can know that they don't come back and say, well, what if we do
baskets, or what if we do— I just want to make sure that we're
sticking to the code on this one. Is that— any other questions?
OK. Thanks, Stephen. Appreciate it.
The next one, uh, I'm actually excited
to hear about this as an avid shooter myself and,
uh, working with, with our— it went from the interns
to Ethan and Addie to Ethan and
Addie as individuals. And so I loved watching them earn their own
names and not just be interns. I understand Ethan's online.
I hope. Yes, yes, that's right. Okay,
uh, hang on. We— oh, there's— there it is.
Okay, go ahead. Okay, thank you very much,
Mayor and Council. I wish that I could be there in person today
to be able to thank you for the intern experience that I've had.
Unfortunately, I had a surprise trip to the ER
yesterday morning for some eye problems, but I've been able to
confine myself to a dark room and— but I'm
prepared, ready to present. So thank you for bearing with me through this.
And thank you for a wonderful summer,
a great internship experience. I feel like I've been able
to see a lot of unique things happen just in the span of a couple
months, which will provide some great context and experience
for the rest of my program. At BYU and hopefully future
jobs down the line, wherever that may be. So thank you for,
for making this a great summer for me.
So yes, this is about a month or 2 ago.
Mayor came to us, and I think there were other couple employees
that had similar experiences of residents who wanted to
practice archery, but they weren't really sure where or how or if
it was legal at all. And well, it really it wasn't.
People couldn't shoot in their backyards, and so
the goal was to provide a way for archery ranges to be
housed in Eagle Mountain. And technically,
you could say there there was a way, but it
wasn't very fleshed out or regulated,
especially to the same extent that. an outdoor
shooting range was. So for context, this is all
that there really is in the code right now, or this is all that there
is regarding archery, that residents
couldn't discharge a bow more than 10 pounds of pull weight,
which is really nothing. That's practically a toy bow with
a suction cup on the end of it. And it
had to go through Planning Commission review for any applicants. But other than that,
there, there were not very many standards or guidelines
for applicants to consider when they wanted to propose
to build an archery range within the city.
So the goal was to provide a more robust framework for that.
And the best way that I found to do that would be to combine
the outdoor shooting range overlay zone with the archery range.
With an archery range zone. So those would become one zone because
many of the same standards that outdoor shooting ranges have,
archery ranges could follow many of those as well.
So this amendment would add archery range to that overlay zone,
and then that would be able to provide for all the operational
and safety standards. And it would also require
that the applicant obtained the land use authority approval
as part of the application process. So some
of the key changes or the key things that I've added that
are different for archery ranges than for shooting ranges.
One would be to refer the applicant to
safety standards. The national or
the sort of governing body on archery participant safety is
USA Archery. So that would require the applicant
to consider their safety guidelines. It also provides a
line regarding backstop and projectile containment,
because that's also very separate, very different from shooting ranges.
And then I've also provided different
definitions for bows and crossbows, because in
certain scenarios, those should be treated very differently, especially considering
that crossbows have more of a trigger mechanism similar to
firearms. And bows can certainly be scaled
differently. They have different pull weights.
Some are for children and some are for adults. So I've
also outlined different
age groups should have different standards. So the age
of 8 is where in the outdoor shooting range overlay
zone children are not allowed to use firearms
if they're under the age of 8, but bow safety
is a little bit separate. So I have allowed for children under
the age of 8 to use bows, as long as within USA Archery guidelines.
And then finally, there within the special use
chapter within the code, there is indoor shooting range standards.
But I have mirrored all of the same safety standards from the outdoor range
to the indoor range, so those would all look similar.
And that is essentially all the changes. It's mainly
just an addition of archery
into the outdoor overlay zone, outdoor shooting range overlay
zone. I'm curious to hear if there are
any other safety standards you would like to see considered or
potentially added to this code as we move forward.
So, thank you. And I'm willing
to pull up— I can have the, uh, the code
as I, as I've edited it pulled up, um, if you have questions.
Thank you for putting this together. As a kid that grew up on a on
an archery team. It's fun to see something like this come forward.
My question is regarding the age of 8. That seems
a little young. I, I would probably consider maybe 12 or 13.
Um, I'm curious where— how
you came to the age 8 to— yeah,
I might raise that up a little bit. Does that make sense? Of course.
The question? Yeah. I can absolutely consider that. Yeah,
as I looked through the USA Archery guidelines,
um, it had all of these amazing stats
about how archery is one of the most safe recreational
activities. And oftentimes there was sort
of like an 8-year-old threshold where, um,
as long as there is like adult, constant adult
supervision with that 8-year-old. It can be practiced, but, you know, that's all I
went off of. That can absolutely be changed and raised.
I, I think, and it's been a minute, I know I only looked 35,
but I haven't taken hunter safety. I think you can hunt at 12. You can
hunt at 12, that's right. So, so 13 would be— I mean,
you could have a license. I think that'd be too high. Yeah.
So I
think giving them an opportunity to experience that. I mean, these— it's
in a controlled environment. They're going to have a range boss there, a parent.
You're not going to drop an 8-year-old off to go shoot. You know, they'll be
with somebody. So I think I'm less concerned about that in a controlled environment.
Maybe if they were just out outside of that, that might be a different story.
Another thing too, their insurance or liability insurance may end up
naturally limiting age. So I'm inclined to let it be that
8-year-old mark and kind of let the market forces kind
of control it a little bit. So I would just recommend that we
add on that portion that talks about the children under the age
of 8 may be permitted to handle a bow with the supervision of a responsible
adult, or, and in accordance with the USA Archery— I think it should say guidelines
so that we know what that's referencing.
Okay. But I have no issues with an 8-year-old. Shoot, I was doing crazier
stuff than that at 8. Okay,
I know your time is limited, so you, uh, you're going back to school.
We appreciate you and all that you've done for our city, so hopefully
we see you down the road. Absolutely. Thank you so much.
Thank you all, Mayor and Council. Thank you. Yes, thank you.
All right, another great, uh, presentation, and this one I'm
really excited about for the council because, uh,
this is something we've kind of been looking for. And as we brainstorm this idea
of, uh, trying to kind of compare our staffing needs with,
with our workload, uh,
Addie and I sat down and with Natalie and others and, and tried
to come up with a metric. So the idea here is if we're missing something,
the we're not done. Give feedback to what else we
can use for the, uh,
what would help us make good decisions in the future. So good
feedback is what we're looking for. And thank you very much
for your time here as well.
Hello, Mayor and Council. Thank you for allowing me to present today. I appreciate the
opportunity. A little bit about me. My name
is Addison Cragin. I'm an intern for Eagle Mountain City right now, and I'm
studying at BYU in the MPA program. And I'm from Texas originally,
but I've been in Utah for the last 6 years and have loved it.
All right, today I'll be presenting about a plan for an analysis that looks
at the staffing load— or staffing level versus the
workload in cities close by to Eagle Mountain City.
And this will just help us to see where Eagle Mountain stands compared to other
cities that have different growth rates, population sizes, and other
things like that. And we haven't
started gathering data yet for this, and so we wanted to just present to you
guys to get feedback so that we're making sure that it aligns with your
goals and what you guys want out of this study.
And I have a short presentation, and I will just have you guys leave
the comments till the end. Just so we can show all the things that we
have done so far.
All right. So for this study, we are looking at cities that are similar
to Eagle Mountain City, but also that have bigger population sizes,
have different growth rates, and also just different projects,
departments. And those cities are Herriman,
Riverton, Saratoga Springs, Lehi, Orem,
Provo, and Spanish Fork. These cities all have different situations
and also maturity levels, which will help us to learn more about
what we can learn from them, but also what we're already doing well here
at Eagle Mountain City.
All right, and we have a few areas of focus that we're looking at for
this study, and those areas are demographics, parks and
streets, trails and open space, water,
recreation center, fire and rescue, and then also just staffing
numbers overall at the city.
All right. For this analysis, I will coordinate with the chosen
cities that we've decided to investigate and send them a survey where we'll ask
for the data points that we're going to use for this analysis. And here
you can see the layout of the different areas and also
of the different data points we're wanting to gather from those cities.
And I'll just list off a few of them. It's not the whole list,
but just the ones that are kind of the focus of what Mayor wanted us
to look at. And those are how many acres
of parks you have and also how many employees you have to maintain those parks.
How many lane miles of road you maintain and also how many employees
you have to help maintain those roads.
And then does your fire department run on 3-hand crews or 4-hand
crews? Those are a few of the ones that we're asking for and then
also just a list of all the departments they have and, like, staffing numbers
for each department, just to compare with us.
All right. And so for this study, we hope that we can try and pinpoint
areas that we're doing well, but also areas that we could improve
on as we continue to grow in population size and also grow just
in general with different departments and needs for the city. And so
here's a few questions we hope to learn from this study.
that we can help— hope you guys can apply as
you learn about how to fix the city and make it better. All right,
so those questions are, are we understaffed or overstaffed
in any of the areas? What services do other cities provide, and could we maybe
make those in-house or outsource for those services?
What departments do other cities have that we don't? Maybe we could
rearrange or add. to make it better for growth in the
future? Are there any services that we should consider outsourcing,
things like plowing? And then how
many employees do we need as the city continues to grow in each department and
also just overall? And the last one is how does our workload compare
to the other cities?
And as I stated earlier, we have not yet gathered any data.
So we're here— I'm here today just to get feedback and suggestions
to make it more catered to what you guys are wanting to change for the
city. So now I'm open to questions, feedback, or changes to this
current plan. Thank you, that was a great presentation.
Would you jump back a couple slides? Yes. The one that
had— that one right there. Yeah. So just a couple of questions I think would
be helpful in asking these, just starting with the parks.
I think we should find out how they're determining their
workload. Based on those parks, so if they have you
know how many total parks do you have? How many regional parks? What are how
many teams do you have? How size what are the sizes of your teams and
how many man hours are you planning per park? I think
for me, I want I want to be able to understand how we decide
that we're over or understaffed,
particularly when we're talking about the people who are out there performing the the
work. Whether we're talking about parks, streets, etc. So I
think while we're asking, that would be some good information to
find out what drives your decision to add additional
labor. What are the solutions that you're using to
do additional labor? How are you leveraging seasonal work?
How are you leveraging some of your high school student type ages that
they're only going to be there during the summer weekends kind of a thing?
I think We have a large amount of those in our city, and I would
love to see how it's being utilized in other cities.
So that would be the first one. And then if you'll just go
to the next, I don't know if it was the next, yes. I think it's
also important for us to understand the structure of our departments.
Are we underlabor, overlabor,
overmanaged, undermanaged? I think it would be great for us to understand
how other cities that we're asking these questions about, do they
have 6-man teams underneath the manager, whereas we may
have 2 or 3, or maybe we have 10 under us and we really should
be managing it with 5. I think it would be good to find out how
other people are doing that to see kind of where we lay out with that
and whether or not these people are also the managers. So I'll
say like team leads specifically if I'm talking about labor. streets, parks,
that they're out working with the people that aren't necessarily working from a desk
somewhere kind of thing. So I think for me, I'd love to know those kind
of things so that we know we're getting the biggest bang for our buck in
how we're hiring and where we need to do some addition.
Okay, perfect. Yeah, we'll add that.
All right. I personally would like to see St. George and/or
Washington included because They have a similar growth trajectory and
they have a lot of land like we do. And if we're gonna look at
parks, I think it's good to throw those guys in the mix.
The other thing that I was hoping that we could find a way just to
standardize the answers that we get back from them. We have some contract
work, a lot of contract work for our parks. And I think it's gonna be
really important that we ask if they are
contracting work, how many bodies are actually doing that work?
And I like how you're including the fire question
about 3-hand versus 4-hand. One of the things that I was wondering,
could we ask these cities to give us 5 years of numbers,
especially the ones that are in a high growth pattern like us?
I think their trajectory would really be helpful for us in seeing when
some of those things would happen. And I think it's probably just as easy to
answer. One year as it is three or five years, so I
guess it wouldn't hurt to ask.
And then there
was another question, and it just went away. Oh, with the parks, can we find
out how many new acres each year that each of these cities
are bringing on? Because I think that that is a crucial metric
for us to just pay attention to, just because of all of our new
development and growth. So other than that, I love it. Perfect. And did you
want the 5-year for all of them, or just— is there certain ones
that, like, ones that are more like developed and grown, or ones
that are currently growing? Can I cut in? I think we gotta be cautious of
the other cities and what we're asking, 'cause that's gonna require a lot of research.
And I'm— Most of them have it in their budget. If they have it,
I just don't wanna, you know, I wanna make sure that we don't push on
it. I think that's fair. So I guess I would say if
they have the information readily available, I think like Herriman
and Washington and St. George especially, it would be great
to see what happened with their population and parks and some of those other things.
If we can't, we can't, but it's useful data. I think of that when they—
when people call us, if we got 2 or 3 of these and then we
just have staffers, you know, they're just doing research for everybody. We got to be
a little cognizant. The second thing is specifically you mentioned parks in St.
George area, and they have a different climate, so they
wouldn't have as much grass. I just want that to be noted.
I think that that's an important distinction. Okay, that's good to think about.
I love this. In economics, we have something we
call— it's called a PMI index, where you can take every month there's a
survey of 800 companies and they ask them the same question
every single month. And when you do this over time, it creates
what Councilmember Clark's talking about as an index that you can go to and get
a pulse of how is the economy doing. And I think what you're starting
here is something like an index for cities. As a new councilmember
coming into this role and saying, hey, fund this job, and I'm saying, what kind
of data do we have around— do we— I don't know, other than You
know, just taking somebody's word for it.
So as a council member, that would be really helpful to have this index.
I'm wondering if there's some other engineering metrics that could be
tied in, like building permits, inspections.
Yeah, I'm the wrong guy to ask. The right guys are over here.
Just, you know, what does that quantity look like as you think about all
the different departments within within a city. It looks like you've got the streets,
park, kind of the exterior-facing jobs,
but inside, like attorneys,
finance, purchasing, there's a lot of administrative logistics
that happen within a city as well. So I'd love to maybe see some of
those metrics. But I love it. This is a great idea. Yeah, awesome.
Thanks. We'll add that into it too. I think it'd be helpful
to know, to delineate between full-time employees and part-time
employees, which I think cities should have that data pretty readily available.
And then I would also be curious if we could get public safety
added into this. If we're going to ask about fire, I'd be curious,
do you have your own police department and what are the staffing levels for
their police department? Yeah, that's a good idea. We'll add, we'll do it more broad
of not just fire and rescue.
And you may even ask how many fire stations they have.
Okay. Craig, could I— so as clarity, uh, when you say staffing
levels specific to the police department per 1,000, like what's the,
what's the metrics you're looking for? Well, we'll have their population. We can get their
population data. So that's what you want them to get, the staffing
level per population? Are you talking per call volume? Like what's the— I'm more
staffing per population. So we just need to know the total number? That's my main,
that's my main. Okay, good. Okay, perfect. Probably the
only thing I would add, I think it's been a good discussion, is I'm concerned
about fleet services and where that shows up because that will segment into parks,
streets, trails, and open space. I mean, there's a
fleet that we're maintaining and we're employing someone to take care of it, or we're
sending those out. If we have more road miles than another city,
we might have 6 or 7 snowplows and another city might only have
2. And so I think that there's some additional Costing that we should be aware
of in some of those areas. So, okay, perfect. I thought of one
more thing, um, and I know it's not a municipal
function, but we still have to support it. Knowing the
number of schools that they have and number of crossing guards, I think might
be a useful metric for us because that's something that changes
a lot for us. So yeah, that's a good point, especially for Eagle Mountain.
Perfect. There, we made it a lot easier,
Addie. No, this is great. This is for you
One more thing that's just bouncing around in my head.
This is probably not going to be specific to the cities that you've chosen,
but I think it would be interesting to know in the categories that you've chosen,
which cities are at the very top for each of those categories,
and what is causing them to be excellent at those things. Okay.
I think that would be interesting to know. Yeah, so just have that ranking at
the end of the analysis? Yeah. Okay, perfect. Yeah,
thank you for all your suggestions.
I think you just created a full-time job. I think you were out
of town when this brainchild came up, and it's— and we
went forward. So I love it. That's great. Okay. I think it'd be really good,
Mayor, too, if we could kind of pressure ULCT to start
collecting these metrics, because it'd be totes easy for them to do
it, and that would be a really good metrics, like Councilmember
Hewish said. And the reason too I lean back over here,
because I know our time is limited with Addie and Ethan
to help us, and we do want to finish this project. I've spoken
with Natalie and she's going to at least compile data, but like you said,
this could be a bigger project than we hoped, and we
may need to allocate some— And what I would say is this, Mayor, I think
that the data, if we can compile the data in anticipation of next
year's budget. I think that's where it would be most helpful. So I'm just— yeah,
just making sure that council's okay with directing some staff time to finish this if
needed. And, and that might be more than Adelaide's, uh,
you know, we've got lots of talented staff. So unless
you think you can get it all done— so we'll work
through that. Good. I think Melissa's
suggestion is actually pretty excellent. I think I, I find
I have a hard time embracing ULCT's value
for me, frankly. And I'm going to tell you, I think that's
one of those ways that they could be a real resource to the cities of
Utah, to start creating an index to help us with
hiring practices, to know when and how the next hire should
be done. When we're— I mean, if we're going to continue at
the pace that we're continuing because the legislature is pushing these initiatives with
housing, et cetera, it would be helpful for them to have data-driven
decisions to be able to help its members to take a look at and go,
it's time, and here are the resources, here are the ways that
you can accomplish that, here's what's available to you. Because I think those are
meaningful things, particularly when you're talking about cities that are young.
We've gone through every difficult growth
that there is. And there's a lot of cities that are coming. I mean,
you build a new road across the lake, we will create a new city
at the south end of that lake. And it's going to happen. And as
new cities continue to grow like that, it would be good for
those of us who have already been through the struggle in the last 50 years
to be able to share data that could help those in the future, too.
Yeah. I like
that for the simple fact we keep spending money on wage studies every few years.
If the data's just there and updated by each city, we can go do our
own study and what people cost. So great
idea. I think it's been a good discussion. You have the direction we need,
both you and Natalie and staff. Yeah, perfect. Thank you so much for your time
and for the suggestions. Yes, and your time here with our city. Thank you very
much. Yes, thank you. It's been fun. Okay,
I believe Kimberly's online as well, correct? Okay.
We've had some conversations on this next one's proposed policy around
tax funding for— I think it says Sheriff's Office,
but I think it's public safety in general. That include both?
Public safety. Yeah, so that's fire and
sheriff and kind of some guardrails of some ideas.
I know Kimberly's had some ideas. Evan has asked
for direction specifically as we move this forward, like I
think I do think you had two or three slides. Is that right? And then,
and really just wondering how you want to go forward.
So show us what you started with, and we'll go from there.
Yep, I'll be pretty quick about this.
We had some instructions from City Council to put together kind
of a draft ordinance that would essentially tie our property
tax revenues specifically to public safety.
And again, as the mayor mentioned, it's not necessarily just the
sheriff's office meant to be broadly accepting of whatever happens down the road.
That draft ordinance was put together over
the past week or so, and that language is all there to create
a public safety fund and then have certain parameters so that
as property tax ebbs and flows, There's certain thresholds
that we're trying to meet within that, coverage ratios that we're trying to
stay within. It does create parameters to say what
does qualify as a public safety expense,
you know, limitations of that fund. The monies can't move from
fund to fund. There needs to be annual reviews and all sorts of
things like that. So it is there now for your
review and for our discussion. Discussion tonight. As the mayor suggests as well,
there, there are some things that we can still talk about with this that we
need to kind of figure out, both something
specifically with the code as far as how you want to approach it, but then
also some potential alternatives if you want to look at alternatives.
A couple things that I identified in here, and this is some
things that you probably already know, is that just because it's code doesn't
mean it can't be It could still be changed down the road. We're obviously
trying to set a standard or a precedent here
now where this is the future of Eagle Mountain,
how we use our property taxes, but that could change down
the road. This code doesn't necessarily
imply that there's any other new public review process either.
There's still just the budget process as far as how this is reviewed. Reviewed annually,
and then other just kind of accountability things between the city manager and whatnot.
And then enforcement and accountability is a little bit ambiguous,
and that's just because I didn't know exactly how you wanted to handle that.
What happens if we go outside the boundaries of this and things
like that? So I also just kind of left this a
little bit ambiguous in some respects too, just because there is a Technically,
when you approach something like this, this isn't necessarily groundbreaking
or revolutionary what you're asking for. And I say that because it's not to
try and kind of ease your feelings to feel like this is something that can
be done. It is something that certainly could be a policy of the
city council, but also kind of lead into there
is an alternative that is the more typical approach, and that is to make this
a financial policy. So, So this is just
to kind of outline for you. Again, we do it whatever way you want to
do it. I just want to make sure that you're aware that this is typically
how it's done with a financial policy.
And the reason why you do it through a financial policy, as mentioned
in these, these bullet points, these financial policies are pretty
robust as they carry through the entire financial
process throughout the entirety of the year.
So you're, you're looking at this through not just the budgeting process but
the auditing process and all of our reporting and things like that. The financial policies
are baked into all of that. Um, so you're,
you're looking at adding your financial policies in the budget book.
You're adding it into all these different things that come to you in multiple cases
throughout the year for public viewing as well.
Um, but then on top of that, uh,
it's still has the same kind of teeth that this ordinance
would have if the ordinance, as we're looking at it
right now, maintains a certain level of enforcement and accountability, because there isn't really
a whole lot of enforcement accountability currently drafted into that code.
So when we look at— I would treat
this almost— in my mind, it helped to kind of compare this
to like our employee policies and procedures manual.
It's not just kind of a policy we throw out there because we
just need some sort of unity on something. It is something that's meant to have
some real meat to it, that is something you can hold people to,
but it's not necessarily something that's in city code.
Besides that, I just want to bring up— this is what the GFOA, the Government
Finance Officers Association, says on financial policies. And I
won't necessarily read through all of these, but you can see on the top levels
there that they regularly recommend financial
policies, which we do have plenty right now already as a city.
But they give a lot of weight to these financial policies as good
practices for municipalities across the country for
the purposes of institutionalizing good financial management practices,
clarifying, crystallizing strategic intent for financial management and
defining boundaries and promoting long-term and strategic thinking.
These financial policies are really what guide
our budgeting process overall and help guide our
staff and guide all of leadership management. So that is
another approach. But again, if it's your preference to move
forward on a city code, we can absolutely do it that way. As well.
So that's all I have for you, but happy to
talk through this at all or, or take any direction from you.
This is going to sound negative, but I'm just going to say it.
I feel like that when we, when we talk about something that's new,
we start with, well, a new council can change that. I've heard that at
least 5 times. In the last month, and I'm curious
why that's the first response from our staff. I've heard it from our attorney.
I've heard it from you. I've heard it from Ben. I think that we're well
aware of that. I don't think that needs to be stated anymore. I think that's
clear. The second thing is,
is I'm trying to understand why present an alternative to this because I
think everybody is aware of the teeth kicking that we've taken over the last month.
And when we're trying to do something that is very transparent,
that shows all of our hand to the citizens to show exactly
what we're trying to accomplish, and then we're told, well, we really ought to do
this in a way that is kind of there, but you have to really look
to find it. I just— that seems opposite
of what we've been trying to accomplish with this. It's the reason that Zach and
I had this conversation about forcing the issue.
To show the citizens that we intend it to go exactly where we say it's
going to go, and that by ordinance it's forced to go into that place.
When we talk about policies, I mean, I think everybody— well, except for maybe
the council members to my left and right— were here when we were told
about what our policies and procedures manual actually had in it,
as opposed to what we keep being told is in there. And I don't feel
confident that it has all the policies that we think that
are in there. I think we have to go and search to find them.
And so for me, I'm not interested really in chasing after the alternative.
I think those should be there also, by the way. You should have policies that
are in place that are guiding how you do those things. But with respect to
how we're going to evaluate property tax specifically,
that should be crystal clear. And I think that we have
told everybody that this is what our plan was. There's a lot of people who
are skeptical as to whether or not that's actually the case. And I want it
to be 100% clear that when we said that's what it was, we intended for
that to be the case. And I want it to be hard.
I hope a council has to step up and go, yeah, you know what,
we really don't want you to know where we're putting this money, and let them
take that fire. Good luck with that. But I'm going to tell you, I think
that public safety, if we're going to go there, it should be restricted to that.
So that we do exactly what we say we're doing. That's my opinion.
Thanks. Thank you, Evan, for preparing this. I'm probably
in the camp of do both.
Code and having it written in
our city code allows for residents to come to a city council
and say, it says right here that this is how this should work.
I understand we can't bind a future council to
decrease tax rates or increase tax rates.
The idea of this mechanism, having that in
code, is that it would require that councils would, in an open meeting,
talk about what is our coverage ratio, with the target
being stated at 85%. If the
coverage ratio they meet, it's at 100%, then the council could consider
cutting the tax, pulling it back. Or if it's
below the lower band of 75%, then maybe a
modest increase to property tax is warranted to catch up
to the growth that we've had in sheriffs. Not having
that for the last 10 years has created this environment where we have had our
safety subsidized by sales taxes. Sales taxes, which, which as we all know,
can fluctuate with the economy. This just assures that city councils
in a public meeting can review the coverage ratio, look at the upper
bands and lower bands, and the second piece of that is is
having those funds assured that they're not commingled
with with sales tax revenue. That when you pay a property tax,
you know it's going in exactly for public safety.
Today, that would be for our sheriff's contract.
So I think I'm probably both. Let's hit it on both sides.
I think it's a great idea to have a financial policy, but I'd also like
to have it in code. So for future councils,
it's there, and I think we're more likely to adhere to it.
And again, thank you. I read through it. You spent a lot of time putting
that together. It's very good. No. I really like the
idea of having it in both, um, because I— as
we were having this kind of discussion about code versus policy,
we've had code in the past where we had like 3 different boards
and commissions that just existed in code, but we didn't do anything with them.
And it took finally repealing that, that like code
is more visible for residents, but it doesn't necessarily
mean that something's Done with it. I think that we're making changes
in that direction, but I like the policy because everybody
knows that the financial nerds love their policy,
and they will. It's just like the timing
of when each report is due and all of those other things. That's all they
live and die by that, and I think that's a really important piece. I also
wrote down who's responsible to execute this. Is it?
Under the city manager's responsibility, is it the director of a certain
functional area? I think that that's a really important
piece that we need to determine,
so that we both the public and the council
and mayor can hold this person accountable to make sure that they're
bringing us the information. And then there
were some other things that I talked to a couple council members about.
And I don't know if it needs to go on this or if it needs
to go in a different piece of code, but I know staff
has been working on some level of service metrics. And I
think that we need to ask for some specific
metrics required in code to be brought
to council and presented in our first like budget meeting when we first
start having our strategic meetings
and different things like that. And that would be things like call volume and
how much the contract is, and, but it would also be
acres of parks. So it would be a full budget thing,
not just for public safety with the metrics. And then the other thing that I
think that we need to work to provide for our residents is
clarity and kind of, Making it simple,
and I really liked how we had the budget in brief. I think
we should always create a budget in brief, and it should be prepared
and presented the same time that the preliminary budget
is presented, and it should be no more than like ten pages. It should
list out the capital projects. It should list out all of the
employees that are being you know. Prepared for in the budget and any
like major changes. So I
think the metrics over a 5-year thing, all of those things are in
the budget. Our staff has been adding them to the reports,
but having it required to be presented to
the public, I think is a really good move in reestablishing
trust and helping them understand that we've heard You
made me think of something when you said that, by the way. I think you
have a good idea. When it's presented, so who should
be responsible for it? I think it's probably gonna be part of the report when
they bring the budget to us. Perhaps you need to show us the percent
is really what it needs to come down to. So here's what the current contract
is, here's what the current collected, uh, Property tax is
that was collected. Here's what percentage of the
bands that that is, so that it causes the discussion to have to happen anyway.
But it also gives us some visibility. So I think maybe baking that into the
code probably ought to be there. One of the things that I think when Melissa
was talking, it made me think also: we need to start the practice of evaluating
an end year year after year budget.
We need to be able to compare to our previous years. And if there's a
financial cost of doing that, we need to do it. Because not knowing
how we're spending department by department, and especially
depleted funds, whether or not we're using the budget, we need to know
whether or not we're meeting those goals, we're overspending, we're underspending,
we're under-budgeted for some departments, we're way
over-budgeted for other departments, I think is part of the budgeting process
to make us better at making those decisions. We need to know that
information, but we also need to be able to compare it with how we're doing
year after year. So I'd like that to be baked in there as well.
I think— sorry, I think that all of them apply
to the budget. I think that the clarity that
we're asking for with public safety is is really important. I'm not sure
if it needs to be 2 completely different sections of code or
if it's another section added on to the end of
it and it's just overreaching budget. I think
separate. I would have, after we work on this,
we move to the next part of what does that financial reporting look
like so it is crystal clear when we put that budget together
that layman can— how often, when does it come,
how are things being paid for? I would propose that we do that as a
second piece of code.
I like it, Evan. And I mean, I want to thank Councilmember Hewish
and Councilmember— I want to call him Councilmember Rich
because Wood— I couldn't think of it. But Councilmember Wood for
their leadership in this. It makes a lot of sense to me,
and especially after the butt-kicking we've been taking, taking in
the public eye for the statements we've made that property
taxes are going to be dedicated to the sheriff's contract. They are in fact going
to be dedicated to that wholly. But I think this helps bring
that transparency that our citizens have been asking for. It also
makes it easier for future councils, for any resident and any staff
member to be able to find it easily because I know the policies and procedures
manual exists. Just out of curiosity, how many of the
council members have a copy of the policies and procedures manual that's current?
How many of you would know where to find it? So that's
at least in my way of thinking one of the reasons
why I think both make sense. I think that The policies and procedures manual
works great for staff. I don't think it works great for the elected officials.
I do have a copy. I don't know if it's the most recent,
but I saved it and I've gone through it on multiple occasions,
but I've been here a little while. And so that's why I asked the question,
not to embarrass anyone, but to just create that transparency.
So I think that it makes a lot of sense for this to land itself
in code. It's really easy for anybody that wants to find it,
who's willing to get into the EMMC, right? And that's
not always easy, but it's certainly available if we're willing to put forward
the effort to find it. And I'm supportive of doing
both strategies as well, and I'm grateful for these 2 council members at my left
that recognize the issue and were proactive about
trying to solve the issue going forward. I think this provides a significant level of
transparency for the citizens And makes it a lot easier on future councils to stay
up with this particular issue.
I'll just— so maybe some
direction. I would just say as a new council member coming in, this is a
very easy policy to digest for someone who has never worked in government before.
For those that have many years of experience,
for someone new coming in, it's, I think, a really digestible
policy. Any feedback for Evan before—
for him to come back before we actually put this into code?
No, I think, I think if you add some accountability metrics and some timing
and some of those things, and if you guys want to work through that and
help him wordsmith it and bring it back to us, I'm okay with that.
I don't know how everybody else feels. I think
this is step one. I think everybody agrees that this should be the first step.
I think a full budget policy is smart that is
done by ordinance. If we can deal with the property tax portion first,
to alliterate to the residents, it'll be
in its own separate account. I think that's item one that needs to be clear.
It cannot be used for anything else but public safety.
Number 2, we need to show how we're coming up with the determination of
whether or not it needs to be revisited. With a property tax increase or
decrease, so that needs to be done when the report comes back to
future councils and even this next year. That the property tax,
excuse me, collected with our contracts that
are going to be drawing from that, what is that percentage? That that's something
that's presented as part of the budget process. And then I think that's
good on the property tax portion of it. I think the language that you have
is actually. Actually great on this one. But I think that there are other aspects
that we've kind of talked about that probably need to be the next portion that
we work on. We need to deal with how we ebb and flow with our
variable revenue and how we determine how
much of that we can give from that variable
revenue. And I'm not talking about restricted funds, I'm talking specifically about sales
tax, whether or not we can afford to give
sales tax to the property tax to be able to make up that extra 15%,
as it might be. And I think policies that are in place
for that, I would find it very strange for a city council
to come in and change something that's actually helping them, frankly.
And I think this creates a level of simplicity
in taking a look at this and being able to eat it in chunks.
But I think one of the things I've heard very most from citizens is it's
not clear how to even determine where it's going.
And I think that ought to be clear. And I'm going to tell you,
I mean, I've been doing this for 2 and a half years and, you know,
4-something years before that. And there are parts of this I'm like,
I think this is where it is. And we have to ask a lot of
questions to get the clarity. I think we need to make it a little simpler
to digest from anybody who wants to to know and have the access
for them to be able to see it truly is going where we say it's
going. Maybe it's not easy for us to explain that because it is a very
complicated accounting metric, but I think our code ought to be able to outline
it. I like what Melissa was saying, it should be able to be broken down
in a way that the public can digest easily to know exactly how
much is going to each of our departments and then how we're performing.
Thank you. Yeah, I would echo that. I think if
there's one consistent message, maybe not everybody,
but I would say the majority, people support our public safety.
And for me to look at my property tax and think that's securing my
safety, 100% of those dollars are going to fund the Sheriff's
Office, that, that's a win. That's very easy to explain for everyone. Do you
have— need any other direction, Evan, or have any questions? I was just— sorry,
go ahead. I wanted to jump in Direction-wise to help,
I think you and I are the only ones I've talked to about this.
I don't remember if I've talked to anyone else. Maybe I did, but we
were kind of spitballing, and I think I was the one that said, "Well,
maybe we do that 10% thing up and down," and you liked it.
But we just used 85 as an example,
so I didn't know if I'm not saying it's not
a good number. I didn't know if the council said. 85 is the number.
So I mean, if we— is that based on a metrics? Is that based
on— I just want to make sure that we're kind of— yeah,
I think I actually did. I do like 85%.
If you set it at 100 and you go to 110,
you've now spent a year over-collecting. And then
what do you do with those funds and how do you appropriate them?
But if you're at 85%, it's seems like it would be very difficult
to get to 100 or drop down to 60. And, you know, wherever we
end up landing in our, in our later session tonight, I think 85% is
a reasonable coverage ratio. You wouldn't be supplementing too
much with sales tax year to year.
Yeah, I would tend to agree with that, Councilmember Hewish. And I, I just,
for the, just for the general public
to kind of get a sense of this. This is a shift in policy,
and I want that to be very clear. And it's a shift in policy
that we as a council have kind of said we think
this is a better way to govern. And we know we've been
beat up because of it, but I still truly believe that. I believe that
funding our public safety needs, at least the majority
of it, through property tax revenue is is it
the most stable and reliable source of
income that we have as a city, and it ensures that we'll be able
to meet those expectations that we have upon ourselves and upon
our citizens. So I just think that that's a really important
part of this puzzle that has perhaps been kicked aside and
removed from the equation. I hope people understand that it is a shift
in policy. The previous policy has been, we'll see whatever sells,
we'll We'll take whatever property tax there is, and then we're going to take funds
from any other source that we can gather it, and we're just going to deal
with the growth in public safety, and we'll figure the rest out.
We want to be more proactive and deliberative in the
results that we're producing, and I know that that's painful. And so I
just want that out there for people to hear. I also
think that we've talked about a lot of really important puzzle pieces. We talked
about the staffing study and getting that kind of an index and understanding
where we rank with other cities. We've talked about earmarking
funds very specifically and clearly making it designated
for public safety. We've talked about accountability. We've talked
about simplicity and helping our residents know what's going on. And I
think— Thank you. There's always
room for improvement, and I definitely think that this— we're headed in the
right direction. So thanks, you guys, for working on it.
I just want to share my appreciation to the, the council for,
uh, your feedback and your direction on this. I think, uh,
where I kind of missed on this was I was really focused on the,
the creation and the implementation part of it, and I heard from all of you
about the need for it to be transparent and something that can be easily seen
by the public, and that's where the code comes
really in the front of mind. So I
understand that, and I think that's— it makes a lot of sense.
So I'll take what feedback you've gotten, and we'll make some tweaks.
Thank you. And just real quick on that one, you're good, Evan.
I just wanted to make sure Kimberly, I know you had some thoughts. That's why
I checked online if she's available.
Does that— do you feel like that direction— I feel
like you're the one that's going to have to implement this. So do you have
any input? Is that fair? No,
I just want to reiterate that, you know, as staff, always we are—
you know, our goal is to identify these policies and the things that the
council wants and to find a way to bring that forward. So again, the things
that we do are to make it clearer and better for you guys to do
the job that you've been elected to do. And so I'll
continue to work with just Evan offline as he continues
to flesh that out, and we'll
continue to make efforts to improve that clarity
and make sure that our residents
as well as the council can answer some easy, you know, questions that should maybe
be easy for you to be able to identify in our processes.
Okay, perfect. Thank you. We've got a lot to
get through and not a lot of time, so I hope— I know there's
at least a couple more discussions that we want to have before we break out
for a closed session. There are a couple of items that Marcus can update
as well, and I think So next item was an opportunity
for the city manager to fill us in on— I
just appreciate the mayor and the staff for covering while I was out last week.
And I know a lot of— obviously from the work session, a lot of good
things and good ideas were implemented in my absence. And a
lot of good things happened in general in the
community. I know it's been a painful week, and I just want to express my
appreciation. To the council for the leadership that you're— the example
that you're creating for our entire community. And I just want to stress
the importance of having civility. It's okay to disagree. It's not
okay to be disagreeable to the— and especially to the extent that
it becomes personal. And I think every single—
there's not an elected leader I've worked with over my entire
career that doesn't get into it because they want to make their
community better and they love their community. And they might see things
differently, they might see different directions
on how things should proceed, but the commonality between every single one
of them is that they love their community. And I know that you love your
community and you want to see what's best for it. And I just want to
stress that to our residents. You both All
right, thanks. As we go through this, I just wanted to touch
on some things to make sure that— I think this is an easier time than
later. When we come to the public comment, I think I've talked to a lot
of people throughout the week, but leaving the public comment
open— I know right now we're going to try to have a discussion on some
of the items in our next meeting, but that we save
or leave open the public comment for some of those items that I think
that people might be here to speak about. It's something that we've done in the
past. I just wanted to make sure if there's any hesitation that we talk about
it now. You okay with that? Yeah. Okay,
we'll handle that when we get to it. The consent
agenda item 9A, the towns at Briley Farms into warranty.
Just stop me if there's a question. 10A is a Transportation
Interlocal meeting minutes. Yeah, I got an item
on that one. I believe that Council Member Lance— Wadman.
Wadman was in attendance at that meeting, but it's not noted in the minutes.
It was. It's all right, Lacey fixed
that already. Okay, um,
let's see, then the regular— I just have a quick question about that one.
I mean, there was pretty robust conversation I
wouldn't say that it was all positive. The reading through the
minutes in that one, it felt like we just basically just get a good— gave
an overlay of topics discussed
instead of what was discussed. Is that the intent of this one? I think typically
we've done— that's kind of what that does in the recordings. Because I
think it would be important to maybe at least note that
we weren't All on the same page with that, which is why
we're going to have to have further meetings to discuss some of
the the way that things are lined up. And I think
if I was a resident going and reading that, I don't think I would gain
any further insight as to what took place in that meeting. It would seem like
here's the bullet points of topics that were discussed, but not
actually what was discussed and what were the actions. So maybe it
doesn't need to be changed for this one, but I would. I would like to
ask in the future when we're having those meetings, context matters.
In that particular instance about why we're meeting together, I don't think it's clear
if I was a resident reading that why we met.
I think it's fair to say, Stephanie, are you the one that did those?
It's fair to say to make a star notation that, hey, this was a
robust conversation and for full context, look at the
recording and that there, wasn't necessarily consensus.
Is that fair? I think we can make that note and add that to the
record. Is it kind of throughout, let her use judgment on that, or is it
more— I think she knows, she's listened to it. I mean, okay,
if you're satisfied, then any other changes on that one?
Can we just say changes as noted in the work session in the motion?
Okay. The August
6th Truth in Taxation. I had one for the August
4th. Oh, sorry. Yeah,
so just, I think on the, on the, uh,
motion for that one, it was for the youth
mayor and youth council that they were going to be in their positions
until the next youth council election in 2027, but we didn't specify this specific
month. The minutes noted the month of May, but I think
we just— the motion was just until the next election. We didn't know exactly when
that election would be, whether it's May or June. So I think
just, yeah, that would note. And I, on that one,
because it is kind of a, the policy, I just wanna make sure, is that
the consensus of the council that that was the intent of that motion? Yes.
Okay, it sounded like that was the intent. So if we can also correct that
it's until the next election's been held,
then they'd hold their office.
Marcus, there's no issue with that in our code, right? Does the code specify different?
I think we asked that question in the meeting. So the code— sorry,
I'm multitasking here. Yeah, I think the code did not specify
the, the terms expiration. It didn't necessarily specify the
exact end council. Yeah, I think it was a little ambiguous there. And so we
just, in the motion, that's why I motioned that it would just— that they would
be in their position until the next youth council election in the year 2027.
Yeah, I think that's what's intended, but we can clarify that.
Okay, so we'll correct that one as well. Is that it on the 4th?
Okay, and then August 6th, the Truth in Taxation.
Any corrections there? The special meeting
or special session on August 10th.
The next one's a resolution of Eagle Mountain awarding a bid
for the 6 million gallon Wastewater treatment facility.
We do have Mac here and Russell,
our general contractor, for any questions.
I suspect— I would really love for him to do a presentation in
the policy session. Our residents need to hear this presentation.
I think a lack of understanding of why we have to do these
things and just understanding the basic things of how many gallons
per day are processed And that we're getting close, and that's
why we have to make these steps. The better information we can give to them,
the more educated they become, and the more they become part of the team,
so they understand why these things have to take place. So my preference
is that we make sure that they hear the presentation.
So is there any questions? And if not, then do
we want to just do? I think I'd prefer we do
the presentation before we motion to the to the. Consent agenda,
and we could leave it on there. Do we need to move it around?
Wouldn't it just be easier to pull it off, Mayor? Well, that's—I think
it would be smart to pull it off. This is something they need to hear.
We can do that, but this is for GMP two, which is the current upgrade
of the existing plant. Yes. So that's going to be what the presentation's on.
I'm going to need you to tell us about the load because
that's really important. I think which part of it—the main part of it, Mac—is.
I just think that the people need to understand what it is. Okay. Like if
they look at the description, a lot of people aren't going to be able to
digest what that actually is. But in simple terms, why we have to do it,
I think the basic explanation that's in the staff report is good.
Okay. But they need to be able to hear that. If we put it in
a consent agenda, nobody even sees it, hears it, or understands why we're even doing
it. And there's a cost associated with that. Yeah, big one. Yeah.
So yeah, the, the presentation that we have is a high level to give that
kind kind of a more of a general understanding. So perfect. And you
have that presentation? I'm one person. Does anybody else agree or
disagree with that? OK, I would suggest we pull that off the
consent agenda and put it on the policy. And is there, besides just the presentation
for more informational basis, is there any other questions that need fixed
or is it kind of informational? Yeah. OK.
Mayor, was that— oh, sorry, sorry, we're having some
struggling with the streaming, so So we need to pause for just a moment.
Is that okay? And we're going to reset our— just our Civic
Plus on the back end. We're just going to pause and just see if we
can get it streaming again. So if you just hang tight. We're on pause.
Okay. I think we're going to go for it. Looks like it's
Okay. Just a short pause there. It is 5:25.
We're going to keep moving right where we left off.
Which was 11A, and I think we pulled that and we're good there. So we're
to 11B, the resolution accepting the Eagle Mountain fiscal year audited
financial statement. I did get some questions on this.
It had to do with some turnover and different things. It was late, but it's
all done. And I think Kimberly and Ron are
both available with questions, but did anybody else have any
questions for Kimberly?
And Maron is online to do like just kind of an
overview of the financial report.
Did you say you want to do an overview? He— yeah,
he is online. So normally when we have it, then we have the external
auditor is here and they just highlight a
few information and talk about the financial statements. Okay. So he's online
to address that. Let's do it. Is that something
we want to be presented during— No, 'cause it's on the consent
agenda, so I think right now is good. So go ahead, Ron.
All right, thank you. Um, hope everybody can hear me okay, and thanks
for allowing me to be here online. Um, what I'd
like to do is just really quickly go through what we do as auditors,
the conclusions that we came to, and how we came to those conclusions.
So there's 3 areas that we look at. We want to make sure the financial
statements are materially correct, that they meet accounting standards, and those
numbers can be relied upon. We want to make sure internal controls are effective,
that they're designed, implemented, and effectively working.
And we want to make sure you're in compliance with state law based on the
areas we looked at during that fiscal year. As far as the financial
statements go, we want to make sure that they're materially correct.
In our opinion paragraph, it says,
in our opinion, the financial statements referred to above present fairly in
all material respects the respective financial position of the governmental activities,
business-type activities, each major fund, and the aggregate remaining fund information
of the city as of June 30th, 2025, and the respective changes in financial
position where applicable, cash flows there for the year then
ended, in accordance with accounting principles generally accepted in the United States of America.
That's considered an unmodified opinion, a clean opinion, or the
best opinion that you can receive. So how we came to that conclusion,
we take the trial balance of the city and then we perform a number of
tests on those balances.
We look at the trial balance, we review it to make sure it's accurate,
that it's accurate,
clerically accurate. We send out a lot of confirmations. So we'll
send out confirmations to banks. confirming cash.
County for property taxes, State Tax Commission for
sales tax and other taxes ran through their department.
We look— we send confirmations to URS for retirement services
and pension obligations. And then other
confirmations for debt and things that we
feel are necessary. We do a lot of review of invoices.
So at the beginning of the audit, we'll pull a sample of invoices. We'll look
through those to make sure that they're appropriately approved, that it's— the
check matches the invoice, that it's posted the proper period,
and posted to the proper GL account.
We do that at the beginning of the audit. Now we just randomly pull a
sample of invoices and check those items.
We do it throughout the course of the audit when we're looking at capital
assets, We pull a number of invoices after the end of the year to make
sure that the expense was recorded in the proper period.
So we'll pull a number of invoices in July and August to make sure
that those expenses that were in June were actually recorded in June.
We do a lot of recalculation of balances as far as accrued
payroll, depreciation expense, compensated absences,
accrued interest. pension allocations,
and we'll go back and make sure that those calculations meet accounting standards and they're
appropriate for the financial statements. And then we do a lot of analytical reviews.
We'll look at this year compared to last year, create expectations,
and then measure the results against those expectations.
If there are differences, then we start to inquire and perform procedures to make sure
we can understand the differences and what happened throughout the year. We do that at
the beginning of the audit. We also do that as we're doing individual balance testing.
And then we look at that at the end of the audit as well,
so that we can make sure that we can understand what happened as, as we
look at the financial statements on a high level. There's a lot of other
tests and procedures that we perform on the financial statements to make
sure that they do meet accounting standards and can be relied upon.
Second thing we do is we look at internal controls. We don't necessarily
give an opinion on controls. We do evaluate those controls to make
sure that they are designed, implemented, and working effectively. And we do
that through interviews, walkthroughs, questionnaires.
We, as I mentioned, we sample those invoices and we'll
walk those invoices through the process to make sure that they go
from the source document all the way to the financial statements and those and controls
are being followed. As we did do our evaluation
of internal controls, there's one finding that we felt we
needed to bring to your attention. As we were
reconciling, or as we were going through our procedures, we noted that certain
reconciliations were not happening on a timely basis.
We feel the cause of that was due to an untimely turnover in the
finance department, which created delays. improper recording and reconciling of those accounts,
and the complexity of maintaining those assets on a worksheet rather than
an asset management software system. The recommendation
is that we, the city, put in procedures to ensure that those capital
assets are recorded properly and that
the general— and then they're reconciled to the general ledger and depreciation schedules.
And then we also recommend that the city look into an asset management
system rather than a spreadsheet.
So the third thing that we do is we look at state compliance.
So this year we look at— we looked at budgetary
compliance, fund balance, restricted taxes,
fraud risk assessment, government fees, cash management,
and enterprise fund transfers.
What happens is the State Auditor gives us certain procedures to perform. We look
at those procedures and follow those guidelines to see if you're
in compliance with state law. During our review and testing,
there were 2 areas where we felt that there were findings.
One is the fund balance. The state requires that fund
balance cannot be more than 35% of the general fund revenues.
In the city, we did exceed that. The caveat
is that in the state code, it includes
unrestricted or unassigned fund balance and committed fund balance,
where you do have significant amount of that money
has been committed for streetlights. So that does play a
little bit of a factor in there. The second finding
was every 6 months, the state requires that
we submit a deposit investment report. And we noticed that there were some
inaccuracies on that report. I know that those have been addressed
and they're making those changes as we speak to get those in line.
I know you're busy and that was a really quick review of the financial statements.
I do feel like it's worthy to note that
as you look and review the financial statements, it can appear that there's a lot
of revenues in excess of expenses. Of expenses, but it's
good to note that of of the sixty-six million that we're showing in a change
in net position, forty-six million of that was due from assets
that were contributed to the city by developers: roads, streets,
infrastruc water infrastructure, sewer,
those types of things. In addition to that, almost eighteen million
dollars was spent on. projects within your city,
capital asset projects. So I think that's worthy
to note that those funds were contributed by outside parties
and not necessarily spent by the city. And then the other was spent
by the city and for capital improvements. That's really kind
of a quick review of what we did as auditors, our conclusions, and happy
to answer any questions.
The one, uh, the one, uh, statement that you said you felt
like that, uh, we need to have an asset management, uh,
software— what have you had good experiences with? We'd love to hear some suggestions of
what you think is working in other places. Well, I think you've got, um,
inside of your own system, uh, Springbrook, which is
your accounting system now, you do have that ability. It's a new module and
it may have to be an upgrade. But your current software does have the ability
to do that, so that's where I would look first.
There's other ones out there. Most of them that I have seen are connected
to the accounting system that they have. So whether that is Cassel or
Plorus or other ones like that, that's embedded inside their accounting system already.
So doing an upgrade would solve this problem? Yep. And then
it's just a matter of putting those assets in there and maintaining them that way.
Yes. Okay, thank you. I have a quick question too. When you
were talking about the state compliance and the findings, you said some
sort of report was required every 6 months and that kind of like tapered off.
Can you say it clearer for me? Yes,
so every 6 months, uh, the city is required to submit a deposit
investment report, which just basically shows what cash,
um, is in cash and investments the city has on hand at those
And as we noted there, as we went through our reporting, there was some
duplicates, and I think the system had added some things that
made it look like there was more cash in the city than there really was.
And I think staff and Kimberly has identified those issues
and is working with state to get a new report up there.
Thank you. If I can just add,
Mayor, one thing to just help the council kind of understand too.
The purpose of the deposit and investment report for the state
is that we're only allowed to hold our funds with certain
banking or financial institutions that have been approved by
the state of Utah. And so this report
is where we're identifying where the money is sitting, which financial institution
is holding how much money that we have
so that the state can ensure That
we're using certified holders and certified investors with our funds.
Okay. Any other questions on that item?
We will move on.
Now, some of this I was a little bit more worried about getting through,
at least I wanted to try to, but with our public comment and stuff going
on later, I think we— I'm not as rushed. So is there the
scheduled items, is there a specific item that you guys would like to talk about
in this setting? I can go straight through them,
but I wanna make sure that we have the opportunity to have a discussion.
Just one question on maybe 12A. Is the
intent for this to be Going forward with the naming of streets,
we're not intending to go and change where this doesn't apply,
are we? It's so that like ranches and spring water— I understand that,
'cause my neighborhood's full of this problem.
Moving forward. Moving forward. Yep. Thanks. So can I also ask,
so you have basically 2 agenda items on this, 12A, 12B,
but the red lines conflict on paragraph
K. If you go to page 5 of each
of those red lines, paragraph K, one of them is not crossed
out and one of them is. And I don't know if that was intentional.
I struggle with the same thing. I'm filling in for Dave here, but I think
he did it on purpose. OK. Because I was about to ask you to table
it, but I'm on— this is where I'm at now.
I think he did it on purpose, because I think the preliminary
plat section is establishes that we
don't want— we want names to continue across
intersections. So he didn't feel the need to carry it on
to the final plat. So that's
where I think he landed.
Is this something that we in the future want to go and rectify,
or is it just too much— that creates too much chaos to change street
names after they've already been established? That— I think it would be good to do
it. Uh, do we have to do that through a plat
process to check? We don't have to go through a plat process to change street
names, do we? You go through the addressing. So it's,
um, we don't have to replat things, but we have to go through county,
and there's some other things. There is, like, for Mid Valley, there's,
there's a few we're having to update, but we're not updating plats, just county records.
We have to update the I think we can do that. It's— if we
have to amend plats, that'd be really cumbersome. But I think
that it is something we do want to look at eventually. I don't think it
needs to be done right away. But if the plan is to do that,
and we're going to make that going forward, we probably ought to be consistent everywhere
with it. So maybe just a plan to phase it.
Yeah. What that might look like. I agree.
So I think we've got another 15,
20 minutes, and there's really kind of 2 items that are more
than 2 items, and that's the— well, there's a little bit more.
So if we go in order, the 13A, we talked about both
those. Is, uh, any questions or discussion
needed on this one? I think— and Kimberly's available.
We're all aware. Craig? Oh, not on
me. Not on me. Uh, okay, sorry, you're right.
What about 13B?
Nothing. Any discussion?
I assume we're going to be discussing that when
people are here. I mean, I don't really have any conversation
that I'm And that's why I said in advance of the meeting later.
I think one of the reasons I said that is, uh, I think it was
Councilmember Hewish and I were talking, and if we were not going to allow
for public comment to be extended, then I think the conversation now
would help people in the public comment period understand the thoughts of the council.
If we're going to extend that, I think we can have the conversation and then
help the public at that point. So I'm good with that
if that's Yes, if we want to hold. Okay. The annual
13C. Yeah,
I had a couple questions on this actually, but it's going to take me a
second to pull this up. So someone wants to— if someone else
wants to jump in first, I do have a couple questions. Yeah,
if you guys can identify any of your questions, if I can answer them right
now, I will, but otherwise I will make note of them and get
get the answers during the break so that when we get to that item,
we can discuss it in more detail. Yeah,
I, uh, thank you, Kimberly. I, I had
a couple questions, uh, regarding 2,
2 of the— this is going back to some of our budget
meetings regarding, um, the Cory
Bee Ride parking expense and Pony Express
Park. I think those 2 projects combined were $2.2
million or $2.5 million.
And my first question is, can the utility sale proceeds pay for those projects,
and can we pull those out of the budget for this year and, and just
use the utility funds that we already have to pay for those?
That's one question I wanted to ask. Can, uh, the council can use
the utility sale proceeds as they see fit to allocate those
towards any project that they would like to.
In regards to,
like, where you said Pony Express Park and Cory Bee Ride Park, did you have
a question about the dollar amount? I'm sorry, I didn't quite write down that first
part. Sorry, no, I'm just pulling up my notes here.
So it was Cory Bee Ride, I think, In the presentation
that we received, I can't remember if it was on April 28th or May 26th,
but there was Cory B. Ride was $1.2 million,
and there was another intended park build-out. I want
to say it was $1.2 million. I'll have to dig into my notes here,
but I more just wanted to make sure that those could be paid for with
the utility sale proceeds and not be allocated into our general
fund budget. If the funds are already there, I think
I'd prefer to use those funds to pay for those projects.
That was my only question.
Maybe if I could just clarify really quickly.
On those projects, you would still budget for the expenditure. It's just the
revenue would be coming from a different source. Correct. Yeah. So they wouldn't be excluded
from the budget. They would still be included. That's right. Sorry. Yes. Yeah. Just how
are we paying for them? I mean, are they impact fee eligible? That's my
question. As a general rule,
we like to ensure that we use the most restricted dollars first
for any project and then And that bleeds out to the
least restrictive dollars. In our case, the least
restricted dollars are the general fund. Your utility
sale funds are also not overly restricted, but there's— they
require council approval. Your most restrictive would be your impact fees,
but we will follow whatever guidance the council would have on that.
Yeah, I found my note. It was the Ranches Trail From
Pony Express Parkway to SR 73, UDOT. It was $1.2 million
was the cost for that. But isn't that— I think that's being funded by— isn't
that coming through a grant from— Yes, the bulk of that is
coming— is being funded at the state level.
And we have a match, but our match is under $100,000
on that. On that one project, yeah, on that trail,
it's, it's funded outside of the city, the bulk of it. Yeah,
it's a MAG project. Awesome. Okay, then it's just that, uh,
I, I think then the only other thing I would have is the Cory Bee
Ride parking lot. Uh, um,
Councilmember Hewitt, that one is a fiscal year 2026 project,
so that one's already been addressed. When we had those capital update
meetings, part of their presentations was kind of giving an update of the status of
the projects for this current year as well.
And that particular one that you mentioned is a current 2026
project. Oh, okay. Finished anyway. Whether or not
it's completed or not, I'd have to defer
to Public Works to follow up on that, but it was funded in 2026.
Okay, if that's been funded, that, that's great. In the presentation
it said additional budget requested fiscal year 2027 budget.
So that, that's what brought confusion for me on both of those projects.
I'll double-check that between, um, now and the break. Thank you.
Yeah, and Kimberly, I just— I, I— a few questions. So I, I see
through these different sections where we have a negative where it says a minute,
like an administrative cost in parentheses.
And so, I'm just curious sort of what that accounting is.
Yeah, so, this is something I will also touch on
during the presentation that we do later today with the public to try
to explain that as well, but when you see the line item that says administrative
costs, what it's referring to is, and what you'll
see is in some of the departments, you'll see it as a negative amount,
and in other departments, you see it as a positive amount. positive number for their
expenditures. So, we have what we would consider service departments,
meaning all of our administrative overhead costs sit within the general fund.
So, I'll use human resources as an example. So, our HR department sits
in the general fund, but human resources is providing services to
all of the departments within the city. And so,
we have a cost allocation method that we use.
In HR, again, as the example,
the costs get shared based on the number of employees
each department has. So, in the general fund,
we're budgeting, here's what it totally costs to operate the HR
budget, but then there's a negative amount moving out,
and it's going to the water fund and the sewer fund and
the utility billing fund and all these different locations.
Because they receive services from the HR department,
and what you're left with is what it would cost roughly
the city to run human resource if we didn't have any of those other departments.
So, that's what those costs,
administrative cost line items are doing, is you're identifying the
services that are being provided and need to be paid for by the recipient
departments. Awesome, thank you. And then when I
look at pages 17 and 18, I see a bunch of links, and I'm just
curious why that is the case.
Pages 17 and 18 of the exhibit,
or— Of the budget, yeah. So if I go down,
let's see, let me scroll down real quick.
Yeah, so like Community Development Administration,
and maybe because that's newer, and then you've got
like Yeah, planning and zoning, for instance,
planning and zoning shows nothing for 2025-2026, but then shows
items for 2027. I'm just curious why we've
got, you know, blank spaces in those various
categories. We did, if I recall correctly,
without having that pulled up right in front of me, but when we moved
the community development related activities activities to the special revenue fund.
We also broke out and created what we call community development
administrative section that
holds— so, for example, like Brandon, and you've
got like your secretaries and things like that, these administrative assistants, they're providing services
within those own divisions. And so that we don't
have to, in payroll, break it out by 10 different GL accounts,
We account for it just in the administration section, and I believe if
you look at that, that's where we put the administrative cost overhead as well,
is in the community development administrative.
But I can pull that up and I'll take a look at it.
One other item under— this
is on page 2 under City Council.
There's in the specific code,
Section 2.15.010 regarding
compensation for City Council. It references— let
me find it here. It talks about a monthly compensation in the
amount of $200 for non-reimbursed incidentals that are necessary to fulfill their
duties, such as local travel, home internet, personal phones. In the
budget, it just specifically says car allowance. I'm wondering if we could update that to
make that line item a little bit more accurate to code.
Yes. Thank you.
And I'm okay if we eliminate that completely from Other council
members may disagree. I made a joke under my breath and said, man,
you're sure lining your pockets with that $200. But it's,
uh, I'm teasing. So any other
questions on budget
item? I think we're good. Moving on to
The Mid-Valley Reinvestment Area.
The Mid-Valley Reinvestment Area. So I think we can kind of lump this in.
We've seen this a lot. I do wanna
just point out that the presentation on this will be for items 14A,
B, and C all at once. And we'll make one motion.
And then if, or sorry,
we'll make one presentation with 3 separate motions, if I say
my words right. On 14C specifically,
just as a note, that one is pending. When we make the motion, if it
was to approve, it would be pending approval of the RDA meeting that we will
have following this meeting. So that motion needs to state pending
specifically for item 3A, which reminds me, I don't know that
there are any, you've seen the RDA agenda?
Just a little bit. Well,
it would be too hard to record. I don't think that's to stop,
go back, and come back, and then because it's noticed for later.
So before I go to that, are we good on the Mid
Valley RDA? Is there any questions or discussion needed?
Then while I'm on that, jumping to the RDA,
is there any questions? specific to that.
Just— and I know I kind of bounced around on that, so are you comfortable
or do you need a second? Good on the RDA? Okay. No questions.
Then I think— I
think the
amendment to the Overland Development Agreement. Any questions or discussion?
I had one note about the MDA on Section 5.4, just wanting
some clarification on that section, but I got to pull it up to remind myself
what that is. Is that Marcus on 5.4
of the MDA?
Overland? Yeah, sorry, what was the question?
5A, he's pulling it up. Yes, Section 5.4
of the MDA. I was just wondering,
let me square out, I got to find it here again real quick.
Section 5.4 of the MDA, yeah, it was— yeah,
let's see. I don't know, let's see,
what was I wondering? There's just an additional sentence added at the beginning of that
paragraph. Yeah, I wonder if I was meaning 5.
Well, I'll look through it. Yeah.
5.3 is the one that got the major rewrite. So I would assume where
most of your questions would be.
But— OK. OK. Just to
maybe read that or be familiar in case that
we have a question later, we'll be prepared on that one. I think that kind
of covers most of the stuff unless there's something I've missed. Anybody know? If not,
we do have a few items that we could talk about. I move the council
adjourn to a closed session for the purpose of discussing— or for the—
sorry, pursuant to Section 552-4-205,
subsection 1 of the Utah Code Annotated. Second.
Okay, we have a motion and a second, and we'll start the vote with Councilmember
Whiting. Yes. Councilmember Wood? Yes. Councilmember Hewish?
Yes. Councilmember Clark? Yes. And Councilmember Wright? Yes.
All right, we'll adjourn to closed session at 5:54, and we'll be back at
I do tonight. Uh,
now we're okay. Yes, now we're good. Sorry. Okay, we're gonna get started. Uh,
thanks for your patience, everyone. I really appreciate that. Uh, we're working
on an online, uh, feed, and that
should be up shortly. We'll come with that information. So thank you for being patient.
It is 7:20, and we'll call this meeting to
order. As we get started, I've asked Elba Maria,
one of our long-term, longtime residents, to lead us in the Pledge of Allegiance.
Okay, thank you. I pledge allegiance to
the flag of the United States of America and
to the Republic for which it stands, one nation under
God, indivisible, with liberty and justice for all.
All right, now that we're rolling, uh, we're going to start with some public
comment. Um, actually, one thing that I had forgot earlier is just
upcoming events, man. Thank you, Mayor. Um, we do have several upcoming
events. Our food truck rally is Thursday, August 20th at 6:00
PM at Cory Ride Memorial Park featuring storytime. All ages are
welcome. Storytime will have 2 sessions at 6:30 and at 7:30 PM.
There's a movie in the park Friday, August 21st, from 9 to 11 PM
at Silver Lake featuring Top Gun.
There's farmers market every Saturday from 9 AM to 1 PM through
October 10th at Corey Ride Memorial Park. Senior game night
is Monday, August 24th at 5 PM at the Eagle Mountain Senior Center.
In-person Utah Valley Job Fair, Tuesday, August 25th,
from 2 to 5 PM at the Utah Valley Convention Center.
Produce Swap is an event at— on Tuesday,
August 25th, and Wednesday, August 26th, from 11
AM to 7:30 PM at the library.
Our Youth Career Exploration event is Wednesday, August 26th,
from 1 to 3 PM at the Chamber of Commerce.
America 250 Pop-Up Museum is Wednesday, September 2nd,
from 4 to 8 PM at Cedar Valley High School. And I'd like to turn
some time over to Natalie Winterton to talk a little bit about our Citizens Academy
coming up.
Good evening, Mayor, Council, and community. I'm excited
to announce that we just opened our signups for our Eagle Mountain Academy
Fall 2026 cohort today.
Um, so this is our 4th time running this class, and it's been a really
fun and exciting experience for everyone involved,
both staff and residents. It's a
6-week interactive course where residents can come learn about
the city from our department heads, and they get to tour all the city
facilities, even the ones you don't usually see, like our wastewater
treatment plant. Um, it's really fun to come and
to get to know your neighbors and also get to know your city. The class
is free for all participants, and if you can't make it, we do run
it twice a year, and you can sign up for notifications for the next one.
Thank you. Thank you, Natalie. This is our,
our 4th time going through this. Our residents that have participated have
really loved this opportunity to get to know all the ins and outs of
the services that the city provides each and every day to make life possible here
in Eagle Mountain City. And lastly, there's one other event. Our Shop Fest is
September 12th from 9:00 AM to 5:00 PM. At Cory Ride Memorial Park,
there will be hot air balloons at 8:00 AM as well. So we invite the
community to come out. Okay, thank you. Yeah, and I'll
second that. The, uh, that Citizens Academy, people that have gone through
that end up serving on boards or,
uh, planning commission. They come out with a whole new perspective.
And absolutely, I don't think I've heard a negative thing. It's a, it's a
great opportunity to kind of get a little deeper dive into inner workings of the
city. So. Come and participate in that. It is super fun.
Uh, now we're going to move to our public comment section. This,
this time has been set aside for public comment. As a reminder, the public
comment is an opportunity for community members to address the city council, and each speaker
is allowed up to 3 minutes. If you wish to speak
during the public hearing portion, please complete the comment form that's
located in the back and return it to the city recorder.
Council members will listen, but not engage in discussion during public
comment. We ask that everyone remain respectful.
Disruptive behavior— I swear I've learned to talk once— disruptive behavior,
including cheering, booing, clapping, or comments directed
at individual city employees is not permitted. Please refrain from
doing that. Um, if you have
issues or questions regarding staff or personnel, administrative staff
will meet you in the foyer and have a further discussion. Lastly, public comment
period is for items not associated with a scheduled
public hearing. If your comment relates to a public hearing item, please wait until that
item is called. For your information, the public hearing items
on the agenda are item 12A, which is the ordinance of Eagle Mountain
City, Utah, amending the municipal code 16 Uh,
20.040, preliminary plats
regarding street names. Uh, 12B, which is
an ordinance of Eagle Mountain, Utah, amending Eagle Mountain Municipal Code 1625-040,
final plats. And then also 13C is
a public hearing, which is the resolution of Eagle Mountain City, Utah, adopting the fiscal
year '26-'27 annual budget totaling $363,992.
Uh, So, hold on, I got to start
over.
$3,063,992,973.
So, with that, I will open the public comment period. And as I explained
before, if you're here to speak on those other items,
we will give you the opportunity later. So, if it's anything aside from the
public hearings or that truth in taxation portion, Uh,
now is the time. It is 7:27,
and, uh, we will open the public comment time.
Uh, Lacey? Um, I do have one. George Reed.
I came here last time about the speeding
on Ira Hodges. We're done with this. We have talked speed
bumps, we've talked the the Speed Ranch. I've talked
to the people in our neighborhood, and what we
have come up with is that Russell
and Ira Hodges,
Waddell and Ira Hodges, and Russell and Major
are going to become 3-way stops. That way people
are stopping at different points. There's already a 3-way stop
down at the school. That's the cheapest, easiest,
and best way. The other thing that this helps is there are certain times
of the day for us that live on our lodges that we can't get out
of our driveway because the traffic is just boom, boom, boom.
Stop signs there will put a break in between
cars so that we can at least get out of our driveway.
So, if the city isn't willing to do this, I've talked to
the people in our neighborhood. I just have to go home and hit the send
button, and I have 6 stop signs ready to
be ordered, and I will personally install them. So the city
doesn't have to do anything to accommodate
us on this, and the people in our neighborhood are fully behind
this proposition. Thank you.
I also have Joy Rasmussen for
a public comment.
My name is Joy Rasmussen. In 2018,
there were large swaths of undeveloped greenbelt land in Eagle
Mountain that have now been converted into massive hyperscale data
center campuses, beginning with Meta's Eagle Mountain data center in 2018.
and expanding with multi-hundred-acre projects by QTS,
Tract, and Google. A Meta campus started on
roughly 500 acres of open greenbelt land south of city center.
QTS, 193 acres. Tract,
over 668 acres that have been purchased in Eagle Mountain.
I have been messaged by an electrician who's helping build the QTS
data centers. He said they are an enormous problem, and I'm frankly
so very surprised there's not more people in Eagle Mountain, Saratoga that are pissed about
it. I can't say too much about them because of legality, but we currently have
3 up and they're working on the building the 4th and plan to do a
lot more. And they will 100% suck the power and water as they run off
both. And the people that live here are going to feel it within a few
years. He said, thought this might interest you. Eagle Mountain is going to be screwed
in a few years once these are up. And again, I'm surprised there are not
more upset people about it. He later messaged me and said, I thought I'd let
you know I found out today that these data centers are for Google and Meta,
and they may currently have permits or approval for building 9 to 12 of them,
but the plan is around 25. To 27. On August
6th, somebody who works building these data centers stood before you and said that
QTS has said that when they're done with Eagle Mountain, it will be the largest
data center campus in the world for their company.
I recently spoke this week, coincidentally, just for something totally unrelated from
my job, to Robert Bergman. He has been working in AI
since the '60s. I didn't know it existed in the '60s, but it did.
He worked for Intel. He's got lots of degrees. He's really smart. He said
to me that data centers are going to be obsolete really soon, and cities
are going to be stuck with these big empty buildings that won't be getting used
because the technology won't— it won't be necessary anymore. And he
wrote an article called Systems View of AI Governance,
and he talked about how the laws are not going to catch up with the
technology. And by the time we realize we need the laws, something bad will have
happened with the technology. He talked about the energy bottleneck.
The major AI companies have responded by becoming energy companies of sort. They're contracting
for dedicated gas plants, batteries, And even nuclear reactors. That buys
capacity, but on the timescale of power infrastructure, which is measured in years,
not product cycle. He said the mathematics
of scaling is unforgiving. Each doubling of compute yields a smaller improvement
than the last. Training runs for frontier models are projected to cost
several billion dollars each, and those costs must eventually be recovered— 30 seconds remaining.
From customers. So I'm asking you to pass a moratorium on
approving any more data centers. Please make a resolution. The citizens
are not wanting any more of these. We've got enough. Let's let them
give us the benefits we've been promised they're going to give the community, the ones
that are already approved. I know we can't change that, but I'm asking you to
stop and pause because we've already lost so many acres. And according to that professor,
I think it's Utah State, the heat— it's going to rise the heat of the
land around it and the water, and that's going to affect wildlife, the environment,
and people. Farmers have been driven out. Your time's up. Thank you.
Thank you.
I'm unsure if this is for the budget or public comment for Adam Bradley.
Okay, thank you. If you want to wait
for 13, I'm okay with that. Thank you. How about Marco Zamorano?
And then also Tiffany Walden. Wasn't sure.
Tonight, tonight I want to talk about the city's plans
to expand the police force by renting additional officers
from Utah County. While I'm very appreciative to Sheriff Knudson
and his deputies, I think it's time for the city to stop spinning in
circles and actually start its own police department.
It should have been done years ago, and if it's not done now,
it may turn out to be impossible later. Here's why.
The city doesn't have a justice court. Why not? Not enough
crime statistics to support it. Why aren't enough
crime statistics? Because the city hasn't entered its misdemeanors
into a system so that the sheriff can issue citations.
Further, if the If the sheriff wants to arrest somebody,
it needs to be for something pretty awful because it takes officers
off the street in Eagle Mountain to drive to Spanish Fork
to put a person in jail because the city doesn't have a jail. And so
then the city doesn't get the revenue from the citations
and the misdemeanors. And there we go around and around and around.
It's time to get off the merry-go-round and start your own police department.
Thank you. Eventually, that will serve the citizens better, and it's a more responsible
solution. To that end, the council is ready
to be a good fiduciary to the citizens. I am prepared to donate the land
to build a county jail or a city jail. Thank you.
That's all I have for regular public comment.
Yeah, uh, just to be sure, is there anybody else that has something aside
from what we've mentioned that, that does not feel like they had the opportunity to
speak at this time? We will not come back to general public
comment. It will be only specific to the items we're talking about. So seeing no
one, we appreciate that. We will hold the public comment for the other items coming
up. So we'll just, uh, suspend that time for now.
Um, we will now bring it back to the, the city council
for some comments. And we'll
start with Councilmember Clark.
Um, thank you all for being here tonight. I want to start with a few
of the messages that have been directed at us during this process. String them up,
make their families watch. All these local government people feel
safe. They shouldn't. They live right next to us. I can see a
future where they're dragged out of their homes and beaten in front of their families.
White woman tears need to be punished by death.
Every city council should be dragged from their seats and
hanged in the public square, then hang their families for
their treasonous asses. F them all. You know
you don't have to wait until the next election, right? Our hands fit so easily
around their throats. Drag them out. While these comments
and messages are extremely disturbing and violent, I don't
care about these people on the internet. I care about the people
of Eagle Mountain. I always have and I always will.
And yes, sometimes that means I get choked up and I cry. Why?
Because I care. And I get that these decisions that we make have an impact
on real people. I care about the family of 8 that has cut nearly everything
from their budget. I care about the families managing type
1 diabetes, seniors on fixed incomes, people working second
jobs, and parents whose adult children have to move back home.
Those are the people that I care about. At the
same time, I'm incredibly grateful for those at the state level,
like Representative Grecious and Senator Balderry,
who have reached out to offer solutions and ideas. I'm grateful to
those who have called me and simply asked, why? How did we
get here? What can I do to help? If you have an idea that helps
us meet our needs while leaving more money in the pockets of our
residents, I want to hear it. And despite what it feels like,
we have been listening, but that listening started long before the
public hearing on the 6th. Our mayor and
council have spent over 62 hours meeting with residents in neighborhood parks,
HOA clubhouses, plus more than 40 hours at community events.
We've read hundreds of emails and thousands of comments. Residents told
us, build roads, address traffic, make it safer
for our kids to get to school, enforce speeding, take care
of the parks, keep water and sewer ahead of growth. improve city
services at City Hall, and make sure deputies are available when
people need them. Then this year, Chief Knutson told us
calls for service increased by 18.6% in
one year and described our staffing as fragile in a city approaching
80,000 people across 52 square miles.
The Sheriff's Office identified a need for 10 additional positions.
We reduced that to 7 because we are already trying to balance that
need With affordability. And then the residents told
us something else. The residents said, we understand
there's a need, but we can't afford this. We heard that too.
There have been concerns that we haven't been transparent.
We are imperfect people. None of this current
mayor and council have ever been through truth and taxation before.
We should have communicated some things better,
but our budgets, audits, agendas,
contracts, and spending decisions are public.
Every decision about city money is made in a public meeting.
What I have learned is that making information public isn't enough
if it's difficult for residents to find or understand.
We need to do better there. I also want to address
the claim that we chose data centers over residents. We didn't.
Data centers have always been a means to an end, a way to bring infrastructure
and a commercial tax base into Eagle Mountain so residents don't have
to carry the entire burden. And tonight
I'm calling on our data centers and our major businesses in Eagle Mountain to step
up too. Eagle Mountain has welcomed you and provided opportunities
for you to build your businesses here. Now we need you to
believe in Eagle Mountain and invest in the people who live
here. We need good partners. Help us build the
community that has helped make your investment possible.
To our residents, I have 2 asks. First, tell us
what matters most. What can wait? We have
more than 100 projects and needs Roads, school safety,
water, sewer, parks, and public safety. If we spend less,
something has to wait. Tell us what you want
us to protect. And my second ask is bigger.
My second ask is take care of each other. I've lived
here nearly 2 decades. I've watched Eagle Mountain show up when basements have flooded,
when homes have burned, when someone's child ended up at Primary
Children's. I've watched neighbors bring meals, fix homes,
watch children give rides, and quietly help people who needed it.
Whatever we decide tonight, there will still be people
struggling tomorrow. So look around, please find
them, help where you can. And as for my
vote, I won't make it because someone threatened me. I won't make
it because somebody praised me. I won't make it based on whether or not it
helps me get elected again. I have to listen to the people of Eagle Mountain,
all of the people of Eagle Mountain. I have to look at the facts in
front of me, understand the consequences, and vote for what I believe is
right for this community as a whole. Whatever happens
tonight, tomorrow will still all be neighbors.
Really? You expect me to follow that, Councilmember Clark?
I didn't, I didn't write the oration that you did, but I will,
but I will, but I will simply say this. I agree 100% with what you
stated. Uh,
I think the biggest regret that I have in this process is that
we did not communicate effectively. I'm a terrible communicator. I can talk to
you one-on-one, but I am not the public face of anything. In fact,
I shun that. It's not, it's not my personality.
And I think that's where we have failed pretty miserably. Let me, let me restate
that. That's where I have failed miserably. Let me take responsibility
for myself and not for others. Um,
I wish I had a do-over and could, and could, uh,
more effectively communicate to more people those things
that we have been dealing with. I think Councilmember Clark just gave you a brief
synopsis of some of the things we've been dealing with. Thank you.
This is not fun. This affects me. It affects my mother.
It affects my sister. It affects my daughter. It affects my son. It affects my
grandchildren who live here in the city. The easiest thing to
say is we're not going to do anything, and the data centers can take
care of all of it at some point in time. But the reality of it
is, I want to make sure that our city grows and prospers, and that
we're meeting today's needs while planning for tomorrow's. Outcomes.
Um, I didn't come to office to do anything but
to see if I couldn't help improve the circumstance that we found ourselves
in. That's it. I don't have any, any goals
beyond that. Um, it was a wrestle for me to want
to even serve a second term. It's not a fun job.
It's not enjoyable. It's a heavy lift.
And, uh, It's weighty. Somebody needs to
do it, and I felt like I had something to contribute. And let me tell
you some of the things that have been accomplished while I have sat here.
We've adjusted residential codes so that the spacing in front of
your houses is wider and larger than it used to be. We've made road
standards wider and bigger than they used to be.
We, we, we have reduced the number of developed
units that were approved by Previous councils who at the time made those decisions.
I'm certain that they were the right decisions in the time frame that they dealt
with, but they couldn't have possibly seen the impact or the outcome that
we are now dealing with today.
I personally have helped to work and reduce the number of units in our
city by several thousand units. I've personally done that.
I'm the one who stood among this council and said This council
in the past counseled and said we cannot continue to sell our water
resources for residential development. And we made that
adjustment. My desire has been to
serve you and to produce outcomes that will benefit
you and me long term. I believe
that a tax increase is necessary.
Perhaps we overshot the mark. I'm going to just say that publicly.
Okay, but I'm going to tell you, no matter where things
land, there are way more needs than
there will be resources to fill them. And I listened
to the gentleman who just spoke about the 3 stop signs, and he's going to
go put them up himself. We shouldn't ever have to get to a place where
that's the only recourse that we have, should we?
And so to hear that is very frustrating to me, not from you, sir.
I don't, I don't blame you. I understand where you're coming from. I've met with
you. And I've seen what you're dealing with. And if you,
if you're aware, I'm the one who stood up in a council meeting in the
budget and said, we need to allocate some resources to put in some speed tables
or some sort of speed calming measures in front of our elementary schools.
But we had to find that money somewhere.
So I hope that you'll give us a little grace.
Challenges. I'm okay with that. Have a difference of opinion. There's no issues
with that whatsoever, but talk to us,
engage us, and engage me. I'm happy to
have a conversation, a phone call, a text, an email. I will engage
with you. Facebook and some of the cesspools that exist in our— in
our— and I'm going to call it just that— our Eagle Mountain Citizens page.
I call it Eagle Mountain Citizens cesspool, and I truly believe that.
Now, Many of you will disagree with that, but for me, it's not a market
that I want to spend a lot of time in because there's so much hate
and vitriol that exists there. And it's not how
I live my life. I want to live my life better than that.
Thank you. I'll just
say ditto to both the comments that have already been made by
Councilmembers Clark and Wright.
And I'll just add just briefly to some other comments. We met with Congressman
Mike Kennedy this last week, a few of us did, and he said something profound
that opened my eyes a bit. You know, he works at the federal level and
confirmed what we already know, that we need to minimize
the amount of money that goes to the federal level. There's so much waste that
happens there. And he said we need to reduce the
money that goes to the federal level. He said, similarly, the state, there's, there's ways
we can improve the efficiency there and
reduce the amount of money that's going to the state. And then here's where he
said the eye-opening remark. But to the cities,
to the cities, you need to make sure that the
taxes are there. That is where the people
will feel it. It goes directly to them.
It builds them. You got to make sure
that the taxes don't lag behind, because then the cities
will fail. That is where the taxes
should be higher, and the federal and the state as low as possible.
This is the money that's being raised to help us,
our city, the future generations that come after us.
This is where the taxes. when there's an increase should
be considered and acknowledged that that is coming as an investment
here. And I realize, like, I've lived many years of
my life in very, very challenging financial circumstances.
I remember coming out of my house one day and my neighbor across the
street was getting in his car and said, hey, where are you
going, Keith? And he said, well, I'm going to Cafe Rio. You want to— you
want to go with me? Back then, the Cafe Rio burrito was like $6.
There's inflation since then, but I couldn't go. I couldn't afford
that. There are times in my life where I skipped meals in order to make
sure there was enough money in the family. I understand what that is.
We're tasked with hearing, and that some have said,
well, that council, you haven't heard us because of various things.
Councilmember Clark just outlined very well the competing voices
that are coming to us from you saying we have, we have
needs for better roads. Uh, better improve public
safety and a whole list of things. All of that costs money.
All of that costs money. Then we're hearing from some residents,
I'm struggling right now financially. There's a balancing act that
we have to do in that. And yes, this is the first— our first time
going through this tax and truth and taxation process.
There are some state laws that regulate how the communications
come out, but in retrospect, we, we, we evaluate and
think, okay, we for sure could have improved. I'm, I'm really,
really proud of the 2 council members. I'm proud of all the council members
here, but the council members to our left, Wood and Hewish, have already
created code to improve the transparency of property
tax dollars in the city. It was discussed in our workshop session,
so it should be coming back to a policy session soon. That's how fast they
acted to improve both the transparency and ensure that the property
tax dollars are indeed 100% going to public safety. And I'm proud of how
fast they acted. Thank you for coming. Thank you for
the numerous residents who have reached out. Every one of you that has emailed me,
you know this, every one of you got an email back. Every single
one of you. I've stayed up really late some nights to make sure everyone got
responded to that reached out to me. And, and I will continue to do those—
that to those who reach out. Thank you for your information,
participation, and your energy in helping improve our city.
I'm grateful you're all here, and I truly mean that.
I think you know that I, I don't shy away from people coming here to
tell us how we can be better. I do have some,
some disappointments in the last couple months. Um,
I love living here, and I, I've told my family a thousand times I have
zero desire to ever leave this area. I love the people here.
I love the community here. I don't think our best foot was forward the last
couple months. We didn't put a very good look
on Eagle Mountain, frankly, and a lot of other people took advantage of that
and made it even worse in the media.
And I'm gonna own part of that. I mean, frankly, we didn't, we didn't
help you to understand better. That's on us.
I'm not even gonna make the excuse that this is our first time around.
We know that we have some communication challenges. And frankly,
I'm gonna tell you, I don't think social media is really cutting it.
There are so many people that are not even utilizing that for their communication,
and even if they do, the algorithm might not even be touching them.
So we want to figure out how
to get the information to you in a way that works.
As Councilmember Whiting mentioned, Councilmember Hewish and I have
been talking about how to bracket and put a good financial
plan in place so that when we're done, the next council can
come in here and we left it better than we, than we found it.
I think that we are— we're close with that first part
of the code, and it will absolutely do exactly what we told you it would
do. It forces it to go to a separate account for
property taxes to be Put for public safety only, and that'll be delineated
in the account. So you have absolute confidence that that money is
only going towards that. The second thing is to know when
property taxes should be even reviewed, and honestly, it probably ought to
be yearly, and that's kind of what we put in there. It's,
it's very easy to point fingers backwards, you know, and I'm
not going to say that I haven't done that because I have. And I don't
know all the reasons that these things weren't done. All I can say is that
now we can't make any excuses for why we don't have financial plans.
It's good governance to have financial plans so that we can plan how we use
the money. We need to have what we do now. We need to have
a 5-year. We need to have a 10-year, and even further down the road,
20-year. Our intent, I can tell you, one of the
reasons that I was so adamant about appointing Mr.
Hewish is because of his financial background, because I believe we need his expertise,
and he has shown that in droves of why he's been
so beneficial. Our intent is to do better,
to make it more transparent, and I— the reality
of it is, is I wish that we would have been doing incremental increases so
we're not sitting facing what we're facing. But I think Councilmember Clark made one
important point. About— you
have to decide what it is you want to cut out. Because the
cost of things are so incredibly high right now. I actually asked one of the
things to be pulled off our consent agenda because I want you to see what
the cost of one single thing for our sewer plant is going to cost.
Because I think it's very easy to not absorb
the cost of everything. When you start taking a look at what each of these
projects cost, We have to leverage small amounts
of money into larger amounts of money by making payments, because we don't have the
income to take care of what our total needs are. If you look at our
total projects, uh, just for roads, I think I mentioned this the
last time, our sole responsibility is $419 million.
The total projects are like $1.5 billion for roads
where we have the state, MAG, and other sources that are
paying for them. That's Eagle Mountain. It's astounding when
you get into this and you find out what everything costs.
That was the, you know, the wall that hit me in the face of what
things are actually costing and what our resources are.
I want to start with that because I think that that's important for you to
share the burden with us as we're trying to evaluate how we solve some of
these problems, because we are really talking about building roads.
We drive on the same crappy traffic that all the rest of you
do. And each one of us live along that way where it's super crappy.
In fact, I, I'm right where it gets really, really crappy in Silver Lake.
And I— there's sometimes we can't even leave the neighborhood because it is lined all
the way back to Hidden Valley.
So I just— I'm asking for a little bit of grace
from you. Understand that there's nobody here that's trying to harm anybody. We're trying
to come up with a solution. I don't know that we found the,
the perfect solution, but we're doing our best to try to find some way to
be able to attack some of these projects that have to get taken care of.
Roads being probably at the very top of that. One of our other problems,
though, and I'm just going to be totally honest with you, we are undermanned.
We do not have enough people to do the projects.
That is one of those— you ask, what would you have done with the extra
money? For me personally, it would have absolutely been bringing
in teams of people for roads and parks to be able to take
care of our assets. That's my personal opinion. I'm not all 5 of
us, but I just think it's important for you to know how we're weighing our
decisions. I want to be truthful with you always. I've always been that way.
You're not always going to like what I say, but I will always tell you
the truth. Thank you for being here. I appreciate it. I'm looking forward to your
comments. I ask that you help us come up with some solutions. Be creative,
because I think we're all in this together. Thanks.
So, there was a shout out that a citizen wanted me to provide, and I'll
keep the citizen's name confidential. But this is a shout out to our Sheriff's Department.
So, the Eagle Mountain Division of the Sheriff Department, specifically Deputy
Craig— no, no relation to me, by the way, but he's
got good names. Yeah, specifically Deputy Craig. Has been
phenomenal in helping us. Will you please give Deputy Craig a shout
out? We absolutely 100% love this guy. He has helped my
family a lot.
Okay, I'll be fast. I first just want to thank
everybody who's reached out to me individually. I've been just going one
by one, two by two, Zoom meetings, phone calls.
I've created a presentation, and one of the first slides
in that presentation—those of you, I'm sorry if you haven't seen the matrix.
It's probably my favorite movie of all time. But, in the beginning of
the movie, the main character, he's given the choice to choose between
taking the blue pill, which he wakes up and he goes
back to his regular life. Nothing changes.
The other pill, the red pill, he takes and he learns that he's actually
not living in reality at all and he gets unplugged from the system and realizes
that society ended 200 years ago.
Serving on city council is like taking the red
pill. My eyes have completely been opened. I've been
learning about government accounting, finances,
how things work and operate, that we don't have a cell tower in our city.
We had a visitor here, billion-dollar investor
looking to come to Eagle Mountain that we're aggressively recruiting commercial. And he's
like, oh, I don't have any cell service here. And I'm like, yeah, that's not,
not great. Um, but okay. Uh,
I just, I want to just extend appreciation. There's a few
people here today that I've met with in a 1-on-1, and I'm grateful to
have all of you. So, while I have you now, I probably won't
post this on Facebook because everything just gets distorted and
the comments get crazy. I prefer just a 1-on-1. I'm— Much
like Brett. Okay. Um, so one of the pieces,
and there will probably be 4 or 5 more things that I think we could
do to improve this process, is as a city council, when you come in
brand new, uh, you, you have some presentations.
We, we had one from the, from, uh, Chief Knutson
that says we need more sheriffs. And, uh, what do I know? I'm a financial
planner. I don't know how many sheriffs we need. And, and so you try to
dig into the data as good as you can. Yeah.
And what we have strived, or at least started to work toward,
is having some kind of safety net for our sheriff's contract,
and maybe one day a police department. That,
that's a really interesting idea to have land to build our own jail.
But the goal of this code that we're putting in place
is to require a council each year to look
at the coverage ratio of our property taxes. So when you pay a property
tax, Number 1, there will be a dedicated segregated
fund that those dollars cannot be commingled with sales tax.
So when you look at your city property tax that you pay,
every dollar goes directly to our safety.
If the coverage ratio target is in this code, it'll be 85%.
That'll be the target. We may not get there this year. I don't know.
We'll have to to see where we, where we land this evening. There will
be an upper band. If the coverage ratio is above 95%,
then a city council could consider cutting taxes.
If it's below the lower band, the city council could consider increasing
taxes. But the goal is that each year city councils are
looking at this coverage ratio so we don't get in a position where we're
behind and new revenue coming in is subsidizing those
contracts. As data centers complete
their projects and those properties have values and can be assessed
a property tax, that obviously is going to increase the property tax number.
So that, that's one of the directions that we're heading.
Another one that we're talking about is having just
a very simple, straightforward budget that residents could easily flip
through and say, okay, I understand what our city budget is. Going through
100 pages of documents. I went to our city website over the
weekend and I spent a few hours. I just said, Zach, pretend like you don't
know anything and you're just reading our city budget and you see a
$50 million transaction. Well, what is that? Well, we have
a sewer project that we're working on, and there's transfers of funds that
by state law are required to go from one account to another account. But if
you don't know anything about Um, the— how government accounting works,
it might look suspicious. You know, you hear $363
million. Well, that's plenty of money to do whatever you need to do. Um,
but really, we have some big major projects. We have a couple wells
that are being built this next year to create water infrastructure.
We have a sewer, uh, that, that's being built to create more infrastructure
and lots of road projects. So, um,
I would just say, If you'd like to meet individually
with me, I'd love to visit with you. I welcome that opportunity. I know it's
not the most convenient thing in the world to establish that time, but I welcome
that and appreciate everyone being here tonight.
Thank you. All right, I'll just add a
couple of real quick comments, and it's maybe a little different direction for
educational purposes. I was going to do this
the opposite, but as I think about it, I'm going to, I'm going to switch
my order. There is no one I would rather be in the trenches with than
these guys. And trust me, if you think any
one of us haven't had a battle, I think we had one today. And I'm
not afraid to say it because we— I can still say that he's one of
my best friends. We don't have to agree, but we can respect each other and,
and try to come to a conclusion. I know we've
had our battles. Every one of us up here have disagreed, and man,
we have to just Fight through that. And there isn't— it
even took a couple days to cool down after one of them. One.
Yeah. I didn't tell him we battle every day. The rest of
them is just one. It's, uh, it's— and there's
no one I'd rather do this with. Now, switching gears,
my, my role is a little bit different. Uh,
I get asked to go out and get information.
It doesn't matter what I think. I have to get the information.
That's one of the reasons I try to get out in front of this and
give people information. It's not my stance, it's information. I'm trying to give you some
facts, uh, and then I have to come back and give these guys the information,
and they got to make the decision. I don't get to say where this lands.
I have dang sure tried to influence the best I could, but I
don't get to make this decision. It's my job once the decision is made to
then Carry it out whether I agree or not. I get to carry that out.
So what I can tell you is,
do we all agree? Nope. Are we going to battle it out?
Yep. And then I'm going to carry it out no matter if I agree with
it or not. And so that, that's, that's something that I just wanted, that I
was thinking about, that I, that I would add to, uh, that. And I'm gonna
leave it at that. The last, the other piece was, uh,
I'm, I'm never afraid of hard conversations.
I love calling the people that hate me. And trust me,
I do it with a smile. And it's not because I'm trying to pick a
fight. It's because I wanna gain greater understanding and hopefully
shed some light for you. And maybe on the other end, we can be friends
because I'm okay with a disagreement as long as we're not disagreeable, as long as
we do it with respect. And I want to help you understand some
maybe perspective. With that, I'm going to set records straight
when I can. It's not a subjective-objective. These are not
opinions, they're simply facts. So I
don't like it when people aren't informed, and I'm not saying it's malicious,
I'm saying it's not right. I sit in meetings every
single day, and I can tell you, if you want to know
how many times I've met with our data center partners in the last
6 months, but even in the last 2 months, Man, I— a
lot. I'm just going to say that a lot. Um,
if somebody has information about 25
to 40 buildings and QTS, I don't. And I
sit with the people making the decisions, and they haven't even said
that. So whoever's saying that they've got these multiple approvals,
they don't even know that, but they appreciate it because they would love that.
But they have never said that. Also, to continue and
talk about water. They have less water allocated
at QTS than one street of houses. They are not using
water. That is a closed-loop system. You hear us say
that. I'm not going to get into it. If you want information, look me up.
They are not using our drinking water on a daily basis. They use
it for their kitchen and their bathrooms. Happy to have that conversation. Just a fact.
Um, now, Because of some of the smear that goes
on, including on Facebook and others, this is not aimed at any person
or any comment that I'm talking about. I want to shed a little bit of
light on what those people have done just
recently. I, 3 weeks ago,
was, uh, and I'm not gonna say who it was even. I was going
to. I'm not going to say this. I was in a meeting with some of
our employees that said, hey, The next phase of QTS,
they're not asking for any tax breaks. They will
be built next year with no asks,
100% taxpayer day 1. I read in the meeting
on August 6th those numbers. I'm not going to read them again.
Look it up back there. It was $19 million that they
will have in. It takes time for that to come in. That will be a
taxable value next year, 0 break. That's a
good deal. That's what we've been waiting for. Now,
knowing that, as a staff internally,
we're like, hey, we have some needs. Maybe if they would front
some money, we could give them back some, a little bit of tax just
to cover our need, tie it directly to that. Then they're still full taxpayer.
I said, no, I'm not okay with that. And I want you
guys to know what I said. And then I brought it to these guys because
I don't have the power to do that. And I said, I'm gonna make a
phone call. I got on the phone with QTS and I said, hey,
that's crap. I'm not paying for this road. You guys are the ones that are
making it bad. And that intersection over there, you're the ones doing that.
At best, you have to pay for those lights and split the road.
He said, let me call you back. Within a day, he called
me back and said, where do you want the check? And I said, we estimate
it's about $5 million. He said, if it's $5.5 million, we're paying for that road.
And I'm telling you right now, that road's getting built because of QTS,
no strings attached. And the signal? And the signal,
2 signals. 2 signals. So, to sit here and
say these guys suck, I'm not okay with that. I'm not.
So, I will tell you that I'm also continuing
to work with both of our data center partners that are already built and those
that are approved to continue to help us bridge these gaps.
And so we are continually— and they are stepping up. That's my
commitment. So I just won't allow for that
to, to be a narrative that's out there without
saying the other side. Now, what I will allow is you can say you disagree
with that, and that's fine. But the facts are they've given us money and they're
carrying their weight, and they're literally coming in next year not
even asking for a tax break. So I just want to get that out there.
Thank you. And, and I appreciate them, and I'm going to say that I— man,
have I worked my tail off. And now it's— we got
to come back here and figure out what that means. But, uh, we're, we're going
to move forward, and our data center partners are great partners.
So I'm, I'm going to leave it at that, and we're going to move forward.
Um, with that,
we have to get a lot of work done, and we're going to start with
our consent agenda. Um, we had a discussion about all these things in our work
Item 11A, we're gonna— has been asked to be pulled off
and put back on. So, and this— okay,
my other note was just for me. So if there aren't any questions, I'll entertain
a motion. Mayor, I'll make the motion. Okay.
I move that City Council approve the consent agenda with
the pulling off 11A and putting that back on the policy session.
And then also the conversation we had regarding 10A,
the transportation and local meeting, just creating some context in there so
that it's understood to the citizens what the conversation was. Second.
Can I add to that? And with, with notes to the minutes
being changed per the work session. I'll amend my motion
to include that. Second. Okay,
we have an amended motion by Councilmember Wood and a second by Councilmember
Clark. Uh, are there any questions on the motion? Are we good over there?
Yeah. Okay. Um, Councilmember Clark? Yes. Councilmember Wright?
Yes. Councilmember Whiting? Yes. Councilmember Wood? Yes. Councilmember Hewish?
Yes. Okay, we'll go right to item 11A.
Um, Mr. Mack, and do we still have, uh,
Russell with us as well? Okay, I didn't see you. Sorry. You're welcome
to come forward just to be closer and ready.
Mayor, council, thank you for your time.
Um, we have a brief presentation put together by Russell Sprague to
talk about GMP 2, and we're seeking the approval of
the bid award.
Good. Thank you, Mayor and Council and the
citizens at large. I'm Russell Sprague with A2S Engineers.
We are the engineers designing the wastewater expansion.
Uh, with the 2nd work package on
the agenda tonight, um, Council has requested
that we give an overview of the project.
And kind of where we're headed and what we've done
to date. So many might not know that the city is broken
up into 2 service areas. The line here represents the north and the south service
area. The north area goes to a different
facility, but the south area goes to Eagle Mountain's wastewater facility.
You can see a picture of it there.
Eagle Mountain's growing at a rapid pace. I think everyone knows. One of the fastest
growing cities in Utah and the entire United States.
There's been 16 to 21% growth rates just in
the South Service Area in the last 2 years. It's been estimated Eagle Mountain's responsible
for at least 10% of the state's growth. The growth
is straining the wastewater infrastructure, and with that, if there's an increased
risk of breaking the permit established by Utah Department of Environmental
Quality, Each household contributes between 250 and
400 gallons per day into the wastewater plant. So you can imagine
that adds up pretty fast.
The planned available wastewater treatment
over time with this beige line here represents a 16% growth rate,
which is what we've been seeing the last 2 years at a minimum.
With exponential growth, it's hard to project that over more than
10 to 15 years. Um,
what we're saying is we probably won't see 16% to 20%
every single year. Yeah. But in the near future,
that is definitely a possibility.
Um, so right now, the treatment plant has
a capacity of right under 2 million gallons per day.
And this first expansion is going to bring
the capacity up to 8 million gallons per day. So when we
talk about wastewater projects, we are quadrupling the size of
this plant to maybe catch up to the growth
that we're seeing. And then in
the near future. So just an overview
of wastewater comes in dirty. Headworks is the first filter.
That's where the screens remove grit,
large objects. I always like to joke, your kids' underpants,
they flush down the toilet. That's where that gets captured and taken out.
The biological nutrient removal is what I call a fancy bubble bath for
bacteria. It's big tanks where good bacteria eat bad
bacteria and remove nitrogen, phosphorus. Which is
what— here on the right, it's regulated by the state of Utah. Utah sets strict
limits on what's allowed in the water we return to the environment.
Total nitrogen, total phosphorus,
biochemical oxygen demand, suspended solids, and there's a few others,
but those are the main ones. And the membrane that we're
putting in— water flows through these tiny membranes, and they act
as a superfine strainer, so only clean water can pass through.
Solids are separated throughout that, and they are dewatered
and hauled to a landfill. So that's kind of the overview
of what wastewater treatment does. So right here in
green is the existing plant. So you have your oxidation ditch here,
and the proposed expansion is on the west side. Here we
have a new garage, a new headworks building, the biological nutrient removal
basins, the membrane building. An electrical and chemical building
and a solids building. So it's, you know,
4 buildings and then 1 very,
very, very large basin that we're planning
on building.
So we've gone to the construction manager general contractor
route of delivering this project, which is we've
hired a general contractor in the design phase.
to guarantee us what the maximum price will be.
So if you hard bid something, when you get bids in, you go to the
low bid, and that's the bid. This delivery method, you negotiate upfront
with the contractor what the price will be for the desired scope.
This is beneficial in a lot of ways. You know
the price upfront. Work can begin while design is still happening.
So that's kind of the phased approach we've been talking about. And it
improves schedule certainty because we can phase it in a certain way.
The schedule is kind of at lesser
risk of slipping. So we call it guaranteed maximum
price. The way we've structured it, it's also work authorization.
Those 2 are interchangeable. The advantages,
like I said, early procurement of critical equipment,
flexibility to address evolving project needs, reduced schedule risk,
and easier cost control. So we've identified 6 packages
in this project to accelerate the schedule.
Essentially, GMP 1, we've already approved back
in April. That was the membrane filtration equipment.
GMP 2 is the one on the agenda tonight, and it's the oxidation
ditch capacity and optimization. We're installing
pumps and pipes. SCADA equipment to
increase the oxidation ditch capacity.
GMP 3 is earthwork. GMP 4 is the bulk MBR
expansion. Most of the facilities are in GMP 4.
GMP 5 is the administration building, and GMP 6 is
kind of commissioning. You do asphalt,
you do the garage, and kind of the effluent disposal strategy
at the very end. So you can see the— I think I
have a schedule here. Right, we've already completed
GMP 1. That was awarded in April,
and you can see all of these upgrades are
planned to be finished early 2029 for startup
with a year warranty for everything.
How is expansion funded? Impact fees. So new growth, new connections
pay the majority of it. Survey payers and also city funds
pay for the expansion. A little bit.
So that's kind of an overview of the entire project. GMP 2
on the agenda tonight. Kind of just a
little bit background of that. GMP 4 has
6 million gallons additional capacity scheduled to be online in 2029.
The current system. So when you look at those projections of influent
coming into the plant, the current system does not have enough capacity to
treat the projected 2029 flows, if that
makes sense. So GMP2 will install pumps and pipes
and other site improvements that improve that plant performance,
basically squeezing every drop we can get out of the existing facility
before the 6 million gallon additional capacity comes online.
So, this was a— I think this was actually out of order.
So, plant capacity snapshot is the existing
plant has a 2.4 million gallon total hydraulic capacity,
but the loading capacity is actually over 100%.
And that's an interesting distinction that sometimes is lost.
Eagle Mountain's wastewater is highly concentrated due
to everything is new since 1995 or 1996, right?
So about 1/3 of wastewater treated in the United States
is rainwater infiltrating into the sewer system. You guys don't have
that problem because your sewer is so new. So it's an interesting
caveat. So your influent
is very, very concentrated with What we call nutrient loading.
The good bacteria wants to take out nitrogen and phosphorus,
and they can only do that at a certain rate. So the way
I like to have an analogy for it is it's like a kitchen table.
If you have 10 seats, the flow coming in
is like how many people can sit at the table, and the loading
is how much food you can provide the guests. If you only have
half of people there, but everyone's eating a lot of food, the kitchen might run
out of food before you can seat the guests, if that makes sense. So,
I don't know how— Right. So that's why nitrogen
removal suffers even when flow looks acceptable. So right now we're not quite at the
flow levels of the plant. So GMP2 kind of bridges that
gap. Today we have, you know, the current capacity is
less than 2029 demand. So, GMP 2
bridges the gap into the expansion.
Also noted is that GMP 2 is part of the master
plan to have 14 million gallons daily
flow at the entire plant
once phase 2 of the MBR expansion is online.
But that's in the future.
So the packet contents, we have the work authorization, which is the mechanism to
authorize work to the contractor we've already selected. It has
the drawings and specifications, which are quite lengthy, but that's
all of the— that's how the contractor knows what to build.
The GMP form is how the dollars are allocated. There's also a work
directive which tells the contractor how changes in
the design are to be addressed in the construction phase. And so
this was just the breakdown, and I think Councilmember Wood alluded
to this. This is a $4 million project, and this
is just to bridge the gap until 2029.
So it's, you know, $2.5 million for the improvements
and lots of other things in here. We do have
$1 million in here for excavation, which is
kind of jumpstarting the next phases.
So we can, you know, keep the schedule.
So, so our recommendation is to approve GMP-2. Addresses the near-term capacity gap
of the plant, maintains reliable plant operations through early 2029
when GMP-3 through 6 is on schedule to
be completed. GMP— whoops,
GMP-3. Oh, sorry. Through GMP-6 remains
on schedule with this early excavation included in GMP-2.
And GMP-2 delivers the plant capacity in line with the long-term objectives of
the, of the plant.
So that was everything. And if you have any questions.
Thanks. I appreciate it. I asked for them to explain this while you guys
were all here. I think it's important for you to understand. the whys.
Uh, when we're spending $4 million, you ought to know why and where we're spending
it. Um, I think the important thing that he said there
is basically we don't have capacity to get through 2029. And so
while we're making some of these decisions— thank you very much for your presentation— it's
important for you to understand what some of the urgency of some of these things
are, why we're forced to make some of these decisions in a,
in a faster tempo than maybe we would like to. But this is one of
those reasons. So, thank you. All right, thanks for
the context. If there's not any questions specifically,
I'm happy to entertain a motion. Mayor, I'll make the motion.
I move that the City Council approve a resolution of Eagle Mountain City,
Utah, awarding the bid for EMC 6.0
MGD wastewater treatment facility expansion,
GMP-2 oxidation ditch, and miscellaneous
site improvements to MGC Contractors, Inc., and approving the contract.
Second. Okay, we have a motion by Council Member
Wood and a second by Council Member Clark, and we'll start the vote with,
uh, Council Member Wright. Yes. Council Member Whiting. Yes. Council Member
Wood. Yes. Council Member Hughes. Yes. And Council Member Clark. Yes.
Man, that was a pretty crappy deal right there. Crappy deal.
So, yeah, I've been waiting for that one.
Okay, let's move on to, uh, uh, item 12A.
This is an ordinance of Eagle Mountain City, Utah, amending the— Can
I make a request? Can we move past 12? Just set that aside and
come back to it. Let's get to 13 and let's give these good people an
opportunity to listen to what's going to happen there and then speak.
I'm totally okay with that. But this also, David could
be done and go home if we— this should be really quick.
I think I love David, but I'm going to tell you, I'm not— I'm good
with his time as the first. I'm okay with that. I just wanted to give
the counterpoint. So let's go on to— we're going to rearrange the schedule from
12A and 12B and skip to 13A.
I think to tee this up, I'm going to tell you that as
this conversation was happening all week, I have to set this agenda on
Wednesday. And I didn't have any information on Wednesday.
I know that there were conversations being had. I know there were things happening online.
And I said, you know what, I just want to bring it back for a
conversation. I don't know it's going to move, but I'm going to bring it back
for conversation. Uh, in the process, we, we were able
to speak as a council. And so I think, uh, I know Kimberly's
online for questions or, or for some presentations if needed,
or we can have a discussion. We've done this a week or 2 ago.
So I'm, I'm going to open it up for discussion and see where it lands.
And then before we Move forward, we will allow the public
to speak. If you feel like your questions were answered,
um, you don't have to speak. You know, if you feel
like there's some context you want to add, uh, that's going the right direction,
you know, I'm trying to be cognizant of your time as well as ours to
say, if you like the discussion, then, then that'll save
us all some time. So that's why it's here, and that's where we're at.
Um, so let me, let me start. I mean, the first item, Mayor, is 13A,
right? And it's really the question of whether or not we're going to repeal the
property tax increase certified rate that we approved on August 6th.
And I've had conversations with each council member individually,
and I believe there probably is a propensity toward that. So in
the interest of time, I'm going to make a motion if you'll allow it.
I'm okay with it. Mayor, I move that the city council, uh,
let me get this right, adopt a resolution repealing
a property tax increase above the certified rate for fiscal year 2026-2027.
Second. Okay, we have a motion by Council Member Wright
and a second by Council Member Clark, and we will start
the vote with Council Member Whiting. Yes. Council Member Wood. No.
Uh, Council Member Hughes. Yes. Council Member
Clark. Yes. Council Member Wright. Yes. Okay,
that passes 4-1, and, uh, we'll move on to
item 13B,
uh, same thing. Uh, I think this is where the conversation
is going to happen. So anybody that wants to speak, uh, Councilmember Wood,
I'm happy if you want to start off with— First
of all, let me say, just because I disagree with that, that doesn't mean I'm
not going to be in the conversation for the rest of it. That's why I
wanted to start. Um, when in talking with Councilmember
Hewish, when we were talking about the code So, just to review what that is,
we're talking about all of the property tax being applied to the
public safety, having a separate fund that's specific and has
parameters where it cannot be spent for anything else.
Um, that, that ordinance is in place. And then
there's some parameters of 95% of the contract,
85% of the contract, and 75%. So, my request
was, is I asked, if we're going to do that, then we probably ought to
put our money where our mouth is and say, What does that actually
look like to the residents? So I'm
the truth teller, so I'll be the one to tell you what the truth is.
The truth is that we are going to be canceling the tax relationship
with UFSA, which is our fire services. The reasoning
behind that is that we are paying more than we are getting back out of
that contract. And so, as a result of that,
so you're paying right now about 0.17 tax
To that entity, which means that there's going to be a UFA contract
next year that we're going to have to look at, and there will be a
cost associated with that. So you need to know what that actually looks
like. So if we were to do a direct transfer, $0.17 million,
and then on top of whatever we make the decision tonight, that needs to fall
within what the parameters are for that code. So it needs to be at least
75%. of what that total contract is for both our
sheriff's contract and our fire contract.
I want to say that to you, so if you don't understand when you come
up to, to give us feedback, please say that to us. That's how I'm
going to be evaluating this, because if we don't believe that, then why do the
code? And that's the reality of it. Why put a code that we're
not going to follow? So the reason I voted no is because in
order for us to accomplish just above the threshold of 75%,
we need to be at least 0.149,
which is 0.15 where we were.
On top of that, you'll have the 0.17, even though that won't be taxed directly
to your property. We'll have a contract that will equal that.
Councilmember Hughes, wasn't there a different number you had calculated on that, or is that
what— are you coming up with the same number? So the, the UFSA
contract, and I've got my, my property tax statement
here carried around with me these days. Kind of weird,
but the current rate is $0.001656.
That's what we pay. Yeah,
$0.001656.
It's roughly the same contract as what we're considering with the
sheriff's office. From a cost perspective. So the 1.7 rate
for— or the 1.656 rate for the fire is
pretty close to the 1.7. Now, that would be fully funded.
And what Councilmember Rich— or either way,
Councilmember Wood is saying is the UFSA
today is 100% funded at the 0.00156
rate. Where I maybe differ with this, I,
I'm maybe disagreeing with my own code year
1, but I think we can work into it year 2.
This volatility in the tax rate is not a
fault of residents, and I feel like we're kind of asking residents to absorb
that in 1 year. For some people it's fine, but there
are many, it's evident that that they can absorb it this
year. It's going to be challenging for them. So what I did is I ran
a— to answer Councilmember Whiting's comment— is
I ran a blended rate. This would be starting on January 1st of next
year when UFA becomes part of— or UFA,
when we are negotiating our own contract— to
come out to a 76% coverage ratio
for both Sheriff and for fire, that means our
sheriff contract, the rate would need to be 0.0009
to achieve a 76% coverage ratio for both fire
and for sheriff. And so that that's the math that
that would pass or or meet muster next
year, and I think we can work into it. Uh, gradually.
Does that, does that answer your question, Council Member Whiting?
There's no other comments.
Go ahead, make the motion. Wait, are we
gonna— what, is there gonna be public comment for this? No, that's why I'm asking.
I've— there is public comment still, still here, so Yeah, did you have
a comment? Yeah, I think briefly, I think, I think we need to acknowledge that
Eagle Mountain City has a slightly different
situation this week than a handful of days ago, in that the Tyson plant
announced a closure that was not part of any of the consideration
when we first met. And so I, I think the public, if we didn't
acknowledge it, I think the public would come up and talk about that as well.
And I think in terms of, in terms of the vote tonight
and considering a repeal, the— when I, when I personally heard of the,
the Tyson closure, my first immediate response is
I sent a message to our economic development director. I said, how many Eagle Mountain
families specifically are affected? Because we know not all that work at the plant are
from Eagle Mountain. Some come from other locations. It turns out to be about half,
which is a significant number. That prompted in my own mind
a need to to, to measure what we're doing here and,
uh, and, and to balance out what we're, what we're working on.
If, if there's no other comments, I can open it up for the public.
Um, really quick, Mayor, sorry, I just really
want to make sure our residents understand. And we talked about
switching out of UFSA. We'll still have the UFA services.
Um, we just won't be being taxed by them. We're going to
shift that burden off of that. So we have more control over it. And I
think there were a lot of numbers thrown out, and I just want to make
sure everybody understands that at the very least,
it's going to be that contract price or
less, because we now, as a city, will get
to help set what our level of service is. So I don't want everyone to
be like, oh my gosh, it's gonna be 12,000% increase. It's not.
What happens is you won't have to pay taxes to UFSA,
and instead we'll be paying through our contract here.
But we want you guys to not get scared about
it because we'll walk through it all together. Thank you.
Thank you.
Okay, and just another comment as well.
The initial request for the money and the
taxation is backed up by a
large number of needs that are— that exist here in the city.
And so I— some people said, well, it was just a head fake. No,
that's not. We're putting out there saying, look, there's a monetary need in the city.
That began a discussion, and we're grateful for that discussion
that happened. Part of, part of my,
you know, being very open to reconsider this is,
is something that you alluded to earlier, Mayor, and that you've had some,
some conversations with some of our business partners in our
city. And, and part of my willingness to,
to, to adjust the rate down further right now is
because of hopes that I have that we can have some positive outcomes
with those discussions. And that,
because I want to assure there, there are a number of residents that have,
have messaged us saying, thank you for this tax increase, because they
know what it means to invest in, in what those dollars will mean for the
city. And so, to those residents, I also want to acknowledge that if there's
a reduction in rate, it's not because we are, we are deciding
to, to take off the gas from the growth that,
from the, from the infrastructure dollars that this city needs.
To take off the gas from so many improvements that the city
needs. It just means that we, we feel that we've got avenues that
could potentially help with that.
And one of those is, uh, I spent some time with some of our federal
partners, as mentioned, Mike Kennedy. And if you think I didn't ask him for every
penny I could get back out of him that we already gave him, meaning the
federal government, you need to come talk to me because we are going
to advocate for those dollars. So, um,
I think, I think it's fair to say I want to hear
from the public, and I hope that you have enough information on this.
Um, and I'm happy to answer some questions as we
go along after we finish the public comment as well. I'll keep notes, and I'm
happy to address those as we all can. So with that, we will
reopen the public comment at 8:34. All right.
And, uh, and ask Lacey
if— and again, if your name is called and you, and you feel like,
you know what, I, I feel good about where we're headed, just say
we're good so we can keep going. If you want to speak, speak, or come
voice your, your opinion. I'm happy with that. I just know that you didn't know
the conversation yet. Um, this— sorry,
this first batch is individuals who wrote, um, topic item 13.
So, I'm not sure what's regarding. So, Anthony Wood.
All right, so I had a whole comment written out.
My phone ended up dying, so I'm going to wing it.
Um, I've talked to a lot of people in Eagle Mountain. I've talked to a
lot of you guys here. Um, I'm hearing a lot of people talking about needs
and Realistically,
I'm only hearing 2 real common needs
across a lot of the councilmen and other, other members in Eagle Mountain.
Um, but where I want to start first is that I'm not a supporter
of property tax, like, internally. You know, I just also logically understand
that I don't live in a society that affords me to have no property taxes.
Just on principle, I don't support it. All that
being said, I do understand that there may be a need for an increase.
I think your guys' first, first ask was too much. I feel like your guys'
2nd number you landed on with 183 was still a bit
high coming out at the 0015 mark.
Looking at the common need that a lot of councilmen have
discussed for officers and staff.
Looking at those 2 needs, those 2 asks there,
I was looking at a number of about 0.001054.
The reason why I was coming out to that number is that it equates to
covering the basic staff needs that were being asked and those
officers. I feel like the first
request of 220 was a reaction to the state's cap legislation.
And I feel like it was acted on quickly, and then it was
reduced down. You know, it wasn't reduced down far enough.
Um, I really feel that we can get
by with those 2 first needs first and read budget, come back
to the table in the future and find out if there's more that's needed.
We're going to have a lot of funds coming in, apparently, from what you guys
are saying. Now, I know that there were other needs that some of the councilmen
have Members have stated, and those seem to be
a little bit more on an individual basis. We were talking about roads.
I may be misunderstanding, but I thought that was covered by the transportation
fund and the gas taxes. I may— we
may not have enough. I don't know. I haven't researched that much yet. But with
all that being said, that we have things that you guys are looking at that
can wait. And we can budget those, we can plan those. I'm not
saying wait. 5 years, 10 years, or whatever. Just take it year by year
by year, and let's adjust as needed. If we do have funds
coming in, then we can adjust to that. I don't think we should be reliant
on any external entity to the city, so I do believe we should have some
property taxes. I would hate to see the data centers leave and leave us in
a hole where we need more money. I, I don't like the data centers.
Let me get that out there as well. But consider a lower number that
might be a little bit more realistic, please.
Wade S.
I don't see Wade. Ashley Erkschein.
Feel free to correct me if I'm wrong.
All right. So I'm
not a public speaker, and I really hate that I have to be here tonight.
Just say no. But I would like to just make sure I
formally oppose any tax increase at this time on
Eagle Mountain citizens. I believe that demanding a financial burden—
a permanent, sorry, financial burden on taxpayers at
a time when your constituents are already strained by the economy is completely
irresponsible and unnecessary. Your constituents
are people— are the people who actually built this city.
The people who voted for you and trusted you to look
out for their best interests. You made claims
that we'll see revenue from data centers, as Anthony mentioned a moment ago,
within the next year. So do we really need
a tax increase now, a permanent tax increase?
Historically, you know, there was a, there was a thought.
I think it was 1913 when income taxes started.
Wasn't that supposed to be temporary too? If we know we
have revenue coming and we know that we
can get by for another year, right, evaluate, assess, be careful,
be thoughtful about permanent decisions, we should
do so. If these needs are
so necessary and we need them right now, then those
of you who served this city for the past 2 to
8 years Should have planned and budgeted these things
sooner. For example, I would like
to know why the city spent $7.3 million on land for a civic
center, aka new city hall, just last year.
Without evaluating the need for public safety, wastewater plant
raises for its employees, or even additional employees
to maintain what the city already has. Why are we buying
more land if we cannot maintain what we already have?
Sorry, I lost my spot. There has to be a point where we look at
the budget and see what can be reduced and make sure that these
things are planned and prioritized at the appropriate time.
And frankly, true leadership requires integrity,
requires the integrity to take accountability for those who, who you
bear responsibility for. excuses and walks around the truth,
moving money around, coming up with new funds,
shifting stuff here, there. That doesn't— that displays
an inability to drive results. And that's something
I don't think this city can afford. Ultimately,
if you guys think about it, I just want you to think about one thing.
Um, and I'm just going to go to the end here, but I would like
you to consider the fact that Your choices— you guys are all on a governing
body in the United States of America, right? And so your choices have a
direct impact on businesses. Businesses offset their costs
onto consumers. So you are directly affecting the bigger problem in the United
States of America, which is inflation. Let's not do that.
Thanks. Your time is up. Thank you. Jen Hackett.
My name is Jen Hackett. Um, I understand our city has grown
tremendously and we haven't raised property taxes in a long time,
and that some of the decisions that have brought us here were made by past
leadership. But I'm asking you tonight to really consider how much
we actually need this right now and to be completely transparent with residents
about what we're paying for. This letter that we received says we hear
you and that every dollar of this increase will go directly toward public safety.
Technically, that's true. When I read it, the first 2 paragraphs
already, I was upset with it. It's misleading
at best and manipulative at its worst. The average resident
reading this letter is going to believe this tax increase is needed to pay for
new public safety expenses. But that's not the whole story. We need
1. $1.5 million for additional deputies. The rest of the sheriff's
contract is already paid for, and moving that existing expense to property taxes
is going to free up millions of dollars for other things.
Just tell us that. Tell us where that money is going.
For example, if it was going to hire groundskeepers to maintain raw spaces
behind our communities, to clear tumbleweeds and dead grass,
and to protect our homes from fire, then say that and tell us what
that costs. Fund what you say you're going to fund and be accountable for doing
it. Thank you. We've heard capital projects. That's not specific enough.
Which projects are they? What do they cost? What needs to happen now and
what can wait? We keep hearing additional revenue is around the corner.
So, if we're in dire financial straits and we cannot wait for
that revenue, tell us we're in dire financial straits. Residents can handle
tough answers. We're being told it's just a little bit more. It's only $1
or $2 a day. It's this much. We're giving
a little to so many more places right now, more for groceries,
utilities, insurance, and gas. This increase
is enough for formula for a baby for a few months. It's a year of
school lunches for a student who doesn't qualify for free lunch.
It's the fee for an entire cross-country season for a high school student.
It's school fees for 2 students. It's a couple weeks of groceries
for a young family. Thank you. It's around 5 tanks of gas to get somebody
to work. Um, you can believe this tax increase
is necessary without minimizing what you're asking people to give up.
Tonight was a poor choice for this meeting. Tomorrow's the first day
of school for most students in our community. Parents are home getting kids
in bed right now and ready for school. They may want to be here,
and you should want them to be here. Mayor Gray,
I know that you attended the last meeting by Zoom. Excuse me. Residents made the
effort to show up, sit in that room. They deserve to have you here.
to look them in the eyes and hear what they had to say. Um,
I'm not asking for you to never raise our taxes, but I am asking before
you vote to consider what we need and moving forward to be honest and
straightforward with your communication and tell us what we're getting for our money.
Thank you.
Steve Peretta.
Good evening. My name is Steve Perretta. Uh,
thank you for allowing me to talk. Uh, I want
to echo what the last lady said. I'm glad to see you could all find
the time to be here today. Uh, there is sarcasm attached to that. I would
expect that under— uh, unless we're talking
serious, serious emergencies, I would expect that all 6 of
you would be here to address our concerns. Transparency comes before
taxes, not the other way around. You tell us you're not communicating effectively and
need to do better, but you voted unanimously for 183%,
and only after the people spoke up did you start talk—
start talking compromise. That's backwards. That's not the way it's
supposed to work. I emailed all of you on the 7th, one day after the
last meeting. 3 of you responded, 50%.
Council members Huish, Whiting, and Clark, in that order.
Councilmember Clark's response didn't come till today, 2 weeks after I emailed,
or almost 2 weeks after I emailed you. My wife and I had a long
discussion with Councilman— Councilmember
Huish, and I appreciate that. Thank you.
Uh, but I still haven't seen the transparency we're asking for. Why are we trying
to fund an entire public safety need solely out of
property tax. That's not the way it's been done in the past. Why are we
trying to do that in the future? Mayor Gray, you told my wife and I
directly before you were the mayor that there would be data center growth
that would equal $50 a month for each household in
Eagle Mountain. It was, it was not on the record.
Uh, it was after a meeting after my
wife and I had both voiced our displeasure. Simple math says $50 a month
equals $600 a year. Thank you. But now you're asking for a $300 a year
increase. That's a $900 swing from a
decrease of $600 a month to an increase of $900 a month. This is not
difficult math. Wrong direction from what we
were told to expect. You said tonight you support QTS,
but you're still asking us for a tax increase before, before giving us the transparency
that we've asked for. You want our support? Support what
we're asking for and we'll support you. Thank you. I submitted a GRAMA
request after the last meeting to understand how the 183% figure
was actually calculated. The city denied my fee
waiver and is now requiring a $100 deposit before they
even begin processing a request for records that should already be
public. So, from where I sit, the city is asking—
excuse me, the city is making transparency cost
money. Thank you. I expect each of you to decide how you're voting tonight.
Uh, after hearing tonight's comments, uh, you each— I'll be
quick here. This council represents 0.0078%
of our population. That means each of you represents about 12,782
residents each. So, to your point, Councilmember Gray,
uh, yes, it's a heavy burden, and I expect you to vote accordingly.
Thank you. according to what your constituents would want you to do. Your time
is up. Thank you. Alex Washburn.
Can come back if he's— Natalie Deschamons.
Hi there. I'm Natalie Deschamont. I am one of
the people who originally co-sponsored the referendum. It has been a
long week of civic duty, and so I got a little bit of taste of
what you guys do, and I have no interest in doing it. I've learned that
this week. While I don't regret what
we submitted, I'm very proud of being part of a referendum and
standing up for the people of the community. I want
to make note that multiple members of the council and Mayor Gray himself
took the time to sit with us and talk with us and respond to the
things that my husband and I had to say and questions that we had.
Um, I understand the need for a tax increase.
I think that the one that was originally passed obviously was too high. I think
we all recognize that. Um, I don't know what the right number is.
I don't do numbers. I'm a— I'm a teacher, so I'm not
a— I'm not a number person, right? I'm a people person in that sense.
But I don't know the right number, but I recognize
the need for an increase. And I appreciate that while
it may have been because your backs were against the wall from public outcry,
that you guys did take the time to sit and reflect and reach out to
us, at least us personally. And that really
is my public comment. So, Mayor Gray, I appreciate the time we took last week.
Councilmember Hewish, I appreciate you responding to my husband and having a thoughtful conversation with
him. And I hope that whatever the resolution
comes to be today, I hope that we all can agree that conversations
have been had and people have been heard on both sides. So that is my
comment. Thank you, guys.
Laura Albright.
This is new for me. I'm just going to read the
last sentence of what I have written down. Mayor Gray
and City Council, my— and obviously my name
is Laura Albrecht. Um, I'm just asking, and this
was after my, my whole page, um,
isn't there just one more way to work this out rather
than causing much distress to the citizens
of this great city. And I want
to thank you for what I have heard, for, for what all of it I
can understand. I can't understand all of it, but, um,
I can tell that you've put your heads together and,
and there's been, uh, a good groupthink.
And, and I hope that we can move forward and not have to worry
about This— I'm sure that next time it comes
up, and like this last little lady said, I realize
we've got to have taxes to live. That's just all there is to it.
But in the meantime, I hope we can do it differently than we did
this last time. Thank you.
Melissa Bradley.
Tonight's not a good night to be here because of school starting tomorrow,
um, and I was in Provo all week— or all day today helping my
25-year-old daughter pack so she could move back home with
us on Saturday. I know each of you have rejected the idea
that, um, your tax increase will affect
rent for our children, but I want you all to know and warn you that
it will Raise rent, and landlords will pass that tax increase on
to our children. I'm here tonight
because I believe we need honesty about the property tax increase and to stop blaming
the past decisions,
um, that are being made today. We keep hearing that
Eagle Mountain has to raise property taxes by 183% because
previous councils made mistakes, that they were cheap.
They weren't cheap. They were intelligent. That is simply not
the whole story. Past mayors and councils built this city.
They faced enormous challenges, lawsuits,
rapid growth, and limited resources.
They chose to live within the revenue that they had rather
than continually asking taxpayers for more.
It's easy to spend more money. When you have more money.
What is hard is being fiscally responsible.
What is hard is saying we can't do everything
right now. Let's prioritize. Let's grow carefully. Let's make
sure every dollar is spent wisely before we take another dollar from our
residents. That's leadership. And I want
to address the Gettysburg analogy. Councilman Whiting, Taxpayers are not the
enemy. We are not the Confederates at
Round Top. We are your constituents. We elected
you. We pay the taxes. We pay our taxes. We have the
right to tell you where we believe our money should and should not be spent.
We're not declaring war on you. We are simply
saying no to a tax increase. If anything,
this is the Boston Tea Party, and we have enough. We've had enough.
And please look at the, at the people this affects.
Our seniors came before you all, and they told
you they are retired on fixed incomes. They do not get to vote
themselves a raise when property taxes go up. They are the people
we should be protecting and valuing and not dismissing.
None of you addressed them last 2 weeks ago.
None of you. Instead, you voted For
a tax increase. Mayor, please stop using Facebook to attack
or misrepresent people that you disagree with. You're the mayor
of Eagle Mountain. Please take accountability for your
actions. Please, please stop the attacking
on Facebook. It's embarrassing. And to the entire
council, set your egos aside. The plan you came up
with in St. George is not automatically right because you came up with it.
Spending more does not automatically. Thank you. Make Eagle Mountain
better. The hard thing is saying no.
The hard thing is making difficult choices, and the hard thing is
admitting— Your time is up. Thank you.
Joel Buss.
My name is Joel Buss. Believe it or not, I've never done this before,
despite who my better half is. Um, but I'd just
like to make a quick comment about why we're here tonight. We're here because of
a breakdown in communication, and when communication breaks
down, you lose trust. It's pretty simple. The pressure this council is feeling
tonight didn't appear overnight.
It built because residents, residents asked questions and too often
walked away without Clear and consistent answers.
I have no doubt this council believes and knows what
Eagle Mountain needs. You also have the entire picture.
We don't. But you as a council can't
give residents incompetent or conflicting explanations
and then criticize us for not understanding what hasn't
been clearly explained. Thank you. You are our leaders,
and you cannot come across as haphazard.
If we have 100 problems and they're all priority number 1,
we need a plan. You need a plan,
and you need to get on the same page.
We can't afford to just firehose attack these problems
and expect a great result. We need
a strategy. We need to approach them maniacally, deliberately, and with
absolute clarity. Tell us what's next,
why it's next, what it costs, and where we're going
after that. You want us to be involved? Give us opportunities well
before the due date. That's why we're here tonight.
Councilmember Wood, I'd like to address you and the comments
you made about my wife. You called her involvement disappointing
and suggested it was a publicity stunt.
I know why she got involved. For 2 weeks straight, I've watched
her take calls, texts, people show up to my house crying,
all from residents concerned about a municipal decision
she has zero authority over.
Because people are looking for someone who would listen, Rich.
So she listened. We're all adults.
Trust us with the information. Accountability means listening
before public outrage forces it. It shouldn't take 2
weeks of frustration for residents to finally feel heard.
Each of you, I know for a fact, could probably list 5 residents
That are, whether they're a pain in the what, or they're calling you
left and right, you could include them. You could make them subject matter
experts that could help you, that could be a voice of the people.
We all want a safer, stronger Eagle Mountain. The people have
a voice, and we expect our council to trust us enough to show us the
plan, explain the why, and let us be a part of how we get there.
Thank you.
Adam Bradley.
So I just want to be clear, you repealed the tax hike?
Yes, that first vote was repealing the tax
hike. I'm not that smart and I didn't get it, so I don't know if
they got it. But the second vote is going to come up with a new
number, and because it's going to be less than the $183 million, you don't have
to go through the tax— through the taxation process, am I right?
No, this is part of that. Okay,
cool. I'm just trying to understand the process because that's important,
and you guys live it. We don't. It's not
always easy to understand, even though some of us might have experience in it.
It's still out of our purview. So maybe some clarification on
some of that stuff. So having said that,
um, I think, I think this whole process kind of Embarrasses
me. It kind of brings me back to, like, remember 15,
18 years ago when a lot of us moved here? Eagle Mountain was kind of
a butt of a lot of jokes, right? Our government was run by just sort
of like a good old boy club, and they didn't really care, and they did
weird stuff, and it led to some tragedies, actually,
right? You remember that? And I felt that, that we've kind of
become that butt of those jokes again. in the last couple of weeks.
You see 183 reduced from 220 all
over the news, all over the place. People don't have context,
but that's the problem. And so I'm
also embarrassed that, you know, maybe we don't
always act great online. It's really easy to be a keyboard warrior, right?
And so, you know, Melissa, some, you know, those are
embarrassing comments to hear people saying about you.
That's not, that's not who we are as a community. That's not who
we are. So I'm embarrassed by that as well. Um,
and, and I'm not going to excuse it, but this
whole process has been bad. I'm glad
you repealed it. I support that, that you just repealed that. But now our next
one, what are you going to do? I have no idea what you're going to
do. And so I support you voting no on the next one. Thank you.
On 13B as well, and just start over.
Start over. You all admitted regret, which is maybe the first time
I've heard that from a lot of you. You all admitted regret in your
communication, in your transparency.
Um, I didn't hear anybody say you regret raising taxes,
because I stand for 0% taxes. I stand
for— Meaning reducing the taxation on our, on our residents 100%.
So you might say that's not practical. I say figure it out.
So taxation is theft. And if you don't believe that,
then you're the wrong person to represent me. And that's not just a trope.
Okay. And so the principles I see
are not, are not there that I agree with. The principles of you
spend less, you make less, you do what you do with less.
And sewer, great. Fund the sewer. We got to fund
the sewer. So. Thank you.
Gary Fuchs.
How's it going? My name is Gary Fuchs.
I lived in Eagle Mountain since 2003, and yes,
I'm wearing an aloha shirt tonight and shorts to talk about taxes,
because I figured if my argument is only persuasive when I'm dressed up,
it probably isn't a very good argument. So I'm going to be comfortable and let
the numbers speak for themselves. First, thanks for making the hard decisions,
and I'm sorry for the abuse and threats you and your families have endured.
It's unacceptable, and we need to be better.
And shame on those fanning the flames while crying victim. Over the last
week, I've spent probably more time than I should have with Google and AI digging
into this tax increase, the budget, the sheriff's contract.
police staffing in other cities, other Utah cities,
truth in taxation, and even the data center agreements.
And after all of that, I support a meaningful
property tax increase. That doesn't mean that I think the city communicated
this perfectly. I think 183% became the story while
100% for public safety was too simple to explain that was
actually happening. The issue isn't just 7 additional deputies.
We have around 77,000 residents and one of the lowest law enforcement
staffing ratios among comparable Utah cities. From my
research in the last 7 years, calls have risen 223%
and deputies only about 119%. We also
have a sheriff's contract that property tax currently does not fully fund.
Other city revenues are making up that difference.
Moving more of public safety onto property taxes does 2 things.
It allows us to add needed deputies, and it frees existing recurring revenue to
address staffing and other needs in the city that has grown enormously.
My ask is to share that list with
the citizens. That's one thing conversations that I've had online is missing is what's
that list? Do you want us to, to give our input on what's important?
What's out there, right? And I understand that this
increase will hurt some families, and that matters, and I don't dismiss
it. One thought I had while sitting over there is exploring the possibility of
adopting something Texas did, which is giving breaks to senior citizens over the age of
65, veterans, and those on disability.
But I also don't think continuing to postpone the problem is responsible.
We haven't gone through truth in taxation in 15 years,
and eventually we have to fund the city we've become, not the city we were
15 years ago. Whatever rate you settle on tonight, I ask
you to make— make it actually addresses the problem instead of
simply choosing the number that creates the least backlash. And will be the
most politically advantageous. Also, as a side note, I'd rather have more
data centers than houses. Thank you.
Garrett Houghter. I'm not sure if I said your last name right.
Okay, thank you.
Hi, I'm Garrett Houghter. Um, so I
have several points that I just want to touch on really quick. Um,
first, I agree with the minor increase. Um, I feel like
The 220 and the 183 were just shocking, and that's literally
what it was. The first time I ever saw it, I was just shocked,
and then I had to come down from that, and it took a long time.
Um, and with that, I just would like to condemn
the comments that you all received. Um, I can
only speak for myself, but I, um, every chance I get, I condemn
those comments, and, uh, I'm sorry for, for that.
Um, Thank you. Okay, next thing I'd like to point out,
um, that class that was talked about earlier, I went
to the first one and it was amazing. I really enjoyed
it. I learned a lot about how the city works. Um,
when they were talking about the sewer, the wastewater plant,
um, I spent several hours touring and I learned a lot about that.
And I think that gave me a perspective through this whole situation that a lot
of other residents and citizens didn't have. I definitely encourage everyone to go
to that because it gives a background that helps you,
helps help me understand the projects you're talking about trying to fund.
So, for everyone that's here, I recommend that 4th class that's
coming up. I, um, one thing
that I, you can comment to or not, but as
you're talking about that new code, the 75 to 95, um, I didn't
hear Anybody say that, that if it drops below that 75,
that that next year it must be increased to match
that, that it must be increased or should be increased, but it didn't have
to go all the way up to 75 yet. And so that's something
to think about. If, if you vote something much lower than that
next year or the next, you have a few years to get back up to
that. I didn't— it didn't sound like the code mandated
huge increases the next few years. Something to think about.
And then, um,
oh, and then you said something. I was here this afternoon. You said something
that I think is— was important for me to understand
the importance of this. And I don't remember which one of you said
it, but it was, um, that a lot of the sheriff's contract is
being paid for by sales tax, which is
variable. It fluctuates up and down. And if it goes too low,
then we have to find other ways to pay for that sheriff's contract.
Um, and the advantage to paying for— 8 seconds remaining.
Paying for public, public safety through property taxes is that it's
not variable, it's fixed. Um, and so that contract,
those public safety contracts will always be covered. And I really—
that was a huge perspective changer for me in this process,
um, to explain why that is necessary and why property
taxes need to go to public safety. So I,
I'm for an increase. I personally, I,
I, if I— Your time is up. Thank you.
Patrick Buchanan.
It's kind of hard to stand up here tonight for some personal reasons,
um, but I felt the need to be here.
First off, I think there's some accountability here that needs to be addressed,
and I don't think this is totally resting on the back of those
we elected. Personally, I think this also lands
on all of us. Our driving,
Which requires a lot of complaints amongst
each other. Not cleaning around our houses, making sure
that brush and stuff like that, that we can control.
We're making a record of this. Can you speak into the mic?
Brush, stuff like that, that we can control is
something that we can manage. I think
that I, I don't want to call out the children across the city,
but I think there could be better parental
type stuff going on throughout the city that reduces the demand
on calls that parents could handle when it comes to law
enforcement. I think that at
the end of the day, when you're the one who has to call 911 and
a deputy shows up, And you're thankful that they're there.
It's meaningful. When you're
the one who, whose home burnt down in
Willow Springs, not mine, and you saw those deputies knock
on every door to get everyone out, I think there's
something to be said for their sacrifice.
I think that when it comes to the fires that
happen around this city, Whether it be the Turtle Hill fire a
couple of years ago, the Lake Mountain fire.
You know, there's a lot of stuff that goes into this,
but there's a lot of stuff that, that we can control
as citizens to kind of help reduce the demand that
the city is asking for. And I think that if
we're going to be a community of self-governance and elect
officials to represent us, I think that they're owed the proper respect.
But I also think that when
the things that we need to pay for are covered, it reduces
things like insurance rates and
the demand that your insurance company is placing upon you and increasing
your mortgage. Now, mind you, a wrap tax is
great, but that's, that's tied to your sales tax.
30 seconds remaining. If you are filling out
a 1040, I think it's also important to remember that
at the end of the year, that information is also being taken
into consideration in your overall tax rate that you're paying when
it comes to the federal government. And so,
try to take it easy on everyone. Try to just see the other side
of this and try to think that— what— ask yourself, what can I do
as a citizen to make this easier? Thank you.
Your time is up. Thank you. Tony Castillo.
So, Tony Castillo, um, there's a lot
of things I love and a lot of things I hate about Eagle Mountain.
We've all been friends and we've all known each other.
We've all lost friends. The biggest thing is
this whole taxing.
It needs to happen. My wife and I are
at each other's throats over it because I'm for it, she's against it.
I'd say come up with a reasonable number because a lot of us have mortgages
and you guys tell us it's $25 a month extra.
Yeah. Love it. Love that number. But what's not
being disclosed is that our mortgage company will
pay that shortage. If I only have $5,000
in my escrow account and my mortgage company has to
pay $300 more for that tax increase, my mortgage
company is going to increase my monthly payment by
double. So whatever $600 divided by 12 is, That's what they're going
to charge me and every resident until the shortage
has been paid in full to the mortgage company. So, as you guys
look at doing this tax increase, keep, uh, bear in
mind that that number that you're presenting to us is not the true number that
we're going to be having to pay.
Love having deputies. Um, one of
the things a lot of you guys don't know is it's my first month living
in Eagle Mountain back in 2020, my oldest son, who's autistic,
ran away.
As a dad, I'm like, what the hell?
Don't know this area. My kid just ran away.
And we called 911, and one of the deputies that
I'd met— we'd put our kid on the list that he's a runner,
all this stuff— and to see all the deputies and even the
off-duty deputies come out to help look for my kid
was more rewarding than anything else. So yes,
everybody that is complaining about, do we, we,
do we really need all this extra? Yeah, we do.
We're overstretched.
We want all these nice things, but we don't want to pay for it.
All we got to do is come together and say, hey, let's negotiate
a better, fair rate that we can all swallow. Because— 30 seconds remaining.
That pill, red or blue, it's going to screw
us one way or the other. It's just, if it's going to screw me
over, I'd rather it be as less painful as possible. Um,
that's all I gotta say, guys. Love you guys. Thank you for doing what you
guys do. Apologize that you guys are getting, uh, the threats and all
that stuff. Um, that's all I got to say.
Betty Peralta.
Betty Peralta. Good evening, my name is Betty Peralta.
Unfortunately, my comments aren't going to be as nice as some of the ones you've
heard. Um, I was here last week and
I was very disappointed that after sitting here from
6 till 11, all we heard
was untruths. So here are my comments.
You've already made a decision. The resolution to increase the taxes
regardless of the overwhelming opposition by the citizens
of Eagle Mountain, has gone on deaf ears.
Rumor has it that this council has already decided on a new
number without listening to what we have to say.
You were elected for the representation of the citizens,
not to make closed-door decisions and lying
and misrepresenting What the expected new funds
would cover. I've asked 3 times
for a line item budget. I still have to see it.
I've received no answers. This council
is deaf to the voices of the people that you, that you represent.
You were hired by the citizens, and it's expected
that you do just that, represent us.
And stop working for your own personal interests.
And stop making frivolous plans that are not priorities.
As I mentioned to you last week, I come from 38
years of public safety. I was a first responder.
I know that that's critical, and I know that having police is critical.
But your excuses, your sad stories.
Will fall on deaf ears, just like our voices have
fallen on your deaf ears. And I don't
see any compassion for the people that were up here, the elderly,
the retired that are on fixed incomes.
You continue to live well with all of the perks that your positions
provide. And none of you have to worry about
high gas prices because the city provides you a car.
All of us don't have that perk. I said,
please don't patronize us citizens with your excuses
of not doing your job effectively and that you will try better.
Try downsizing your lifestyle. That's what you've told us.
Expenses for many Eagle Mountain
residents— 30 seconds remaining. Are— I'm sorry, that is exactly
what Eagle Mountain citizens are doing on a daily basis.
Eagle Mountain citizens' hard-earned money is
not for your discretionary or personal use. Thank you.
David Higgins, I think, is what it says. Is that right?
Yeah, David Higgins. Yes, ma'am. Is that correct? Okay. Higgins.
Okay. Yep. Thanks. Good evening.
I first would like to thank you guys for this opportunity for me
to vent and express my feelings on this,
uh, tax increase. But first of all and foremost,
I'm acting liaison for Eagle Mountain's 3
percenters. Do you guys know what that is? That's your seniors
and your fixed incomes. That's me.
And 3% makes us the minority.
So anyway, but thank you again, and I have to admit this,
that I myself are in disagreement with
the tax hike. I'm more for the referendum than against
it. The reason for that is, is my,
my views are that it should be fairness for all.
by all. And in order to obtain something like
that, we need to put it on a ballot and have a vote and
have that. Now, ballots used to be pretty secure at one time.
I'm not saying they're that way anymore, but, uh,
that's where I stand. And, uh, once again,
I'm not in favor of the hike, and it's not because I don't think taxes
aren't needed. It's because I think it's the way we require And
obtain those taxes that needs to be polished.
Anyway, thank you.
Donna Burnham.
First of all, I want to say how horrified I
am by the things that Melissa Clark read.
That should never have happened. And I want
you to know that you don't deserve that. Um,
I understand what it's like to be in those seats because I sat in
them for 16 years, and it's a
heavy load. And I know how hard all of you work, so I
just want you to know you didn't deserve any of that,
and I'm sorry that we weren't better that
we needed to be. I believe you want the best for the city. I do
take issue with a few things, and one of them, of course, is going to
be the blame put on former councils. Um,
I feel like it's very important that we be good stewards
of the tax dollars, and I feel like I was a good steward of our
tax dollars. We were lean, um,
and that's what we should be. We should be lean.
However, in the last few years, we became too lean.
And I get that. And should we have raised taxes?
Maybe. But we were also raising utility rates, as you remember,
which was a huge impact on citizens. People were reeling from
the cost from COVID and from all other things. So that's
why we didn't— we didn't put that burden on the residents because
we knew that there was a bright future ahead.
And we, we took a risk that that would come sooner than later.
So I get that you're in a position that's difficult,
um, but yes, we have a smaller percentage of
the sheriff's department than other cities do, um, but our call
times have always been good until the last few years.
And call times are what matters. It matters how long it takes
a deputy to get to your house. That's what matters. And so yeah,
we need more officers, especially Especially with the increase in calls.
That's obvious. I get that. And so do we
need an increase? Probably. Do we need that
significant an increase? I don't think so. And I, I would
respectfully ask that you look at just doing maybe a 50% increase.
And I know that's a risk because I'm asking you to
bet on future income. But I think you all know it's coming
and that it's there. And I think that that's a risk worth
taking to protect our vulnerable citizens, those in
the 3%, as he was talking about. Also families with children
who— young families who are just struggling to make ends
meet, that don't have insurance or whatever. So that would
be what I would ask. And I appreciate you at least
being willing to repeal what you started with and at least listening to
our concerns. Thank you. Michael Thompson.
Hello, I'm a 9-year resident of Eagle Mountain, and I appreciate
all that you do. And,
uh, I want you to know that I'm also a great supporter of, of our
first responders, my own Father-in-law and brother-in-law
are retired Utah police officers, and,
and I, I want to see more support for them,
and, and I'm willing to pay for it.
That said,
I could add to the hardship stories. I have plenty of my
own, including a daughter that lives here and is,
is scared to death that her rent's about to go up because of the tax
increase. But what I really want to do is see
if I can offer some help. So I have a stepson who
is a construction manager for custom homes in Salem.
He tells me that they enacted a $30,000 charge
for new building permits. They do that to slow growth
and to provide money so that infrastructure can be put in place before the
growth occurs. And I think maybe we need to look at the
possibility of doing that. Um,
and I, I would much rather see us, uh,
get some more money out of these developers like Carl Ivory,
who, by the way, has raised my HOA fees 350%
since I moved into my house 5 years ago. And I'd like to see
the city do something to stop them from— these declarant-controlled HOAs
are out of control. The other thing is,
I ask that you quit giving a break in water rates to residents
with lots that are over half an acre versus the rest
of us. I know there were some good reasons
for doing that in the past. I think those times have passed,
and they should be paying the same rates as the rest of us and get
some more money for the water that, that is used in the
city. That's all I have to add. Thank you.
Duncan Searcy.
Melissa, you can take a breath. I'm here for Craig tonight, not you.
But I do want to say I'm sorry that you have received death threats,
um, and publicly condemn that. And I'm serious. I've been
on the receiving end of, of that before in my life, and it is not
a fun feeling, and it's not appropriate. So I, I'm, I'm sorry
that some of the content that I've generated has caused you to feel that uncomfortable
stuff. I unfortunately cannot, you know,
regulate how people react to the things that I say, but I
am sorry that you experienced that. And I hope you know that, um, you are
still my sister in Christ and you deserve to be safe and happy,
even though we very seldom agree on things. I,
I— that's not appropriate. So, um, I'll give you your
time. I'm just gonna remind you, personal attacks will not be accepted.
So speak as you will. Have I made a personal attack? You said I'm here
after Craig. Well, I'm gonna give Craig some feedback about the truth in taxation.
I'm okay with feedback. I don't want an attack, if that's okay. Okay. Uh,
so where are we at on time then? Where were we at when, when I
got interrupted? We paused it. You have 2 minutes. Yep. All right, I'll keep going.
Um, and then I just want to say thank you to my fellow citizens.
I didn't think I would get to speak tonight because I had other engagements.
And so I want to thank
you for doing that. I know it's not easy to stand up here and speak
your mind, but it is very important. And then I also owe an apology
to, to the mayor, Jared Gray. Um, he caught some
heat from my social media today because I'm being investigated by the
Utah County Sheriff's Office, uh, because somebody here on the dais— it's not
Jared Gray— uh, said that I'm making threats. Thank you.
And so, uh, I, I, I thought that was you,
but after we got into the discussion, we discovered that it's actually
somebody else, not you. So I apologize, and I'm more than happy to
put out another video. I hope you'll do that with me, and we can,
we can set the record straight that that wasn't you that's, uh, using law
enforcement as a pressure to try and silence me. Um, so now
we'll get to Craig's feedback, not attacks. Okay,
so for the Truth in Taxation meeting, I was there. You started
off with saying that we needed speed tables and
the discussion went to child safety. Okay, for me, that's gaslighting.
We're not— that's not what we're there to talk about. Then you shifted
our discussion to Fauci and you stopped trying to
appeal to people's love of children.
And then we're going to try and deflect the anger to Fauci. That's not why.
Trust me, dude. I lost a pretty sweet career in part because
of the policies that that man put out. I hate the guy. Okay. 30 seconds.
But the fact that you're going to try and deflect anger to Fauci instead of
staying on, on task is totally inappropriate. And then the last one
is the biggest one. I'm a war veteran. Never ever
would I use people's ultimate sacrifice as an
example of you're going to be our general and we need to fix bayonets
and go into battle. Especially over taxes. A lot of our brave men
and women have died because of taxes.
So please do not ever do that again. Thank you.
Your time is up. Thank you. Kristen Meyer.
Hi, good evening. I'm Kristen Meyer.
On August 6th, I gave a comment to urge the
city to lower the proposed tax rate to cover only the $1.5 million contract
for the sheriff's office, because I support public safety.
Um, and I was really hopeful because you did lower the tax amount to
183%, and that's progress.
Um, still not quite there, but I was hopeful when I heard
that a group of residents met and the city negotiated a
new rate again. Um, I downloaded the agenda packet
and I pulled the resolution, and there were blank spaces for the
new tax rate and the percentage amount and the dollar amount.
So it was hard to prepare for a public comment because I couldn't see it
beforehand before this meeting. So that would have been more helpful.
Um, and then I just wanted to say, I understand, like,
the city has needs beyond the sheriff's contract. Um,
costs are up for everybody, but incomes aren't rising to
keep up with that. Um, layoffs are
extensive, as you know, and then people who do keep their
jobs are told that, um, they can't get a raise and
that you should just be grateful to have a job. So with our income not
rising, it's hard to keep up with, like, the costs.
Um, and I also want to just be mindful about the Tyson's plant being closed
and leaving families without a job. So, um,
I would support it if the tax rate just covers the
cost of the sheriff's, uh, county contract. Thanks.
Jeff Ruth.
Hey guys, um, I wasn't planning on speaking tonight,
but let me start by saying the roll-on of this sucked.
Um, could have done much better. Uh, I've known
you all pretty much except for Zach over here.
Uh, I remember Jared and
me when he was first running for office, talking on my front porch.
You got to put your trust in something. Got to put my trust in you
guys because you guys are the ones that are looking at the numbers. And then
I see these people, like one guy at the last meeting,
that Pony Express isn't safe for his motorcycle when he's
riding. Well, Yeah, I was thinking about it today
coming down, and yeah, that road is rough. And I've seen other people saying,
well, why didn't they just, you know, repave it?
Well, because that costs a lot of money. Um, but they
don't want to pay for that part, but they complain when it gets, you know,
to make the road itself last longer, that gets crack sealed.
Um, it's just some of the things people come up
with that we need this, we need this, we need this. But then
when you guys try to figure out how to do all that, they don't want
to pay for it. And I've been on the end, like I said at
the last meeting, waiting for a sheriff's deputy to show up.
Um, I've had a neighbor threatening me and my wife,
and we had to wait a little bit for a deputy to get there.
And you know what he told me? Hey, you better be carrying.
Because they knew those people. Um,
and minor things I've called in and
I get a phone call, hey, we can't come out today, we only got 2
officers working this morning. Okay, I understand,
but I believe you'll do the right thing.
I believe you are concerned about the citizens.
You guys know I'm on disability. My pay isn't going to go
up. It's going to be a little bit more rough.
So do what's right.
Think it over hard.
And I'll support you guys.
It, it's hard out there. It ain't going
to get any easier. But we need things done in this city,
like Pony Express fixed. Try drinking coffee
on that road without getting it up your nose. Seconds remaining.
So I wish you guys would tell the people that,
like, for the new city hall that's being planned, hey, we need to get
our employees under one roof instead of having them scattered all over
and paying rent for these buildings. So again,
thank you. Do what's right. Think of us.
Have a good night.
Tracy Peretta.
I'm gonna bring buckets of feathers. Speak to
the mic. Sorry. I was gonna bring in a bucket of tar and some feathers.
Thought it'd be funny. I'm glad you didn't. Yeah, you might think it's a threat.
It wasn't a threat. It was just to be funny. So one
thing that I have an issue with is he's complaining about, uh,
Pioneer— or excuse me, Pony Express. Wasn't it paved last year?
Yes, I rode my bike on it last year. It was a crack
seal treatment. It was a preventative maintenance treatment.
I'll talk to you about it after, but it was different than—
Have somebody come back and fix it if it's not adequate.
Don't pay for service if it's not what it's supposed to be. If everybody's complaining
about it, it needs to be done right the first time. Ask somebody to come
back and fix the problem if it's inadequate.
The other thing is, you guys have all been on the board for a long
time. Donna was on the board. All I ever heard at
every meeting I came to, I objected to it. Let's just build,
build, build. You guys were like drunken sailors.
Seriously, it was bad. I said, don't spend your water rights.
Why are we giving water to everybody? And that's all that you guys did.
And it was ridiculous. So you built, you brought all these people
out here. Everybody came out here because it was cheap. This is
the only place they could afford. Now they're out here and you're going,
oh, now you're going to have to pay all these taxes. Too bad we grew
too fast. Well, you guys didn't put in the infrastructure for
businesses to be able to have a tax base that we can rely on.
All our tax money goes down to Saratoga Springs. They go down to
the Walmart, they go down to the Costco. I mean, it's called retail
leakage. All our money goes there instead of
bringing it into our community and spending it. I've been here for 10 years.
We're just now getting businesses here on the street. It's ridiculous.
You guys have put the cart way before the horse, and you needed to
stop and think about that. So,
the other issue that I had— I'm sorry, I gotta look at my notes.
So everybody says that we need more money for the police department. We have so
many military here. We have not a huge retirement
community, but we have some elderly people here. Why don't we have a citizen volunteer
that can go do the stupid calls that, you know,
kids riding down the street without a helmet on, or he's riding an e-bike.
Those are things that can be taken care of by a citizen patrol. Instead of
taxing our police force to go out and do the piddly stuff,
because they're going to come to my neighborhood and they're going to bring 2 police
officers and they're going to have all their cars there just to ask one little
kid, you know, where's your helmet? Because I've seen it. We passed it last week.
We— 30 seconds remaining. We went down the street. They had
3 police cars pulling one person over. I mean, how many people does it
take to screw in a light bulb? Seriously. It's getting
a little bit ridiculous. We really have
a low crime area, and we need to take advantage of that. Ask the citizens
to help volunteer to take up some of the load and not spend all our
money. Thank you.
Melody Castillo.
Sorry for my appearance. I was getting my kids ready for school
tomorrow and had to run down here. Um,
because like a few other people have said, I have been horrified
by the things that have been said to you guys, and that is absolutely not
okay. And I feel like it's creating this divisiveness within
our— within our, our amazing city.
And this us versus them mentality— people forget you guys live
in this city too. You're voting for or against or whatever taxes
that you— that affect you as well. And I think people forget
that sometimes. Thank you. Um, so I'm so sorry that you're dealing with
all of that, because whether I agree with you or not, I know that
in your hearts you love this city, you love the people of this city,
and you're doing the best that you can.
And so I applaud you guys for that. Um,
second, I apologize to
every other entity In the
city, I don't care what you say. We have the best deputies out
here. Our law enforcement out here is amazing, and I'm
coming from one who I used to be on the side
of we need our own police force, and I don't think
we can do any better than what we have.
I see what they go through. They're stretched
thin, and in what? What other industry,
when you're good at your job, good at your job, do you get punished
by not getting the support that you need, not getting the help that you need?
So I am in favor of an
increase, but I think
that they're going to get the short end of the stick because so many people
are upset. upset about the additional stuff.
And I think that we need to make sure that
we don't sacrifice the needs of our
deputies out here in order to get everything else.
Um, so yeah, that's it.
Um, it looks like Wade S is here. I called him earlier, but he was
not here. Is he here now?
Thank you for the— for giving me time. Um, I haven't been here as
long as most people. I've only been here a few months. I moved here
a few months ago to be closer to family and help out. Um,
but I wanted to start out by saying that, uh,
why, uh, God created police officers is
so firemen could have heroes.
So I'm,
I'm a retired police officer, and so I support,
I support, I support the,
the tax for them, um, because we
need that. We're growing, we're growing fast, um,
and again, I, I do thank each of you for serving in the capacities
that you do. I'm sure it's not easy, but I,
but I do appreciate that. I think that to go back to the table and
reevaluate the other taxes, because we need to get some itemized,
you know, something, some kind of list showing us where this is going.
I love it here already. I plan on being here for a while.
And yeah, just thank you. Thank you for the opportunity for
being here. Okay,
these last couple we received through the recorder's office earlier today. Just want to see
if they are here. Courtney Ramirez stated,
please listen to the residents who are asking you not to raise our property taxes.
And since Charlotte is here, we can just go to you, Charlotte Ducos.
Sorry, I just didn't want to walk in front of everybody.
I teach at the high school, so I have an early morning tomorrow,
but I teach government, and one of
the projects that I do with my students is they take a look at our
city budget every semester. And I'm grateful
for the partnership with the city putting that information together. And one
of my favorite moments is when they take a look at the spreadsheet and realize
how little money they have for the list of projects that they have to do.
And these are actual projects. And they look at me like, how are you supposed
to do this? I'm like, that's a great question. Um, you're, you're elected leaders.
have to figure that out every single year. And, um, if high
schoolers can figure it out, um, by looking at those numbers,
then I think that we need to learn to do the same thing. And,
uh, the interesting thing is I've been working this budget project for
years now, and some of the same projects are on the list
that were there when we started looking at this project. And,
um, Donna mentioned— and Donna and I are good friends Um,
and Donna mentioned that, um, they ran lean and
they did it on purpose because that's how it should be, and I don't disagree
with that. Um, she also said, were we maybe too lean? Um,
that's where, that's where her and I disagree a little bit. I think they were
too lean. I think, uh, government's responsibility is to meet the needs and,
and hoping for income that's maybe going to come and
hopefully next year Um, that's like paying with a credit card.
We— if we don't have that income yet, we're not— like, we, we have
to do something about it. And I appreciate that
the council has taken the time to listen to the residents and to bring the
number down. Um, I think that that's appropriate, but I, I do think that
we need that tax increase. Um, we don't have to get all of those projects,
and we are not going to. Um, the 0.9 that's being— that's on
the table right now Um, is, is not
going to cover even a drop in
the bucket of those projects that have been on the list for years and years
and years. But I think we got to start somewhere.
Um, and I think that officers and employees
to meet the needs of the city that we already have— it doesn't even buy
anything new, just allows us to do the things we're already funding.
Um, I think, I think that that's probably a great place to start.
And, and that's, that's the comment that I wanted to make tonight.
This is another email comment that came in. John J., you're here.
He just states, I do not feel there's justification with the tax increase.
It's rather lengthy, so I'll make sure it's part of the record and get you
a copy as well. Jason Clint emailed.
Another one believes that there's a more reasonable approach to
approve a tax increase that covers additional expense associated with the sheriff's contracts.
Let's see, this one is also rather lengthy, so I can make sure.
He also says, I recognize the city has difficult decisions to make. I'm not
asking you to ignore public safety or the city's financial needs.
I'm asking you to find a reasonable middle ground. So we'll get
that part of the record. Another emailed, Carissa Ferris,
also not here. She is new homeowner.
Another lengthy comment, also opposing the
tax increase. So we'll get that part of the record. We have Olivia Lund,
who did fill out a paper but does not wish to make a verbal
comment. I want to make sure that that was true for Olivia Lund. And her
comment is, because you can't tax some of the most wealthy companies Our,
our rent is being raised and we can't afford to ever buy now
because we pay the difference for corporations. It's from Olivia.
Uh, Mary Compton also wrote in but does
not want to make a verbal comment, I believe. And she
states, your job is to serve the people, present ideas to the people,
and make decisions based on what the people need, not just a few people
who want cleaner parks. Um, and she says,
the rest of us are struggling to make the money stretch as well. You should
also make the money stretch. And the last one we have for
public comment is Emily Buss. She did send in a 2-page letter.
I believe it did get to the mayor, but I don't think it got to
council, so we'll make sure it gets to you as well. Um, she does say
she believes there's a reasonable path forward, um, and does support
the council considering a tax rate between 0.0009 and
0.001. 0010547, and goes
into some specifics, so I can make sure that that gets to you as well.
The final comments that I do have have noted that it's for the public hearing
on 13C on these last couple comments.
That's all I have. Okay,
the ones for 13C will still have a chance to speak. That— okay, I just
want to make sure I heard that right. And, and, uh,
We're nearing the end, so I just want to make sure, is there anyone else?
Yeah, I'm waiting.
So— I think we have Dale. He said he put in a paper,
but I don't see it, so it might still be back there. But just go
ahead and come up if you'd like, and you can fill the paper out after.
Yeah, if that's okay. So state your name for the record, if you would.
Hello, Dale Benson. Uh, thank you so much for,
uh, having this discussion and,
uh, being open. And thank you to the public too for coming out. I was
kind of a latecomer to this conversation, but,
uh, they, they did— some of my friends, they did, um,
tell me I should come down. Um, I'm gonna have to side with
the vast majority right now. against the tax increase.
And I'll just, uh, give it a little context.
I mean, I refer to the great Thomas Sowell,
great economist, started out as a Marxist, thought the government should
be doing all kinds of things. And then he learned, wow, this is the worst
thing that's happening to my community. And he really
started to understand. And, uh, I'm coming from California,
so I've As I started learning more about politics and I
started seeing how deceptive things were,
we've seen this game so many— so often when it's taxes.
Oh, it's going to be for— it's got to be for the fire department.
It's got to be for the police. Oh, don't you want your kids to have
education? It's always the same rodeo. And Thomas
Sowell, I mean, the big picture, inflation is because government
is spending. It's giving money and it's such malicious
games that I saw in California. I mean, it gets to the point where they're
buying votes. That's really what it's coming down to. What's the smallest
common denominator that we can give people money to
where they're going to vote for us and keep us in office? And now we're
seeing tremendous fraud, and this borders on treasonous,
what's happening. They're even bringing people that aren't Americans
and Figuring out, hey, this is a great new voter class.
There's all kinds of things that we're dealing with, but we're dealing with tremendous
inflation. And I'm glad— I'm just going to side with
everybody and say, you know what? The government gets to raise their
wages and stuff. You get to open new city council buildings.
You get to do all those things. Then, oh, we got a raise, but it's
for the police. I mean, we've just seen this game so often,
and of course, people working in the public sector. They might support it,
whether you're in the schools or whether they're in the government.
Hey, we need to raise— things are going up. But inflation,
that every time they say we're going to give you money, now I'm
realizing you're— we're going to lose so much in the future. You're going to pay
for this. I mean, look what Biden was doing, giving money like crazy.
And it's almost like, hey, I'm just practicing. So,
Zelensky, Cloudward and Piven. Let's just
destroy the whole system by overwhelming. I mean, there's a
lot of stuff out there. 30 seconds remaining. Um, I think it's great
that we have a pause on this and
that you realize that we're going to talk about it.
And also Facebook, I've never participated in that,
but there's a lot of passive aggressiveness also that goes on.
Where, oh, we're getting these threats and we're going to frame
one side as being like this when
actually they're the normal side. The things that were talked
about 10 years ago as normal.
Thank you. Your time is up. Thank you.
Okay, I'm going to ask, uh, is there anyone who would like to speak that
has not spoken? I'll address that in 1 second. That has not spoke yet.
Okay, if you will. So why she's coming up, Joy, this is the continuation
of the original time that we said you get 1 opportunity. Now,
now hold on, it's— you can't holler because it's a recorded meeting. So I'm going
to continue. You have 1 opportunity. What I will tell you is there's a public
hearing coming up. That was a little hint. So I'm just telling you, you get
1 opportunity and then there's a public hearing that starts over.
You're absolutely welcome to speak in the public hearing is what I'm trying to tell
you. Um, so my name is Lizette, or is Wendy.
Sorry, I wasn't prepared to speak, but, um, we have toddlers and my husband
stayed a few hours with them, and I'm like, I feel like it's worth it
for them here. Um, I teach them to be brave, and I'm even— I'm like
really nervous. I'm like, I'll do it. Um, so the letter, the letter stated,
um, so yeah, I think that's a point that it kind of makes my point.
I'm like, a lot of families want to be here. We don't have a babysitter,
we don't have family, so it's like we can't be here. And a lot of
people are on Zoom or Facebook, of possible. Hopefully my husband said he can listen
to it, but the letter stated, we hear you. I personally have never seen
any of you at the public park. I have my toddlers at the park every
day, so I'm like, I'd be interested to know where you guys got this information
from. Yeah,
we're always out and about, and I've personally never seen you guys face to face,
but there has to be a better way to get accurate information on what the
residents want and need. From what I understood, the mayoral race was
won with like under 10K votes. And how many residents are there
in Eagle Mountain? So obviously people are not actively voting, which is not your fault,
but it's obviously our fault. We don't take advantage of our rights.
But yeah, it's a very small number compared to all the
residents that we have. We have small kids, full-time jobs. I haven't seen my kids
all day, my son for like 10 minutes while he dropped me off. People living
paycheck to paycheck. What you asked, what to cut out. I think I know it's
probably not gonna be popular, but I mean, I prefer Personally, my kids go to
bed. I'm like, we don't go to the fireworks. We could cut fireworks. I don't
know how much money is invested in that each year. I'm sure they're costly,
including like police officers to patrol and make sure everything's safe and
kid-friendly for everyone. The event at
Nolan Park— we live right next to Nolan Park, and I know there's a free
annual event where the kids get to do the bouncy houses. My kids love it.
I personally would be willing to get rid of that just so we can help
the 3%. Um, our family can afford it. I think it's a blessing to
be able to afford it, but obviously I'm just here to represent people that— like,
my parents are on a fixed income. Um, everything's going up,
utilities, there's bills coming left and right. Um, I work,
um, in a data security company, and there's just businesses closing left and right all
over the country. Um, and then also the other thing, city employees.
Like I said, I'm at the park all the time. There's city employees everywhere.
So I'm like, if there's no money to fix anything, why do have so many
employees, which is something that somebody made in the meeting last time, and I agree
with. Um, we're not against supporting public safety, and I
think that's the most important— Melissa Clark asked earlier. Thank you.
Okay, one more time. Is there anyone else that does not feel like they've had
an opportunity to speak? You're welcome to come forward. Just fill a paper out after,
if you would. And, uh, turn it in.
State your name for the record, please.
Daniel Laub.
Um, hate to be here. Hate to try to address these things. It's no fun,
obviously, and I, I sympathize with the job you guys are trying to do.
Um, we have no idea, obviously, what that side of it is like.
Um, so I'm gonna admit that I
am pretty much against the tax increases right now, just to kind of state
my position in the beginning here. Um, the transparency
just isn't there. We're not seeing— maybe we're just late
to the game, but it's, it's very hard to see and justify these
increases, especially the $220 million. And of course, you backed off of that,
but it leaves us wondering why. Why? that was proposed in the first place,
why that massive amount of an increase was even proposed.
Um, and the whole process for me has
left a lot of distrust in what the process— what
we're actually even doing. We have no idea what you guys are actually trying to
accomplish. Um, there's a lot of vague talk about,
well, roads and improvements and stop signs
and, you know, a lot of stuff that's just really vague. There's no real numbers
to anything of what we're going to do and why we're going to do it
and why it's needed. And right now, with the economy
the way it is, with— I mean, we're facing all kinds of difficulties.
Things aren't getting better if the war doesn't stop. We're facing
a lot more. It could get a lot worse from here. Right now is
a terrible time to raise taxes. Uh,
we are grateful for the sheriffs, what they do. And,
and we would love to try to, to do something maybe
in the future. For me right now, I don't think it's— we just can't swing
it. It's just a bad time to be raising costs above where
we already are. Young people coming in trying to buy homes, I mean,
that's just completely out of reach with the prices the way they are.
Add a couple hundred bucks a year to their overall
cost, and it's, it's, it's enough to put people out of the
the ability to do it.
Um, I, I feel— and, and I'm— and I— how
do I say this? I honestly feel there's a lot of— because
of lack of transparency, I feel like that we're being lied to.
I don't understand where you guys are coming from. This— none of this process has
made sense in like what the needs are. Um, the sheriff thing,
that kind of makes sense. We kind of understand those numbers. We're, we're getting that.
Um, I still don't want to do that right now. Um,
I'd like to say the one thing that I
thought last time we were here that went well was Jared made sure that everyone
that wanted to speak had an opportunity to speak, and I'll congratulate him on that.
And that's all I have to say. Thank you. All right,
I think we've covered it. I do want to make note that the last 2
comments for Dale and Daniel, we do have their papers. They were in my stack
for public hearing. So those finalized. Thank you. Thank you.
Um, if you spoke and did not fill out a paper, that helps us
with our record keeping, if you would please. Um,
seeing no one else for, for our public comment period, I will
now close our public comment.
Um, we do have a lot to talk about. If it's okay
with the council, I can address some of those things that are kind of more
matter of fact if you guys want to speak. Or we can get right into
that discussion. Just really quick, one of the things that I hated about Truth
in Taxation a couple weeks ago was that the residents
are like, you're not being transparent, we want answers, all of those things.
And because of the way that public hearing worked, we couldn't answer their
questions. So I'm left now saying,
oh my gosh, I want to answer all your questions. So how do we address
that, you guys? Because We have answers to all the things that they asked about,
and I know that it's late, so I'm trying to figure out how you guys
want us to get you the answers so you're not left going,
what's going on? I was, uh, I was gonna say that
that's what I offered. I've only got like 4 or 5 maybe that are
kind of easier, and then if there's something I missed, I'm happy to have that
conversation as we go through this process. Just try to keep it brief so
we can keep going. Can I just say one thing? Because it came up so
many times. Sure. But the 3%, you guys, there's a property
tax abatement for senior citizens. If you're 67
or older, you get, um, 20% off
of your value. So they discount that. So right now you
only pay on 55% of your value. If you're 67
or older, you can get another 20% off of that. So that brings the
total value of your home that you're paying tax on down to 35%.
And then there's a dollar amount if you're under a certain income
level that can get given back to you. We also have that
in our state for our veterans. I'm going to ask that
our team on comms help get the links out because
the deadline to that is September 1st. If you guys need
help filling this stuff out and nobody can help you at the county,
call me and I will help you. I don't want anyone to go
home tonight thinking We're trying to screw over seniors. We know
that there's a property tax abatement, and clearly that's another thing that we've been really
crappy at telling people about. So let's get everyone in Eagle
Mountain who's over 67 on that. Thank you.
Okay. Couple of real quick answers just to clarify
some things that are objective, I think, not subjective,
uh, to some of the comments were out there. Uh, number 1,
I want to state Right off the bat, that I can tell you
sitting right here, I have no idea where this is going to land. So anybody
leaves here and says this was predetermined, I don't even know. Uh,
I can tell you that a little while ago before we started the public comment,
that I did hear a 0.0009, and I also heard a
0.0014. And I suspect that the ones that didn't
give a number are probably somewhere in the middle. I don't know. Uh, there has
not been a predetermined outcome, and I'm curious to find out myself.
Number 2, on that note, and I don't even remember who made these,
some of them repeated. Somebody said that 0.0009
is on the table. I'm going to tell you, everything's on the table from
0 to 0.0017.
That's the max. It's all on the table.
Um, I think maybe 0.0015 might be the cap
from our last, but I think it's all on the table because that's what we
submitted, right? Just making sure. I don't think it's
going that way, but I want to clarify that's the truth.
Uh, one, one thing that I— well, and I want to clear up something there,
and there was one specific comment that really said a
lot of things about council's luxuries of being
up here. Oh my goodness, I would love any one of
those. None of us have a car, including me. I provide my own car.
I do get a small stipend that doesn't even cover my fuel, let alone my
car. Uh, none of these guys have a car, a gas
card. None of them get any of that. Uh, their stipend doesn't
cover hardly anything. Uh, there's a little bit, and it wouldn't
cover their expenses, let alone their time. So I'll let you weigh
in. Yeah, I just wanted to clarify on the, on the car in the,
in the budget. It's called a car allowance, but in the Code.
It's actually a phone, internet, travel allowance.
It's $200 a month per council member. So I
just wanted to clarify that, and it's not something you submit for
a reimbursement. It's just part of the code. So I'm open
to changing that in the code. I just wanted to make sure that got answered
as well. As far as lifestyle, it like,
It's not that great, especially right now. So, uh, it's— we're
just like you guys. I get up and come and do my service, and that's
it. Uh, so, so I just wanted to make sure that that was clear,
that there is none of that. Uh, one thing that I wanted to clarify,
uh, a lot of people keep saying, why didn't we plan for this? Why didn't
we put the infrastructure ahead of time? I just want to help you understand,
because I don't want you To pay now for the guy that
comes in later for a free ride. Growth has to pay for growth. And if
we do that now, when you say plan, what you're really saying is pay.
And I don't want you to pay for the next guy, and it's all there
when he gets here. So growth needs to pay for growth. And one of
the ways we do that is through a bond. This sewer plant, we need
2 million dollars— 2 million gallons today. It's about to overflow.
But I don't think you all should pay that bond payment for the guys that
are coming in the future. So we bond for it in order for the next
guy that comes in and pays that impact fee to go towards that payment.
And then the next year and the next year, that's why we bond. So,
uh, not that I'm advocating to vote for bonds, but I'm telling you, it's so
that the next guy pays and you don't. Uh, just a little secret there.
The other thing about no increase, all the people
that said keep it flat or don't increase really, really have to understand
how taxes work. There has been no movement on our taxes, correct?
That's what we could all agree. There's been no movement for at least 16 years.
That's incorrect. And the people that say, well, we're dealing with inflation,
so are we. We're buying this stuff at the store too. The employees
that are pushing lawnmowers— a lawnmower costs more today than it did 16 years ago.
The problem is our tax rate's actually going backwards.
Not only is it not flat, not only is it not growing, it's going backwards.
So, 16 years ago, or 10 years ago, the rate—
and I'm going off memory, so I'm going to forget— was it like 0.0013?
Nothing has changed. And that rate went down to 0.012,
down to 0.101, to 0.09, to where it is today, to 0.05.
It's not that we kept it flat. We allowed it to go backwards.
And so to say tighten your belt or find
other money, how? It's continually leaking backwards, yet we're
trying to go forward with more services. So that's more of an
educational piece. Not that I'm advocating for one or the other.
I don't know where this is going to land. I just— that is a
fact that I'm telling you that that's the way they go.
Look at— you've got your tax bill right there. If you look
year over year at the previous one, that rate has continued to go down.
Is that not true? That is true.
I paid the same property tax for the last 12 years that I
lived in my house. So, and, and the rate went down in order
to keep that, so the inflation went past the rate and you continue to go
backwards. That's right. It's, it's about $220, I think.
So, so I want to make sure that people understand
that it's not a matter of trying to raise taxes. We're trying to stay even,
to even continue to provide services. I am happy
to sit down and help you walk through that, to explain that. It's not because
I advocate for a raise. It's none of that. I want you to understand why
we're in this situation and how can we correct it and move forward. I also,
uh, some of the rest of stuff that I've commented on Facebook, but I'm telling
you, there are better days ahead. We have to bridge
the gap until those collections come in. We can't go backwards
and provide the same service with a growing population, with added lane miles, added parks,
added deputies. There's no physical way that we can do it.
So, uh, I think that's the bulk of, I think, what I
felt were the questions that I hope that answered some of those.
If not, I'm happy to talk to anyone, and I'm happy to
turn it to you guys if you want to add to those.
If I could, just to Gary's question on mandating
future councils, that's something that we're not legally allowed
to do. For example, there's a couple of council members here when they served in
their time, they couldn't require or obligate or
bind future councils to do certain things. And so the code
that we're putting in place simply calls the councils
to account where they publicly will say, we're not going to maintain that
coverage ratio and why. And I think as a, as a citizen,
that would have been nice to have from my perspective.
So that's what we're trying to do is create some kind of environment or,
or more than a culture, something that is in our code that
will force councils to eliminate that code
to not be held accountable. So I hope that helps answer that question.
Thank you. That was a great question, by the way. I want to address the
question of why did we buy land for City Hall?
Uh, because the cost of land is increasing substantially
year over year. Unfortunately, it's something we probably should have done 5 or
6 years ago because it would have been half what it is now.
And so to be able to do that in the future, again, we have
a limited amount of money that, that we have to be able to work with.
We felt like that, that was a good investment in the future, because then that
land can be developed when the money is there to build City Hall. So I,
I know that it seems like that there's a lot of deception.
And man, I wish, Mr. Lab, there was a way for
me to undo how you're feeling about all this.
I also understand where you're at too. Um,
it's not an intentional thing. I said
in the very beginning, and I, I think I've said this multiple times from this
dais, we have to be better at communicating in multiple
ways. I think we've relied heavily on social media, and I
think that has been a big mistake. Um, to the point
with the 3 percenters, most of them are not even on there. So how are
they even getting that information? And I think that we are relying on
an algorithm that's constantly pushing us towards content they want us to see rather than
what we want to see. And we have to find some
better ways to communicate. I'm going to tell you,
that is one of the commitments that I have, though, is not
to get stuck on this topic for too long. But I think the code needs
to start with what we're doing with our property tax. And maybe one of— that's
maybe one of the things I want to clarify. For some reason, that message is
not hitting. So I just want to say this on the record so
you hear me say it. The intent of the very first 0.0017
was to cover the entire contract with
stable income. The only stable income that we have as
a city is property tax. That's it. And that covers the one
thing that everybody uses. There isn't a single person in this city
that does not use public safety to some degree.
In order for us to fund the entire contract, we're not talking about the
increase. We're talking about the entire contract. It's almost $10 million.
What we were looking at is making that stable income from property tax
to pay for that. What that does is then free up the other sales
tax revenue that we've been supplementing that with so that we can start to
do some of the things that you guys are talking about, not just It can't
all be build a road. Some of it has to be, we can't crack seal
this. It's time to tear the road up and fix the underlayment
that's washed away over years and to put proper asphalt on it. We need to
be able to make some of those decisions, but you can't do that when everything
is always, you know, so low as far as what our income
is. And so that was what— that's the reason. The reason that we did that
in the first instance was for that reason. If we fund all
of our public safety with our stable property tax that allows our variable
income from sales tax to be used for projects as we set them
priority-wise. And to your point again, Mr. Laub, I don't
think we did a good job of saying, here's the list of projects, there's 400
of them. And we have to prioritize based on what we actually have.
That's a year-over-year decision. We'll have to look at that and say,
look, we only have $6 million. We can't build this,
this, and this, but we can hit maybe these 3 things in here,
or maybe we can leverage that money in a way that will allow us to
do maybe one of the bigger projects. Our other problem is, is that we also
have to have somebody to do the project. And if you don't have manpower
to do it, how do you get the project done? I think it was Charlotte
that said we have projects that have been there year over year. The reason
why? Nobody to do them.
So we're trying to fix some of those problems. Again, I want
to be just upfront with what the problems are that we're facing. You need to
know what they are so that we can make better decisions. And I hope you
guys come back with better ideas. Whoever the gentleman was that said maybe we
need to raise the fees, we have tried everything we can
to stave off the state. I'm going to tell you that right now, to keep
them from dumping every single house that they want to be built in
the state in Eagle Mountain. And one other thing I want to make with regards
to the data centers— those data centers prevented them from
putting houses there. That was their intent from the state. They wanted to fill
every single square mile. of Eagle Mountain with houses. That enabled
us— not only do we get a benefit, by the way, from that, but it
stopped them from being able to be houses that we can't— we cannot service them.
I mean, that's the truth. We're stretched. We have— we had 2
cities that were built at the same time with nothing in between, and we were
trying to connect everything with services, with sewer plants, with trunk
lines, with all of those things with no money. And I just—
that's the truth. That's the truth I want you to be aware of that we're
trying to solve now, you know, 10, 15 years later. So I appreciate the
comments. Hopefully that gives a little bit of context to some of those things.
Anybody wants to have a conversation, my telephone number is
always there. You can call me. I may not be able to answer that.
My job has become a little more involved during the day, but I will definitely
call you back. Anybody who's called me knows that that's the case. So. Reach out
to me. So I
wanted to address— you had a question about the 183%. And so,
and I'm happy to stay after and talk if you're able to stay, and we
can talk through that. But I'll explain briefly. I'm the one that came up
with that number. That was also from last— the Truth in Taxation. There was no
predetermined number at that time. I was the one that proposed that to the council.
The council at the time supported it. We've now repealed it. So that number doesn't
exist anymore. But, but the— here's, here's the math I used to come up with
that number. So, understanding that what Councilmember Wood just
said, that the intent of the tax increase was to place the property
tax dollars and public safety together, that would cover the new growth in public
safety. And then sales tax dollars were previously supporting public safety,
would then be able to divert to other, to other resources.
So, so the 183% would clear our
our new hires that we needed for the Sheriff's Department. It would also hire
a minimum number of employees that we need to fill some staffing needs,
which that was a pared-down list, by the way. It's public. It's a public list.
Anybody can see exactly what that list was.
We debated for a long time coming up with those. So it gave us the
sheriffs, gave us that, that the minimum number of employees, and then
it gave a small wage increase as well. Our city employees
are already paid somewhere between 80 to 85% of the median for
equivalent municipal work. So the wage
increase doesn't even get them up to 100%, but gets them up for a little
bit, and then it leaves a little bit more somewhere in the $2 million-ish range
that could then be used toward accelerating capital projects within
our city. But for me, what that also
then did, that $2 million, capital projects now,
but what it allows for 20, you know, next year when we come
into this cycle, we know that given the population increase, the sheriffs will need
more. So, in my mind, that was budgeting a little bit extra to
absorb a potential next year increase. So that's how I came up with 183.
That's why I proposed that to the council. And that's where we landed
on that. But if you want to talk more about that afterwards, I'm super
happy to meet with you. Um, and then I'll just address some other things real
quick. So, uh, a citizen commented, and I,
I should have written down everybody's name, and I apologize. Separate tax rate for businesses.
It's an excellent idea that needs to happen at the state level.
Um, yeah, yeah, go ahead. I'm going to jump in and again
throw a bone to one of our data center partners, and I don't mind saying
which one. In this case, QTS. Uh, not only did
they say, I agree with that, they also reached out to our legislative
assistant. I don't even know if I've told the council this and said, Will you
help us write legislation and make that happen? Is that true, Evan? Evan's our legislative
guy. QTS said, we want that. We want to pay more so
you pay less. So I want that to be out there for you guys to
understand what QTS specifically is doing on that piece. They agree
with you. Okay, and then a resident talked about why don't
we have volunteers that help the police? We actually do. It's called the VIPS program,
Volunteers in Police Service. We need more VIPs. So if you're—
if that's something that interests you, go talk to the VIPs. I'm sure if you
look online, we'll be able to find their, their contact info.
Hey, we're recording the meeting, so we're happy to answer that question,
but nobody can hear you. So yeah,
so you can talk to our sheriffs after, or they could go out
in the hall. They've got all the information, and we, we're happy to get that
to you. I just— we just can't hear their Recording. So, no, I'm sorry.
And, and I'll tell you, just to back up a little bit on the hires.
So we had to pare down the original list of, you know,
requests that came into us. But one that we pared down that we probably
need to revisit once there's funding for it is a community services director who would
then be able to help in a number of ways,
and one including communications, but organizing volunteerism and things
like that in the city. So, but we do have volunteer police force that helps
with things that you're talking about. Um, and I have been— anyway,
and I won't talk a lot about this now, but it's— there's a fundraiser that
we're going to be putting on for them that I, I'll talk about later in
the meeting for anybody that stays around later. Uh, but that's there, and it's a—
that's a really good question. It's something— it's a program that we should, we should
increase and enhance and enlarge. So, uh,
I appreciate that. Um, DJ, I really appreciate your comments.
Thank you. Part of, part of the challenge of this setting
is being able to, like, we have
to listen and speak, but we can't dialogue and just go back and
forth at the same time. And I think when, when you're in a setting when
you can go back and forth at the same time, it helps to clear up
a lot of misunderstandings. I can see how you, you took that statement from
a handful of days ago the way you did, and I apologize if it came
across incorrectly. Same with Melissa. So I'll
clarify it a little bit here. So when I was just trying to think of
an example of when a leader had made a decision that
the group necessarily didn't necessarily like,
but he took them to a place where he felt it would be most successful.
And that was the extent of the analogy. I didn't mean anything relative
to taxpayers being on this side or that side. It was us as a community
together, all in the union, not in the Confederate. So I apologize if that was
that confusing. No, I think that's great. came across incorrectly. And that really was the
extent of it. I've— it's America 250, so I've been reading a lot of history
books this year, and that was just the first thing that came to my mind.
But I really appreciate that you brought that up. And that's what's
healthy with communication, because it enables whether the speaker or
the listener to clarify what their intent was. And so it was appropriate for
you to bring it up in a public setting. It was made in a public
meeting. So thank you. I appreciate that. And I'll
clarify. So the reason why I brought up speed tables is because one of the
other residents at the public hearing Specifically asked council members to name a capital
project they were interested in. That's the reason we brought up speed tables. It's on
top of my mind. It's at the top of their minds. Meant nothing beyond that,
aside from that. And the reason why I brought up the Fauci thing is to
applaud us together, that we need a healthy skepticism of
government leadership, and really to applaud the number
of people that showed up last time and tonight. Like, this is healthy. We need
to be skeptical of the decisions that government leaders are
making on all levels. Thank you. So that's really the intent.
And I'd be happy to talk to you afterwards if there was something additional.
I'm always happy to talk to you. So thank you for coming. Thank you for
your comments. I appreciate that. Let's see,
I think, yeah, I think that's— I think that's— oh,
I do believe it would be important, I think, to help talk about the
sort of the state requirements that are placed upon the city and how we communicate
the tax truth and taxation. I don't know if we want to go into that.
I think there needs to be work done at the state level, but I'm not
here to disparage them any more than I want them to disparage us. So I
prefer that, that we understand if there's questions, read the state code.
We, we are working with our legislators. We're working on legislation to raise taxes on
data centers. Can't wait, you know, but, but I'm, uh,
I'm not in a hurry to— we need to fix the process because it's kind
of got us handcuffed, if that's fair to say. One thing that came up earlier,
we talked about how we can make sure our residents know what we're facing
earlier. And we're talking about, in addition
to the code that they are working on to kind of lock public safety
money into its own little space, um,
creating something so that there's specific metrics that have to be
given to council every year, but they're also given to the residents. So you guys
can look at it and go, oh, call volume's done this. This is how many
deputies we have, or this is how many acres
of new park space we have this year. And this is
how many employees we have. So, like, just clear metrics. And then the
other thing, um, that I'm actually— I think
we should push our state legislators to add this to the Truth in Taxation,
but to add the budget in brief. So our comms
team made the budget in brief so that it would explain some of the terms
and a little bit about the budget. But I— we're proposing,
and we've talked a little bit about having something that's just like a very
condensed version of the budget, 10 pages
or less, that has like a list of the employees
that are being proposed, a list of capital projects, like some of those things,
so that when we get the 429-page
budget that we need to read, you guys can have
the 10-pager and it will help you understand some of the things that we're
talking about. Kristen brought up the blank spaces in
the thing, and that was purely because We didn't have a predetermined rate.
We had to come and sit up here to talk to each other about it.
So sorry that that happened. Um, there was a question about the $30,000
building permit. The state governs us so carefully, and every
time we try to change impact fees or building permits, we get like protested by
the Home Builders Association. Now, crack seal treatment
in our city. Every single road, um, every 5
years gets a preventative maintenance. So, like, it's the difference
between us not wearing sunscreen and wearing sunscreen.
That's what my street guys tell me. So I'm just giving you my, like,
overly simplified version. What happened on Pony Express was
not resurfacing. It was a preventative maintenance
treatment because we don't want to pay to resurface right now because
we've got so many stupid utility projects we have to accomplish. God bless
our utility guys, but we don't want to waste money on resurfacing.
So we do those preventative treatments because it helps
prolong the life of our roads, and we try to have that,
like, go through all the streets in our city so that they
all are getting that preventative maintenance. Because in the end, preventative maintenance means
we have to replace roads less frequently. We have to rehab
roads less frequently. There's a ton more questions, but we all are willing
to sit down with you when you have more. It's— oh, last thing,
transparency. We start the budget, our staff
starts the budget in October, and they start talking about all these things, and they're
doing long-term plans, all of that. Then we
have a meeting in January where staff says, this is some of the stuff we're
looking at. Then we have a 2-day ridiculously long
meeting that they trick us to come to by calling it a retreat
when it's not a It's just a really long meeting, you guys.
But in that, that's all public. You guys can actually come to that,
and we go through every little need. Then every single month
between then and when we pass the budget in June,
there's another budget work meeting. Every single one of those
pages, all of it is available to everyone.
It's on our website. It's in the public meetings thing. I want
you to know that even though we couldn't articulate
where you could find that stuff, or understood that you guys didn't know how to
get to it, it was there. We didn't hide anything
from you. It's always been there. So let's
get more of your questions answered, and I'll shut up now.
Okay, so real quick, Lacey, if you don't mind putting that up. I was
wrong. I don't mind admitting it because I said I was going to use a
round number, but for education's sake, I have been putting this out. For months.
And I teach some— a lot of classes. I won't get into that, but I
tell my students that if, if you don't understand it, you got to stop me
and tell me to say it in a different way, because it sounded great when
it came out of my mouth, but I'm not getting this through. So I want
you to understand when I say taxes are going backwards and that you've paid the
same amount and you're actually losing to depreciation. Study this,
share it, and help me educate the neighbors, because obviously I'm not doing
it right. Because every other post says that when my house goes up,
the value goes up, and that is just not— or the taxes go up with
the value. It does not. It does not. It goes down
when your value goes up. Uh, so here's, here's an example.
In 2016, we have not raised taxes.
The rate was 0.001081. That was the
rate, and we have not touched it since. And the taxable value is $116,000.
Paid to Eagle Mountain City was $125,098. That's how much
we got in 2016. Today we got $125.38.
By the way, by my math, that is a 40-cent decrease in
the amount of money paid to the city. 60 cents, 40 cents. I don't
know. I can't do math. But it took years to get there. Yeah,
I mean, it was only 40 cents over. So,
so again, hey, hold on. We gotta have some order here.
So. Um, I know we're joking. In 2017,
$10.11. In 2018, $9.24,
$8.25, all the way to the rate we're at today of $5.34
taxable value per $100,000. As your house goes up,
per $100,000, $108, $101, $92,
$82. Tell me to tighten my belt.
I did, to $53. Can't go anymore.
Can't do it. Uh, change from the rate since '16,
50.60% without inflation.
That's without inflation. That's at a '26— a
2016 value. We have lost 50%.
Not today's value, 2016 value. Uh, estimated market
value, just so that you can understand this and help me explain that that's the
problem that we're facing. I hope I'll leave that up for a few minutes,
but I hope you can understand. What I have been trying to articulate
and why we're in this position. Mayor, really quick, there was a question that
came from the audience. There's more houses. Why aren't— why isn't this increasing
our revenue? So I can answer that. We are
in Utah, what's called a revenue-based system, which means we ask
for amount of money in 2016, and it does change
a little bit, and this is going to get a little bit more tricky to
understand. So, I wish I'd get a little leeway on this one, but I'll
try to be as articulate as I can. We basically asked for
$1.9 million in 2016. And then in 2017,
we asked for $1.9 million. In 2018, we asked for $1.9 million. Now then,
why did we get $3 million this year? Because that's the growth number of the
base, and you get that year's growth and then it goes backwards. But the reason
that that doesn't equate anything to the budget is because you also increase services.
It costs you more. So we're still getting a 1.9
value like here, even though it's $3 million here, that's only $1 million.
But we increased our expenses in the 18 new parks they
built with those new houses and the 2,700 new lane miles
that they put in and all those water connections. We are now spending
millions more, and we increased by $1 million based
on that growth factor at the given rate. So,
so growth actually hurts us because it costs
us way more than it, than it generates. And so, so,
so, and I know that that's a little bit more of
a loaded question, but that's the growth question.
It, it makes— it compounds the fact that we didn't
go up way more quickly. It compounds
it. So the only way to offset that is through economic development, which we've done
a great job, including in the past councils. We, we've been trying to get things
in here that pay. So please understand that this is what we're wrestling
with. This is why if, if councils every year,
the 85% idea but completely different code,
just said we're just going to adopt this rate and keep it going forward,
guess where we'd land today with the people that said the, the COVID the
sheriff's at? It's that number. But guess what we would have had all along?
We would have got that number every single year in here and not had that
decrease. We would have had plenty of extra money by keeping
it flat. We didn't keep it flat. We lost money every single year.
Now, I'm happy to have that conversation, and you can debate it and tell me
I'm wrong. Okay, that's fine. I'm happy to have that conversation with
anybody that wants to learn more about how taxes work. So I hope that
helps. Um, I'm gonna leave it there. You guys can study that.
Go look at your own tax bill and tell me that's any different than that.
And by the way, when you say, well, then how come it went up?
This is the Eagle Mountain line. What's not on here is Alpine School
District, the sewer plant, the water district. The reason your bill went
up, not according to your value, is because somebody
raised your taxes, but it wasn't the city. It was probably— well, the school
district did 10 out of the last 12. I lose track because it's every
year. They've done it almost every single year. So I could probably say the school
district. I also know the water district raises our taxes quite a bit. To a
flat number. UFSA has raised our taxes almost
every year. That's about change because it's going to come in-house. So, yes,
your taxes have gone up, not to the city.
So those are the things that I'm trying— help me, please help me educate
your neighbors. That's, that's the situation. Is there anything else?
Let's talk about the item if we can.
So I'll lead off. I've heard a few different numbers. I've heard there's a 0.09
idea. I've heard of 0.14, and I'm dropping the zeros, so forgive me.
Uh, 0.009 and a 0.014.
And for clarity's sake, I do
have to put one more thing out there to help the council and the public.
Uh, people say, I want to know the, the percentage. The percentage is only,
only relevant if you know the base, because 10% of
a dollar is a lot different than 1% of $1,000. It just isn't
the same thing. So the percentage looks big, but that's because
the rate's so low. Eagle Mountain City at this
number is the 2nd lowest tax city minus UFA.
I get it in the entire county. So when we— 200%,
when everybody was shocked at 200%, is because the base,
it's because of this number. Uh, the same,
for instance, and I'm not going to throw our neighboring cities under the bus.
But they might have only done 12% or 25% or 50%, but that
50% generated more than our 220%.
So to me, the percentage is only relevant if you use
the denominating number. How much did it generate per month?
How much did it cost? That's got to be the— it has
to be part of the discussion or the rate doesn't matter. So with that,
I think Kimberly's still online. We haven't talked to her in a while. I,
I believe The numbers that I've heard,
for instance, a 0.0009 is 69.
Can I, can I just make a comment here? I'm happy to get help.
I'm trying to be neutral. I don't just— just to start a conversation.
So it's interesting looking at the 2016 rate at 0.001081.
If just as an example, if we were to go back to that
rate, what that would do is that would create
just over $3 million. So $1.5
million of that, uh, well, that, that would cover 62%
of the sheriff's contract, and it would effectively free
up $1.5 million somewhere else in
our budget for staffing raises. We, we've— in
our last meeting, we talked about, uh, considering about $1.3
million in new hires. I think 4 of those would be more administrative
in the city, and 14 of those would be parks, rec,
open space, neighborhood improvement.
What am I missing? There's, I think, a few others.
Engineers, engineers.
Somebody's got to approve things.
So, so at that rate, that's effectively what would happen. We've also talked
about Which I didn't know this, but when Eagle
Mountain was established, maybe it wasn't when it was established,
but we don't pay for Social Security
for our employees. Is that fair to say?
Am I okay to say that? If it's not, I just did. Okay.
So, we opted out of that system. Our employees have a pension plan.
So, for me, I pay 6.2% at work
and my employer pays 6.2%. So when we're talking about getting to 90th
percentile of the median, what we're really trying to do is put our staff
at par of what their peers make. And I shared this in
our last meeting that my neighbor used to work for Eagle Mountain. We trained
him up. He does amazing concrete work. He now works at Harriman. He doesn't
have to go far. It just waits for an opening and then leaves our city,
and then we have to find somebody new, train them up.
Uh, just to, to lose them. So that consideration
is, is about half a million dollars to bring our, our staff up
to what, what would be considered a median income.
So when we stack those, those, just those 3 items,
uh, $1.5 million to the Sheriff's Office, $1.3 million for,
uh, staffing, and, uh, half a million dollars for
to, to bring our employees up, that's $3.2 million
is what we're considering. So, let me summarize at the 0.0010
rate going restoring back to the 2016 rate,
that would generate about $3 million. So it'd be a little bit short, which means,
um, you know, we would certainly put off capital projects.
Which is, uh, you know, that, that, that's fine.
We, we can wait on those, I guess. Um.
I think that that's all I want to say. If we go down to the
0.009 number, that generates
$2.1 million. And so that would require that we move
into our reserves if we intend to achieve those 3
objectives. Okay, so I hope that's helpful for those that are here.
You gave all the numbers that I didn't, and the one I was looking for
was the percentage. I think it was 69 or 70%.
And at the, uh, 52— okay, so it is— and
I'm sorry if I'm confused because the people want to know the percentage, even though
I don't know that it matters to me. I apologize. The 0.0009
number would cover 52%,
52.95%. Cover, you mean that's the percentage
raise of the— that's the shared contract. They want to know how much
is it raised, the increase. I'm sorry. And I think it's right around 7— going
from 183%, that, that would be 69.81%. Yes. And, and I only
This number because a resident shared it with me that I think is still here,
but the 0.1054
is roughly 99%. It's under 100. Okay.
So, so, so just to give it the nominal dollars for
median house, that would increase 0.0009. That would increase the
annual dollar to $99. So that'd be about $8.27
a month. I think at that rate, and Mayor, I think just for clarity,
we— I want you to know what we're looking at. Okay, I mean, our finance
department sent this out to us earlier in an email and it just has a
bunch of different rates to consider. That's it. So it doesn't say,
here's the one you should pick. It doesn't say, here's the one you've decided.
It says, here's the impact if you do this, here's the impact
if you do this, here's the impact if you do this, here's the impact if
you do this. I want you to know that's what I'm looking at. I don't,
I don't know what everyone else is looking at, but that's what I'm looking at.
And because I'm old school, I had to print it. That's what I did.
So roughly 99% at close to that 10.5
number, and at the 9, it was 70, just, just shy of 70.
So anywhere in between there. Does that answer the question on the percentage?
I hope so. But I think it's helpful to, instead of talking about percentage,
what's the monthly increase? Yes, and I agree with that. But I think,
well, I understand that these guys want to know the percentage,
right? Right. But that's where I'm saying 0.0009 gives—
is a $99 a year $8 and change a month.
Mayor, can I ask that we shift this conversation? I'm kind
of tired of going around and around and around and around. I think it's important
that we just establish where we want to be. And I don't know where everyone
is going to be. So I'm just going to give you my 30 cents.
I mean, I thought a lot about this, and, and frankly, I,
I was okay at the 1.5, and I know that that will probably get me
beat up again. Um, but I was because
I think that the investment in our community is worth it.
But I've listened to what the people have come and what they've said, and I've
heard from a lot of you. And, and just as I've listened
to the people, I've tried to listen to our staff,
I've tried to listen to our Sheriff's Department, and I've tried to really be
in tune with what it is that they need. And so for me,
what I would like us to consider at, at a bare
minimum and it's probably going to be more than what some may be comfortable
with, but for me, I think we should, we should fund the
increase in the sheriff's contracts with the $1.5 million. Okay.
Those employees that we hammered through all of those positions
and worked through to whittle that list down, I think we should fund those positions.
And I think that we should fund the, the $525,000
that does give our existing employees a raise and gets
them to that median. As I understand it, the number
that will most likely accomplish that is the, the 0.01100.
That's kind of where I'm thinking we should be. I,
I mean, I heard you, Councilmember Hewish, say point,
you know, the 0.00900.
Anywhere in between there is going to work. But I— what I hate
to do is to short-sell our existing employees and to say no to the new
hires that we so desperately need. Because just as our sheriff's
contract is woefully undermanned, so are
our employee staffing levels.
And look, I don't have the data to hand
you that. I just have the experience that I've had, and I've watched the
workloads that they're trying to do. That may not be enough for,
for the citizens, and, and, and I'm okay accepting that.
From my perspective, that's the, that's the direction I think we should go.
For me, I think that it needs to be at the 0.0009.
I probably said too many zeros. Um,
I know that we're going to have additional revenue. I know that
there's things that are coming, and I
know we need to hire staff, and I know we
need to deal with the sheriff's contract, but I feel
like that is the
most that I want to go because I, I really do want to make sure
that we're not raising it too much.
And I think the $8.27 feels more manageable
to people than You know, $30-something.
So, um, and I totally get where you're at.
I respect it. I am worried that with
the number that I just said, it— if we fund
all that stuff, it brings our reserve down to 19.51%.
And just so you guys know, the state maxes us out
at 35% for our reserve. So it is stepping
us into, uh, an area that
some people aren't super comfortable with, but I,
I just, I feel like we're headed in the right direction financially,
and I think that this is a good measured approach. Councilmember Clark, can I just
ask for clarification then? And I, I, I, I think it's a reasonable
approach that you're suggesting. My question is really Um,
what you're— what I'm hearing you say is that you still agree with the staff
hiring, but you would fund it from reserves. That's what I'm hearing you say.
And I know that every single staff member that has a Master of Public
Administration is like cursing me right now because they're like, you can't fund
employees and ongoing expenses with reserves.
But I also know what's coming with MET. I know
what's coming. With property tax. And, um,
I think if we can ask our residents to trust
us and help us get to this lower rate, we can also
say we trust that
this money is going to come in. And the reality of it is, you guys,
if it doesn't come in next year, then we're going to have to have this
conversation again. But I'm willing to do
this for 1 year. to see if we can make it instead of raising it
higher. Thank you, that's helpful for me. Thank you.
And it would drop reserves from 35 to 19 if
we fund all of it. So like, if you look at the chart that staff
gave us— sorry, you guys, we should have it for you guys to look at—
but if you look at that, it— what it does is it said general fund
reserves, $12 million. You— do you have it on email? You can put it
Um, it says $12 million, 32% of
the 2026 budget. So it's telling you in that 2nd
to last line what the difference is that you'd have to make up
if we fund all the things that we said we were going to fund.
But if we pare down and maybe slow some
of the hires, and we do a couple of them in 3 months instead
of like tomorrow, I think that That could help us minimize
that impact on the reserve. And I can tell that Colby Curtis is going
to yell at me later for this. But— No, I think
in our next budget item,
once this is decided, that's where we're going to bring the hatchet,
start cutting. So,
I mean, I think I've already stated my, my position. I wasn't in favor of
repealing it. I think we need the 0.15.
We need something. There's no question about that. And I,
I think I appealed to the citizens, say, then you're gonna have to be okay
with what we can afford, and that's gonna—
that's definitely going to be something that you'll feel. Thank you. Um,
but at the end of the day, you'll know you're heard.
If we do that, that means that we are all agreeing that we're not
going to be able to do the things that are needful, and we'll have to
live with whatever we can do. And that will be some diminished
things, um, whether we're talking about the— when
we can replace roads, when we're talking about whether or
not we can bring our current parks that we own up to a reasonable
baseline. But if we're all in on that and everybody
understands that, then we'll expect that the— that we're all in the same place and
we'll do this together. So I
think 2.0009 is too low.
The thing that's just weighing on my mind is the Tyson experience.
And, you know, we have reserves for a
moment when the city experiences a challenge. And so in
my mind, I, I, I feel this is a moment where I'm comfortable dipping
into the reserves. I, I'm not— I— what I am not comfortable
doing is reducing the velocity the city needs in terms
of its hiring and wage increases. The sheriffs— I'm not comfortable
reducing that speed. I— we, we need that.
If it, if it weren't for Tyson, I think I'd be having a different
thought right now. But based on what happened with Tyson,
there's, from what we can understand, about 400 families.
Family average family size is a little over 4. The 1,600, 1,700 people,
maybe 1,800 people affected, it's a decent percentage
of our population. And that's where I do feel comfortable dipping into reserves.
I, I think good governance— I, I go back to the beginning of where we
sort of direct— like, started with this good governance— is that we will
set the rate at a level that enables the, the city to achieve
what it needs for its primary services.
And so I, I, I am still grateful
for the direction we headed. I do feel like the, the,
uh, landscape changed a little bit when it came to the Tyson situation, and that's
where I'm, I'm willing to dip into some reserves. So I feel like I'm willing
to go down You know, and the 0.0009 number only
came out when we're talking about the 75% threshold that we're talking
about with the, you know, the coverage ratio for our
public services. And that's based on some calculations of what
will happen next year that Councilmember Hewish ran. And so when
that number came out, and I'm looking at things, I'm willing to go down to
that reserve, you know, to dip into some reserves
to hit that number. If there's no other comments, I'm going to see
if we can get to a motion, but I'm never going to rush you.
I know it's a big deal, so make a motion.
Uh, this is 13B, correct?
Yes, 13— yes, B.
Mayor, I move that the city council
approve a resolution of Eagle Mountain City, Utah, approving a
property tax Increase above the certified tax rate for
fiscal year 2026-2027 of
0.000900.
Finish the statement. Is there anything else? Can I— yeah, do you want me to
finish that statement? Is there anything else that we have to add to it?
I, I believe you have to say the dollar and roll
results for fiscal year 2026-2027.
This rate exceeds the certified tax rate of 0.000530
and will result in an increase in the city's ad valorem property tax budgeted revenue
of approximately, uh, let's see here,
approximately $2,132,876,
or 69.81% Above
the city's property tax budgeted revenue for the prior year, exclusive of new growth.
Thanks for the assist, Councilmember Whiting. So I'll, I'll second
it. I'll second your motion. If you're the one that started it, I'll second that
one. Thank you. Okay, we good, Lacey?
Okay, uh, we do have a motion and a, uh, a second.
Motion by Councilmember Clark, second by Councilmember Whiting. Is there any questions?
All right, I, I think I lost track, but I think I was here.
So, Councilmember Whiting. Yes. Councilmember Wood? No.
Councilmember Hughes? Yes.
Councilmember Clark? Yes. Councilmember Wright?
It's immaterial what I say, Mayor, but I will vote yes.
Thank you. Uh, 4-1 if I'm counting, so that passes.
Uh,
um, now I'm at a— what's that? Did I— I thought I heard
something. Um, do, do we want to do the budget now? I think we got
to do the budget now and then go back to the other 2 because we've
skipped some, and I'm trying to find out the order that— you're the one that
asked for it. Messed you up. So are we good with the budget? Yeah.
All right, uh, we're gonna go to item 13C,
uh, resolution, and this is a public hearing, so anybody that wants to comment
on this, uh, resolution of Eagle Mountain City adopting the fiscal year 2026-27
annual budget. totaling $363,992,973.
Um, we do have Kimberly here, uh, I think,
and I'll bring it to the council.
I'm not sure, Kimberly, if you had a presentation or how this affected
the— this tax rate changes things. Does the
council need— Mayor,
I am here. I'm trying to see if I can get my stuff to activate
really quick. But we did have a
presentation that was prepared on the budget.
A lot of it talks about like the budget process in general.
I can run through that if the council would like.
If it's a matter of wanting to get in to
talk about what adjustments will take place,
obviously we don't have a total amount
For the budget now, because it depends on what the council wants to do with
this reduction in revenue.
So, council, that's— I know, and then some of those things for the sake of
the public, and I know you guys have been here a long time, we've been
doing this for months, uh, all of the questions
we keep getting, the council keeps coming back to staff saying we have got to
help these people understand. So a lot of what Kimberly's talking about is she,
she's answered some of those questions if you wanted to go through those,
or are we tired enough that we just move forward? Uh,
so Kimberly has some, some of the answers, I believe,
from the different questions have been asked throughout the week about
the transparency process, which we've shown it, but maybe
explaining it while the people are possibly— I think it's helpful for the people
to hear this. So, so it'll be on the record. I think it'd be good
too to show the list of employees that We're targeting, because we've,
you know, kind of thrown them out there, but it would be good to see
it concretely again. So, yeah, and I know it's a school night
and whatnot, but Kimberly, yeah, go ahead with some of those questions,
and we'll just try to get it done as
quickly as we can.
I think you're muted, Kimberly.
Yeah, okay. There you go. Let me see
if I can share my screen.
Okay, are you guys able to just see
the— Yes, we can see your screen.
I am— Can you go to full screen so it's easier for people to see
it? Yes, that's why I was trying— I had to wait for the little bar
to move away so I could access that part really quick. So Um,
there's a couple of things that I wanted to be able to share
with the community in our agenda that are just the items
that we're going to try to cover tonight. And again, it is still
really high level, but talking about our budget process,
our timeline, what are the things we try to accomplish with the budget,
a couple of things related to service delivery, and then the budget
overview. But before we get into that, I did want to address
some of the questions specifically that kind of have come up in
the conversations with the, with the council about the
budget process in general. So one of the challenges
is having been
involved in a number of meetings, right? We've— you
guys are all aware of, we have a lot of internal staff meetings,
we have a lot of council meetings, there's been a lot of work that has
gone into everything. But what I can recognize is that
having been involved in all of it, a lot of times when we go back
and we look at the communication, it makes sense. It makes sense to us
because we've been a part of it the entire time.
But having seen it from the citizen standpoint, if you're
just stepping into it and all you're doing is looking at the, um,
like the budget and brief or things like that, it doesn't— cover a lot of
the details that we covered over hours of different meetings.
When we do our budget process, we do break it down into different work
meetings where we start to talk about operational costs and personnel and
what those requests are related to that. We have a separate meeting where we talk
about our capital improvement plan and those particular projects.
We have just
areas where we break it down. And then when we're trying to put it all
together at the very end, A lot of that detail
is missed if people didn't attend
those particular meetings. So we've made note a lot of the feedback and we'll
work towards improving our processes so that
at the end, anybody who jumps in regardless
of the timeline, it's, it's clear to them on what is taking place
in the budget's changes from year over to
year from that. One of the complexities that we deal with as
a city has to do with the
different activities from a governmental standpoint versus our business-type
activities, the restrictions in funds. As you guys know,
there's a lot of resources that come into play. There's been a lot of
questions about our development and why can't
we require development to just pay more money.
One of the things I wanted to point out about that was a number of
years ago, I think it was 2022, there were
some new bills passed at the state legislature that
restricts the fees that we collect related to development-related.
So when they're paying an application fee or they're paying a building permit,
those charges are restricted and can only be
used to provide the service that someone is paying for. That's really
the difference between a fee and a tax. And so the state was coming down
and identifying, if we are charging more money than it really
costs to issue that building permit and provide those inspection services,
then what we're doing is levying a tax, and we're taking that to help cover
other operational costs within the general fund. And the state has said you're
not allowed to do that. With those restrictions that went into place,
it did impact our ability to fund other
things that we do consider growth-related, such as,
you know, the public safety costs, the enhancements to
parks and things like that that come with, with the growth.
We're not able to use those resources anymore. That partially
led to why we decided to pull that out into its own special
revenue fund. Because those resources are restricted and can
only be used for that purpose. And it— we
wanted to make sure it was clear that that money isn't available for
us to use for day-in and day-out operations for other services
within the general fund. So that was one of the changes that has taken
place over the last couple of years that removed some resources
that the city did have to help pay for those growth-related
costs. That is not something that's available to
us anymore.
There's a lot of talk about just the rate, and people
like to compare us to like Lehigh or Saratoga Springs.
So when we talk about, as we've done for a lot, about what the property
tax rate is,
the rate is what we're always talking about, but the end result is what we
need is how much revenue do we need to operate, um, the city?
So when people say, hey, well, Lehigh City has a rate
that's much lower than ours, well, the rate that they have in place generates $15.9
million for them. And so it's not about
how high our rate is, it's about the revenue that we're generating to provide
the needs for our community. So it
does make it hard when we try to compare compare, because there
are a lot of unique things here in Eagle Mountain that came up tonight,
um, where people talked about how we have 2 different communities and we have a
lot of infrastructure that has to connect everything in between.
And, um, the rate that was originally, um, adopted last,
um, at the Truth in Taxation hearing of the 0.0015,
um, although the rate was higher compared
to Lehigh or Saratoga Springs, the revenue that it generated was less than both of
those communities would also see. And they also have a significantly
greater commercial resource available
where they have higher sales tax dollars that are coming in.
But it's really about what are the needs of our community. That's really all
we're looking at. It's not about comparing us to other cities.
It's about what do we need in our community to meet service levels that
our residents expect, and to be able to,
again, always look sustainably.
And that's our goals and our objectives when
we come forward and we look at budgeting.
Some of the additional questions that were raised were
about, you know, the amount of
money we had in our capital projects fund already.
And so again, a couple of years ago, that reserve
was a lot higher, and it is higher because we had
proceeds related to our road projects for when
we had issued our sales tax bond in 2022 to fund
a bunch of our big road projects that all got completed,
and those funds have been spent down. So when we see things that
say fund balance, it doesn't necessarily mean it's money we can There's
a lot of different resources that tie into that about what that money
can be used for.
And it does make it hard on these summary documents.
Obviously, people— it just looks like a savings account
with a total amount of money, and why can't we use that? So we
will look at being able to break that down where we can see the different
classifications about what has already been committed or assigned. to projects,
what's restricted specifically for certain types of spending like
our transportation dollars. So there's definitely some things that we
can do to try to communicate that information
better about what is going on.
I want to actually just jump into some of these items and
about our budget process and timeline
and what the goals that we, we had hoped to be able to accomplish.
So When we do look at our budget and planning,
the main things that we are really always focusing on is trying
to align those priorities, plan for the future, and build consistency.
That really is the basis behind all the things that we're doing
that we roll up to, to make sure that we are able to,
again, sustain our community long-term and that it's not just
a place that people come to because it's the only place they can afford,
but hopefully it's a place that people come to because Eagle Mountain is a
community that they want to be a part of.
With our budget process and the cycles that we have,
we do identify, and it is just cyclical
in that way. Our budget process is a year-long process. We do
start over again in October. October with that,
but it does involve the planning, the budgeting, the monitoring,
and the engagement that we have.
So we did have a number of public
meetings. We made an effort to attend some of these events
that the, that the city put on this year and to run a booth.
We've done that for the last couple years where we actually have a budget booth.
We're trying to get out to the So we recognize that people can't always make
it to meetings, and so we've made an effort to try to get out into
the community places where people might be to try to share and pass
on the information and invite people. I— this is what I do,
and I love it. And I know you as a council have heard me say
it a number of times of how often we have a public hearing
for budget processes and nobody shows up for it. And,
um, trying to find a way That people
are engaged and want to know what's going on, not just because we do
a tax hearing, but because they,
they want to be a part of that process all the time.
And I welcome that, and I'm grateful to see
so many people be involved at this point.
When we look at our— the budget in terms of the system of
a lot of things that are feeding into it, The strategic
plan is a high level where we're trying to— again,
this is where the council set that really high long-term vision.
It is covering typically a 5 to 10 year plan of
what we're trying to accomplish in the community. And so when we budget, a lot
of times we talk a lot about line items, and those are things that are
needed for accounting purposes. But really, all those line items roll up
into services, and what is the service level that we're providing
to our community, and how do we
meet that. And the strategic plan is one of those things that
help us make sure that when we are enhancing programs or we have requests
to increase service levels, that it falls in line with what the council is
trying to accomplish for our community. So we do
look at the strategic plan. A large portion of
our budget is our capital infrastructure, and it's not just
about building the new infrastructure, but it's also about providing the funds
to maintain that. What we don't want is to require
all of our developers to put in amazing parks and amenities for
our residents that then we're not able to maintain, and all it
is is an asset that is deteriorating. It's important that
we're able to maintain that quality of life for the residents who live here,
as well as those residents that will move in into the future.
Performance measures. So one of the things actually that we've
talked about with the— I think for the last 2 years we've been talking internally
and we've been talking a little bit with the council, and that is about
trying to talk more about the budget from a service
level standpoint. And with that comes those performance measures. performance measures,
and then the accounting and the reportability to where we can respond
and show the council what the result of
the efforts put forth, and that we can say if we're adding more money to
provide a service, has that improved our
ability to meet that end objective? So implementing
some of those performance measure tactics is something that we have been moving forward with.
for the last 2 years within our budget.
The relationship between the budget process and long-term financial planning.
Again, these are all the items
that kind of go in and feed into that overall. One of
the big differences when we're talking with our governmental funds is it really
is— and when I talk governmental funds, that means that those are the
funding sources that come really from sales tax dollars. You're providing a service
that you aren't able to charge a fee for to cover that service. It's a
service that's a benefit to everyone, and therefore taxes
are what's used to cover it. And because it's taxes,
a lot of the, the what you're looking at really
is designed to be short-term, and that is why the,
the state has put a maximum
on the 35% fund balances, they want you to only raise the money that you
need for this year. And if you need more money next year, they want you
to ask for it. So as a result, that's, that's a shift that
we're trying to make again, which is where we're talking about our taxes basically
every year to determine what our needs are within the community.
And that, that is a conversation that,
that we're not afraid to have when it comes to truth in taxation
and so forth. That it really is a conversation about what the needs are and
that we can find that balance and between the
services that the citizens would like to see and what it would take for
us to provide that level of service.
Overall, the goal again with our budget is that it
is a guide on how we do it. It should be a
budget as a policy guide, a financial plan, a communication tool,
and an operations guide. That's always our goals as we
go into the budget process and what we're looking at.
And what we will work towards is having
more of that information up front. Historically, our full
budget book, it doesn't get released and it's not available until
after the budget is adopted. And that's where most of the material
comes to communicate with residents about what's in the
budget going forward. But it didn't give them that information during the planning
processes. So those are some of the changes that we will shift to try
to make sure that really this guiding document can
function better as a communication tool as well.
So, as mentioned with the budget process and the timeline,
we did— this is just kind of highlighting some of the
things that took place for us in our budget process there. With our kickoff
that started October. And then the
budget work meetings that we had as we went in through January, February, all the
way to the tentative budget in May. And then with our interim budget
and our Truth in Taxation process. So we
will be finishing our budget. We have to have everything approved and
submitted by the end of— by August 31st. 31st,
and then we have 1 month to get our stuff ready
to kick off the 2027-28
budget in October again. So here's
just a little bit of an overview. This comes from the budget in brief that
was put out, talking just about some of the
metrics about our community and the service level delivery
snapshot that we have about the number of parks, the number of miles
of roads that we're trying to maintain,
and the water services and so forth. So just a few of
those. Obviously, it doesn't cover all of the metrics
and all that we have going in our community, but just a snapshot.
And I know earlier in the meeting, there were some additional
highlights that kind of compared us to some of the other cities too about
the services that we are providing. Let's see,
with the fund types, I mentioned this a little bit,
but I want to talk just a little bit, not to try
not to be too much, too lengthy, but to really
talk about the difference between those governmental types of funds versus the business type funds
and what we have here at Eagle Mountain City.
So, the ones that have a single asterisk are
our governmental type funds. So for us, that is the general fund.
We have what we call special revenue funds.
And then we have our capital project funds and internal service funds
and the debt service fund. All of these types of activities
are really just subaccounts of what we would
consider our general fund. When we do a special revenue fund,
it means that they're typically restricted resources,
like grants, or again, those building and community development
related fees that are now restricted. We pulled those out into a special revenue fund
this year. They're funded with charges for services.
But to have a special revenue fund, you're required to
be able to generate more revenue from
basically a charge for service than you would from a transfer in
to fund those services. So we do have some restrictions.
And in relation to that, we use special revenue funds for
some of our impact fee monies because, again, even though we
have impact fees for water and sewer, they're actually grouped up.
They're part of the enterprise fund. And so when we're
looking at the water fund, it is their operations As well,
and then we will break out and we'll kind of show you the projects that
are being funded. But those impact fees are classified as
those enterprise business type activities. So we have a lot of things that kind
of cross over that can make it a little bit confusing about
what is being funded when you have what we call a capital projects fund,
but that doesn't actually include all of the projects for
the city. It only includes those governmental type projects.
And then the projects for water and sewer are located
within those separate functions and stuff.
So we did have a budget that was proposed that was this $363
million. There'll be some changes to these numbers that we
will address as the council discusses the way that
we want to look at the revenue shortfall
from the change in the property tax revenue that would be
generated. We do have,
from a personnel standpoint, I broke these out just into
the functional areas as a summary showing
the full-time and part-time positions that are currently funded
citywide. And I did group
those public safety positions that are in here as well.
For our general fund revenues and general fund expenses,
we are at this $41,
just under $41.5 million in terms of what the
budget is proposed. But with that, like, if we were
doing kind of a comparison to previous years and so forth,
one of the percentage changes that is the higher
is the transfer that we had proposed to the capital project
fund while, as a resource from
the new revenues that were going to be coming in from those property taxes.
Okay, there are 2 areas
that are kind of similar that I just wanted to hit on. These are
also questions that kind of came up that we saw out there in the public.
One of them is an item that we call cost allocations.
Sometimes people might know the term as more like an administrative overhead cost.
I'm going to jump to the next slide and then come back to this
one. So if you were looking at the online budget
and you went into one of the funds or one of the service departments,
you might see a line item that says administrative costs.
And this one that I'm using as an example here has
a negative number. And so when you see something like that,
it's identifying that this is a department that provides
services to the entire city, but it sits
within the general fund. And so when we're talking
cost allocations for us in the general fund, those service
departments that we have are listed here on this slide. But what we
do is we're identifying that Even though Human
Resources sits in the general fund, it provides those
services for the water and the wastewater,
stormwater, all the other different fund types that we have that have employees.
They're also benefiting from that.
And so the cost allocation,
we actually have a giant spreadsheet. We use a reciprocal method.
We have drivers that we create. So on the human resource side,
we actually use the number of employees that each department has to
determine their share of the cost that that needs to take place.
And as a result of that, then you will see an outflow of money.
So we, we would budget the entire cost for the department,
but then you'll see an outflow of the administrative costs, which is the share
of the budget that is being picked up and
redistributed. to the departments that are
receiving that benefit. And,
um, we call those, um, those administrative costs,
and it— the purpose is so that you can,
you can see what the full cost is to, to budget the department,
but you can also see what the full cost would be if we didn't have
any of those other services involved.
That, um, like if we didn't have a water or sewer fund and things like
that, then Part of these costs would go
away. The benefit is, if you were like, again,
if you're a special service district and all you do is provide water,
they have to have all of these same overhead. They need an attorney, they need
to have a human resource department. The benefit
to us is that we get to share those costs across
the organization, very similar to what we do with the sheriff's contract.
So, because the sheriff's contract is part of the Utah County Sheriff's
and part of the Utah County administration in general, we get to
have the benefit of all the administrative services that they provide to
us, um, that if we
were doing our own police department, we would then need to pick up, um,
more additional, um, administrative overhead to be able to provide those
services as well. Kind of
similar to that is transfers. So when we're
talking about transfers, we are required
to have a separate set of balance sheet accounts and revenue
and expenditure accounts for every fund that we have, so that we are accounting for
the money that is generated from those charges or services
and the type of cost to fund those programs.
And so when we need to send
money over to another department, it's done as a transfer.
Transfers are not a loan. It doesn't create new money for the city,
but it does inflate our overall budget because you're,
you're kind of double counting those expenses. You're— it's an
expense as it goes out of the, of the fund that it's transferring
out of, and then it's an expense when the money actually is,
is used for whatever purpose it was.
In our city, we have
3 what we call internal service funds,
meaning the entire purpose for them is to provide services
to other departments within the city. So for an
example of that is we have our fleet fund. It's an internal
service fund. So All of the vehicles that the city owns and all of the
maintenance costs for those vehicles resides within the fleet
fund. And every department
who uses a vehicle has to pay their share towards that.
And because it's an internal service fund, it happens as a transfer
rather than a cost allocation. But it functions
very much the same way. They're— you're paying for your services.
We do transfers, not just for that type of purpose,
but the only way to get money to the capital project fund is by
a transfer. There, there's no
fees that you generate for those,
the capital project improvements that we're funding out of that capital project fund.
So the way that you get money is it is money that you're
earning in the general fund that then is going to the capital project fund.
Going over to the capital project fund, or if we get like
a grant from UDOT or a MAG contribution,
that is another way that we can have resources. But essentially, it's contribution
and transfers is the only way that we actually
get resources into those capital
improvement projects that are not impact fee eligible or impact fee related.
This budget year, we do have $94 million in
capital improvements that are planned.
We have capital improvements that for
2026 that won't have been completed.
So in September, we'll be doing our first budget amendment.
But what that does is, again, capital projects
They typically last— they cross fiscal years. A lot of times it takes multiple years
in construction for those to be finished off, but the budgeting
cycle is just a 1-year cycle. So once
we have finished closing out the previous year, any of those projects that weren't complete,
then we have to roll that funding over so that we continue that and
get those finished off. So there will be additional
increase to the budget that will take place when we do that. But it's not
new spending. It's, it's just to continue these projects that have already
started. But for the new year, we do have $94 million in
anticipated new projects that
is an investment in our community. So I know
it was still— it might have seemed long, but actually that's really quite brief
in general to some of the items that are included
in the budget and the budget process.
So, That has taken place really over the last 10 months
of this year. If the council has any questions
that they want me to try and address in more detail,
then I'm happy to do so.
Great presentation. Thank you, and I hope that was educational.
So happy to have all the discussion that's needed, but we've
been going through this forever. Mostly for the public's sake,
it's just so we could kind of go over it again. I know, uh,
employees have been talked about ad nauseam.
Uh, now that we kind of know, at least for today, where that number's
at, any questions? Anything that we need to talk about on this? What direction
you want to go? So now we're talking
about the budget budget. There you go. This is our opportunity.
This is your chance. Okay, for the 100th time, announce all the people
you don't want. I'm teasing.
Now let me, let me pull it up here.
There's really just one section. I don't know, I don't feel as comfortable,
uh, bringing our reserve capital reserve account down.
So there are some things that I would just contend
that we probably should hold off on, or, or, or maybe not
pressing priorities given the state of everything that we've just
been through as a city.
Sorry, I should have had this pulled up.
While he's looking at that, is anybody else quick on that? Yeah,
well, I, I wanted to kind of get a little discussion. And I'm
sorry to make you wait, but I think that was beneficial to hear
what we're talking about before we open the public hearing.
So, you want to— you got anything while he's looking that up? No?
Okay, I, I think I, I think I found it.
So there were some things that were presented for,
for, uh, 2027.
Um, one of them was relocating the rodeo grounds.
There's $1 million budgeted for that. And I'm,
again, I'm just looking at areas that we could pull out that
would not require us to go as deep into our reserves. That would
be one thing. Um, the, all of this,
the, the road projects, I, I feel comfortable with.
That was one that stuck out to me. There's also a proposed land acquisition
for $2.5 million and a
civic campus for half a million dollars. I believe that is the,
uh, City Hall study design piece.
I don't know that we're in a hurry, uh, to do that this year.
I mean, those are 3 things. I mean, right there,
there's $4 million, and that keeps us out of going into the
reserve. Um, if, if our financial circumstances
change and we want to move forward, we can always make
a budget amendment to bring them back in. So I'm not in it. I don't
know that we need to be in a big hurry. I'm gonna say, Councilman Hughes,
I like that because my, my reticence in—
sorry, my resident— why I was reticent in the last part,
I don't want to see us have that reserve account at
a minimum level. I think we need— we
don't know what's on the horizon, and I hate to not be prepared for
somewhat of a short-term emergency. Correct.
So, to recap your list, rodeo ground, million.
What else? Okay, well, your mic
went off. I don't know. It was everything under that. That was my fault.
Under the administrative presentation, I believe that Steve Mumford gave.
I think it was May 26th.
I might be wrong. So the land acquisition for $2.5
million, and I understand that real prices are going to go up.
But I also want to be a realist and just say, can we really afford
to write a check for $2.5 million in good conscience and
reduce our reserve fund? I mean, these are the trade-offs. So, as a city,
we just need to be comfortable with the fact that in a year or 2
years, when we feel more financially ready for it, that it's going to probably
cost $3.5 million. So,
um, that— so those were the things relocating the rodeo
ground. There was $30,000 allocated to a field house.
I believe that was some money that was more of a match from
the Smith Entertainment Group and Utah County.
The Civic Campus design, land acquisition, and the rodeo.
So that was $4,030,000. And then the
other comment that I wanted to make is, and I didn't know this before
serving on council, but there's about— it may not
now be. $3 million, it might be $2.8 million in
our utility fund. I would propose for the park projects,
uh, if I go down to page 20, and,
and just for those that are following at home, that this is all available
on our city portal. So you can go look at the same information that I'm
looking at. This is all publicly available line by line. But under
parks, we were considering, um,
The observatory, that, that's been done, or,
or it's funded with outside sources. That's funded with outside sources.
And I will jump on real quick. Data center, that was paid almost
$1,250,000. Natalie,
$1,250,000, I think. Data center, we didn't pay a penny. The, uh, the,
the ranches, Pony Express Parkway to SR 73, that's being paid for through
MAG. I understand that. Uh, Nolan Park.
Now, this is a— these are 2026 estimates, but these improvements
that we're looking at, the City Center Street
Escape, say that 10 times fast,
uh, was being considered at $792,000. Can that
be paid for with that same— with those same funds from the utility seller?
No, the streetscapes in City Center? No.
Couldn't— so I don't understand the question. That's why— Mayor, I can respond
to that. So, Councilmember Hewish, yes, the city streetscapes
project was a project being funded with the utility cell proceeds.
Okay, perfect. So there's $1.5 million in
parks, and I just want to make sure that we're using those restricted funds
from the utility cell for, for that.
And I think just sake of conversation,
residents have said, and we're getting the RAP tax.
You know, that's, that's additional funds that could be allocated in the future
for some of these projects. But in the meantime, we got to take care of
our general fund. Just, and I'm just going to throw my 2 cents
in, and I know I don't get to have much of a say, and maybe
unpopular with the public, but we, the City Hall design.
We're already 3 or 4 years out on that if we keep our foot on
the pedal. And I'm telling you, there's no way we can survive.
I would advocate to keep the City Hall piece in, not necessarily land, but the
design, because that's— that pushes us backwards. I think—
Sorry, Mayor, I was just going to say, I think there is some wisdom
in doing the design because the design helps us understand what the
financial target is for for that and what we need to
figure out to fund and stuff like that. I also, I want
taxpayers to understand that every month we're paying between $10,000
and like $11,000 in rent to, to house
our resident or our staff in other places. And there's some
staff— well, who was it? Was it Craig that was— we
were talking about a rent— one of our staff members Shares a desk,
but can only be there during certain times of the day. And there's certain days
of the week. I'm looking at you. We don't have room
in our city hall. I hate to break it to you. I think that
in the long run, starting making incremental progress
toward that will save our taxpayers money because it's costing
us money right now because we don't have enough room.
No, you can't go to Amazon and get your city hall shipped
to you and Here's the challenge is like, what's our population going to be,
or our employees, our employee count 4 years from now,
5 years from now? What is that employee count? So I think we have to
keep going down that pathway and, and, and pushing that
along. So I, I think we— I don't— I couldn't take that one off
the table. But like the, the rodeo grounds,
I'm very comfortable with those. The rodeo grounds
is funded out of— and by the way, I'm not in that conversation at all,
but where did those funds come from? Because the reserves is only general fund,
and if that's utility sales, then that doesn't help the reserve.
Do you remember, Kimberly? Do you know what that one was?
Yes, sorry, Mayor. The rodeo grounds right now is— is
that particular one is flagged out of just the
general fund, uh, capital project reserves, not utility sale proceeds.
Then that's the right one. And, and I can— I can't report anything.
I think Brett's the one that would know. I don't think there's much movement on
that. So, so there's no rush.
Perfect. Okay. And question, how far down
with the 0.0009 that we just landed on,
how far down are we on the reserves from where we would want it
to be? So we know other things that we could try to manage. Kimberly,
can you like, Put that into your little spreadsheet and tell us. I think,
I think it's $4.6 million is the shortfall.
So that's what I'm trying to find. Yeah, and I
think there's going to be— she just mentioned our first budget amendment, which is just
allocating funds, is in a month. I think if we can identify a
few of these, we can move forward knowing that we can trim on this.
Uh, I think there's some room for employees to be added and be taken off.
I've identified one that I think Councilmember Wood agrees that,
uh, some project management, you know, that's something we got to talk about. It's not
in this budget. Um, so if,
if we can move forward with some kind of idea, go ahead.
So if we take the $1 million out for the
relocate rodeo grounds and we take out the land
acquisition, that's $3.5 million. That leaves us about $1.1
million that we need to get to if don't want to dip into our reserve.
So if you feel like you can trim another 1.1, we can do that,
or you can take that out of the reserve. Well, and honestly,
1.1 out of the reserve is not— it's not critical, it's not killer.
What would be our fund balance if we took 1.1 out of there, Kimberly?
Would we still be at the 25 or 28%?
Well, with You'd
be roughly 28%. Let's do that.
Okay, that's a good compromise. Just do those
2. Okay, so if,
if it looks like— I'm just going to recap. So it looks like we're taking
out maybe those 2, probably still going to be able to fund what we need
to fund in the employees. Uh, did I capture that right so we can
have the public hearing. All right, uh,
with that, I think we've had a good discussion, and this is a public hearing.
So, uh, at this time
it is 11:29, and we will hold a public hearing. I know
there are people that waited for this. We will open the public hearing.
Charles Peterson,
he was in our office yesterday. He did write a lengthy letter So
we can get that to you as well. Joy Rasmussen.
So I was confused because on the website it said
that there was only a public hearing about this item, not about the property tax.
So that's why I didn't understand.
So I saw somebody post online about property tax. Before you increase
property taxes, ask yourself, Is this worth someone losing their home
over? There are going to be people who can't afford
increases. In Utah, we are the top 10 in the nation for housing costs,
the cost of a home payment. I work full-time just
to pay our house payment. Mothers all over Utah are not home
parenting their kids, or they're working from home like I do and not present.
And so kids are getting into trouble. That's why we're having more crime with the
youth, more problems with drugs, more other stuff going on with the youth running
around because the moms have to work to pay for the housing.
So, um, somebody messaged me,
an elderly lady. She said, so much for trust government. It was about the
previous tax increase. Now our taxes go up because they probably gave
the data center tons of tax breaks for only 100 jobs. We live on a
fixed income. My Social Security is $1,244 a month and my
hubby's Federal retiree is less than $2,500 a month, and when he died— dies,
he's 83 with Parkinson's and dementia, I only get half his retirement.
Our house is completely paid off, but if he has to go into an assisted
living, that will take all his money and will put liens on my home for
his care, about $5,000 a month. How can I afford property taxes that way?
This has to be— anyway, so she— that's why I'm here. I'm not here
because I can't afford what you've passed, and I appreciate you lowering it. I appreciate
you listening. Thank you. listening. But Meta did get breaks.
Meta got a $150 million property tax break in 2018,
$77 million property tax incentive in 2021.
QTS got tax increment financing and community reinvestment area,
so they're getting rebates on their property tax. They're barely paying any property tax right
now. So when you say that they want to pay more,
are they going to give back these incentives that are published in Deseret
News. I've— I mean, I've looked up reliable news sources. City leaders,
um, you, you said the property tax was needed to help with water and
sewer needs, but we'd already— you guys already voted on a $220 million
bond that was supposed to be for water and sewer. You voted
for automatic 12% water rate increase every year in 2024,
and I think the amount you said was going to be like, oh, it's only
$30 more a month. So we add all these little things that you're adding on
to people, and it adds up really fast to their house payment,
to how much they can afford just to live and to drink and to flush
the toilet. Um,
there was a podcast where several of you were present,
and, um, uh, Craig— 30
seconds remaining. You mentioned that the legislature was going to cap property
tax increases, and that's why you guys were trying to increase property taxes, because you
think I think that the legislature is going to do it again next year and
that the city opposed that and helped fight it. And so I just
think there needs to be honesty with, with, with us about what it's really for.
And Craig, you also said that the residents should go
out and earn money. It's easier now than in the history of ever to go
out and earn more money, more opportunities. I have kids looking for jobs that haven't
been able to find a job. I've been at the same job for 4 years
and I've only gotten a $2 an hour increase in 4 years. Your time
is up. Thank you. Jason Rasmussen.
Um, hello, and thank you guys for, um, your consideration and,
and the conversations that you've had, and I'm sure that this has been,
uh, difficult. I think that, um,
as you— as I think about it, uh, I think a lot of this is
about communication and, and clarity and maybe what
we were told initially the, the purpose of this was,
um, and that maybe it was for a lot broader,
uh, needs than just like funding
the, the Sheriff's Office. And I think if we had a little bit more clarity
at the beginning, you know, like what we had, uh, today, that it
would have helped a lot in helping us to understand And, um,
Jared, I know that— noticed that you were shaking your head about kind
of the, the quoting the $150 million and the $77 million.
This is coming from Deseret News. I'm not— I don't know that I know everything
about it. So, like, in terms of the data centers, I've heard,
um, you— I've heard the previous mayor mention that they're our
partners. Um, I think we need to understand as citizens
how they're being partners. I know you mentioned the
$1 million. I don't know, I forgot what it was funding, but there
was like a $1 million line item that was like the data center was providing
that in the conversation earlier.
But we need to understand how they're partners. And I think
in addition to that, if they want to continue to build, I think
they need to help us understand and maybe
show us what they're going to do to kind of alleviate some
of the burdens that that, you know, the general population is
experiencing as taxpayers, because if they want to build here,
they need to invest in our community. And we need to be
very clear. They need to be very clear to us in how they're going to
invest. Otherwise, I don't know that it's worth the
traffic and the construction and everything else in the water
and everything else that's involved in them. being in our community. So thank
None of that inappropriate stuff. I'll throw you out.
Lastly, Michael Thompson.
I want to go back to the, the idea of bringing more
revenue in to cover some of these things that we need.
And specifically address what Ms. Clark had to say.
In my generation, this would be considered very strong language, but to hell
with the homeowners association.
In the 6— in the last 6 years, I have been cheated,
lied to by 2 major builders in this city,
TJ Thomas and Clark, and neither One of them had the
courage to face me face to face, and they cheated all my
neighbors as well. And they even colluded with the previous administration
to— in some of that. And I can give you details on that at another
time if you like. But I know that some
of the richest people in this state are builders, and they have a lot
of politicians in their pocket. Don't let it happen to you.
I have fought hard to replace some of the previous administration
and, and brought in people, at least 2 of which are here now, that I
worked real hard to help get in here.
If they're going to build all these houses, they need to cover the cost of
the infrastructure to support them.
Thank you.
Okay, was there anyone else that did not get a chance to speak on this
item? Please fill out a paper when you're done and return.
Do you need a paper on that? She's got me on file.
Yeah, she needs another one. Just humor me.
Okay. I like the discussion about kicking
the city hall down. I like that a lot, and I think
I can't speak for everybody, but I think a lot of my fellow citizens would
appreciate that as well. I want to encourage you to, to pause the design as
well, because if you design something and then in 2 years
you guys could be gone and the plan could be new, and then all the
design fees just get wasted. So that would be my additional encouragement for
the city hall. I know you guys are hell-bent on it. You really want it.
Another thing to consider is half of this building is occupied by
the sheriff's department. We're renegotiating that contract,
apparently. Maybe it's time for them to find somewhere else to go. Find a new
home, a new office space, and then you have your space for
your employees, if that makes sense. Um, there was one more thing.
I like the comments about the developers. Don't get into their pockets.
I will find you out. Um,
there was something else that was really important about saving money,
but maybe it wasn't that important. So, thank you.
Happy to take a private message if you remember.
Was there anyone else who wanted to speak on this item?
Um, seeing no one, we'll close the public hearing
and bring it back to the council. Uh, just a couple quick things that
I'll jump on there. It was about $1.2 million, and it
was Facebook that gave that money for an observatory that's planned at Walden Park.
And that was something years and years ago. It started in 2021
is when it was announced. Yeah, it was just never
fully funded. Uh, this year we got a little pressure to fund
that, and it's another one of those that, that I got very aggressive and said,
I'm not going to the taxpayers and telling them to pay for something they
didn't ask for. Y'all halfway funded this and
then left it on our plate. Once again, this was Facebook.
They said, uh, hold on, I'll call you back. And he said,
check's in the mail. That's the kind of stuff I've been pushing back on.
And, uh, they fully funded that. Now that project will go forward.
So, it's recorded meeting, so you'll have to send us a message.
I can't do it. We can't. It's the rules. Sorry, man. I gotta
stick to it. Sorry. Um, the— and on the police note,
there is the police. The police shares this building. Another reason why
we're— and something that we hear a lot is, when are we getting our
own police? I think, and this is just my opinion, I don't know that it's
shared. It's just my opinion. If we had a city Hall, this could become the
police station, and we could move into our own police department. There's no way.
We, we don't have anywhere to put a police department of our own. There's nowhere
to put it. So I think in my mind, that's what makes that
City Hall piece first, and then the police
part, and then, you know, it's kind of a dominoes thing. But we can't
start a police department without having a, a City Hall or a place to put
them. So that's just some clarity on that. Thank you. Um,
oh, and, uh, just starting with the first comment,
QTS, uh, I think there's some numbers. The reason I shake my head, there's numbers
that are getting used on QTS or Facebook's and Facebook
this way. Uh, the first 3 buildings at QTS had a small tax
incentive. Uh, so the comment about, are they just giving us back our own
money? They— that all of their future buildings are
100% taxpayer. They're not asking for a penny. They're paying on day
one, and that's where they want to do that and give money.
So that, that's why I said no, that's just not true. Uh, they get a
little bit on the first 3, and everything since, 100% taxpayer. Mayor, could I,
could I just ask that we do this? I mean, I'm listening to the citizens
and they're saying, look, we— Jason in particular, I mean,
he says, look, we just want to know how are they partnering,
partnering with us. And it doesn't sound to me like we've done
a very good job of communicating that. Could we just put together some informational
flyer that just says, here are the things that Meta has done for us over
the last 5 years, whatever it is. Here are the things that QTS
has done for us so far, and here are the things that they're committed to
do. I just think if our residents could see that, that perhaps their attitudes
and understanding of whether or not they are community partners or not
might change. Because I think when you sit in this seat and see and
experience some of the things that I have, you— for
me, I, I start to wonder, how does everybody have this perception of them when
this is my experience? And I would like for you to each experience
that. So I'm going to ask you if you would perhaps consider doing something
with staff to communicate that. It's probably going to take
us a couple of days, but we can, uh, you know, we'll start working on
that. And I think they'll help us and show us some of that. Abby just
finished it over there. Come on, let's get serious.
Well, I actually— so I'm gonna put a plug in for an
open house and let's see if we could get reps
from both Meta and QTS to be here physically so that
residents can have face-to-face time with them and they can advocate for
them. The data centers can stand up for themselves
and be accountable and show off the cool things that they're doing
in our community. And have the handout. Like,
I just think face-to-face is good. So, thank you.
Just a couple quick comments responding to the public comment.
Um, the reason why Utah has the highest cost for housing is our
homes on average are the largest in the entire United States. The average home
size in Utah is 2,800 square feet. That ranks number 1 in the
nation for house size. That's why it's more expensive.
In terms of, like, the developer situation, I just want
to report to you, this city council has only approved
33 new vested housing units this
year. That's it. And those 33 are all affordable housing,
deed restricted owner occupancy, deed restricted to 80% area
median income or less for the buyer. So it's for affordable housing. Those are
gonna be approximately— don't quote me on this— $330,000 homes, fully landscaped,
fully fenced, all appliances, all blinds, ready to
go, detached single-family homes. And that's some of the
creative things that we have done partnering with developers who are concerned
about the growth of our community, growing it the right way, to bring to the
city. And I say 33, we actually reduce some out of that. So our
net effect is probably 20. 27 or 28 new units that we've actually— that's it.
And that, that's because of the council that you've elected to help manage the
growth and be serious about the management of the growth.
So just to give you that number. Um, Joy, I,
I appreciate you bringing up the conversation about what happened on the podcast. I'm happy
to talk to you more about that afterwards. Um, I would, I would invite you
or ask you to at least consider my comment in the context of,
context of my life that I've experienced Where I've also
skipped meals many days to provide food for my family, and that
was in the podcast. And if you selectively take out something
and not put the whole story in, then it may sound different, and as if
I'm being like not you know that
I'm concerned for those that are through that. I know what that's like. In fact,
I've worked most of my days in my life, my work life. I have worked
six days a week, and for for various
reasons. But it's I understand what it's like to have to. to,
to stretch very, very far to, to make things, to make things work.
But I appreciate you bringing that up because apparently I didn't communicate it well enough,
and that's why you felt the way you did. And I, again, I appreciate you
brought that up. So, um, I, I recognize we're,
we're, we're in a, we're really, we're in a tight spot, and, uh, which,
which influenced part of the why, you know, we voted the way I did in
the last, in the last vote.
Okay, I'm gonna, I'm gonna push the council just a little bit here, if that's
okay. To a motion? Okay, go ahead.
Maybe, maybe I'm, I'm getting close.
I, I think this, uh, we've heard
hours and hours of, of residents that are, that are— we're asking them
to stretch their budgets. I'm gonna maybe
ask us to stretch our budgets a little bit. Um,
when I look at the internet phone allowance
that comes every month, I already pay for internet and I'm already paying for—
um, what was the other one? For my phone.
And so I would consider removing that from city council,
or at least cutting it in half. I don't know if the council
would go along with me on that. I, I would be okay
to consider it, but I'm going to tell you one of the historic reasons why
it's there. One, so that we don't have to turn
in mileage, um, because there's just
incidental driving that we do as part of our role as city council.
The other thing to keep in mind is we may
be in the position that we can eat the cost of that, but there
may be someone coming down the road That we really want to
run for city council, and their financial position may necessitate
being reimbursed for the phone and the internet
expense. So I think historically,
that's been part of the conversation, at least, is we want to make
sure that we're not excluding really
amazing potential council members because of their
financial situation. Yeah, I'm just going to speak to that.
I'm the reason that we did the increase, and that, that is the
purpose. I don't think anybody in this city is looking for retirees and
rich people to be running our city council. And frankly,
I tried to put something in there that would allow everyday
man and woman to be able to come and serve and to have something to
help, because it is a huge, huge commitment
that there is a financial burden. for. And if there is
no way for them to be able to do that, then what I just previously
stated is exactly who will be serving on your council. So that's
a looking forward mechanism for any of you that have been
spending all of your time learning about taxes.
I hope that that moves you to the next step
of serving on boards, coming and putting your hat in
the ring to run for city council. So that I don't have to do this
after the 4 years, and I can be done, and you can take it over
for me, and I can go back to being totally anonymous again. Sounds like
a plug for the 3%. I just think that that's, that's the important part to
remember when we're doing some of these things. It's, it's not always about the
people in this moment. You're trying to plan for somebody to be able to replace
you that's going to come in and carry that, that torch. And if we keep
looking at it from a perspective of, Oh, really? We need to get it down
here or down here, down here. Then you're really just saying the only people who
are going to be able to do this is the people who can afford to,
uh, to not have income. Can I tell you what
I always say? It's not mine. It's just my turn. No,
you can't say that. No, thank you.
Mayor, I think we need to manage our time now. We've got a lot left
on there and an RDA. I'd like to propose that we set
a time to be complete with this meeting. Make a motion. I'd like to
move that we set a time for 12:30 to complete the regular city council
meeting. We better get rolling. There's a lot of business, and I think, I think
we can get to it. Make a motion. I just did. Second it. Second.
Okay, we got a motion. Second. That's what I meant. Sorry. We are to—
Councilmember Wood?
Yes. Councilmember Hughes? Yes. Councilmember Clark? Yes, Councilman Wright. Yep. Councilman Whiting.
Yes. Okay, we will set a time to adjourn at 12:30. So let's get to
work. Uh, back to the item. Are we ready to make a motion on that?
I'll make a motion. Go, go, go. I'd like to move that the— hang
on just a second, reset my screen here.
We're on C, right? 13C. I'd like to move
that the city council approve a resolution of Eagle Mountain City, Utah, adopting the fiscal
year 2026 to 2027 annual budget.
I have a question. Do I need to reduce the amount out of that total
number? What I would do is recommend that we, that we adopt it
with the adjustment as reflected by the new certified
rate. So moved.
Second. Because it is going to create some
numbers that change slightly. They're looking for some
guidance on that. You, you go. I have the account numbers.
You want the account numbers in the motion?
So, uh, you said you have the numbers, the— what the reduced number
will be with the lower tax increase? Yes, and the
account numbers in the budget. I don't know that we need
the account, the GL numbers. Um, I just—
Do you need us to specify the— sorry, it's late— the particular line items that
we're removing? Marcus, do you need us to remove the specific
line items from the budget? Because I can do that. Yes,
that would be— let me amend that.
We're moving $1 million for the rodeo
grounds and $2.5 million for land acquisition,
and then taking the remainder.
What is the total? It's like $1. Well, the rest just
gets funded. The rest is going to be funded from the reserve.
Is that clear?
Whoever the second is— I was the second. Yeah, has my blessing. I just—
if Kimberly wants to weigh in, make sure that she's okay with that as our
finance guru. Yes, I'm, I'm good with that.
Okay, uh, we got a motion, a second. Start the roll, Council Member Hughes.
No. Councilmember Clark? Yes. Councilmember Wright?
Yes. Councilmember Whiting? Yes. Councilmember Wood? Yes. Okay,
that vote passes 4 to 1. Can we hold on? Can we clarify who seconded
that? Uh, Councilmember Clark. Yep, Councilmember Wood
and Councilmember Clark. Um,
we— I think I want to go to 14 because if we gotta hurry,
this is time sensitive. We might have to take just
a few minutes. We might as well just do it.
Yeah, then is there a need? I'm gonna— okay, I'm gonna go back to
12A. Those are public hearings. Yeah. And it
is notices of public hearing. So do we have any questions or presentation needed
on this one? I know David's been here. I don't know where—
I think just have Brandon just do a quick synopsis of what it
is. Yeah, that's totally fine. So,
um, David had, had talked with
staff. We'd found a couple of things we wanted to fix, particularly,
um, if you, if you look in your, uh,
agenda packet, some of the— he present or provided a
presentation for you. There's a picture of 2 roads.
Uh, on one side it's named one thing, and on
the other side it's named something else. The idea is, is we just don't want—
we don't think it's wise to have roads being named one
thing on one side of an intersection and something different on the other side.
So simply, we're trying— the biggest thing we're trying to accomplish here is trying
to be consistent with our road names for ease
of navigation of our roads, especially for emergency
services. David also proposed a couple
of things in there about being more Updating the
way we refer to county, like when we've got an
easement we need to note on a plat,
and we used to refer to book and
page. It's just, we don't need to do that anymore. We just need a recording
number. And then he also talked
a little bit. And the other
thing that he mentioned was just Making
it a requirement for plat
applications to show, identify which land is
going to be maintained by cities. So just a couple of housekeeping
things. I think they're all well founded.
They're things that we've identified in the course of just our normal
review of plats. So that's— staff recommends you
approve those. Items, and, and that's
all I've got for you.
Okay, this has been pretty straightforward. It's just kind of aligning streets so we don't
have 2 different streets going different directions. Any discussion?
It is a— the only thing I want to say is that when we
make the motion, I'd like to give the instruction for them to set
a plan for updating the ones that are disparate throughout
the city. And just give us a plan to update those. What— that,
that's a 2 or 5-year plan. Great. Just let us know. Okay.
So this is a public hearing. Um,
at this time it is 11:55, and we will open the public hearing.
No one. Uh, is there anyone here that has not
had an opportunity to speak on this item? So,
on street names, seeing no one. We will close
the public hearing at 11:55 and bring it back to the council for discussion.
Go ahead. Just one quick thing to kind of quell
any concerns that Councilman Whitey
may have had. I did double check in order to—
a final plat has to meet the requirements of
a preliminary plat as well. So I could go into the exact language,
but it It's more complicated.
It just basically says that the plat must conform
to the requirements of the preliminary plat. So the fact that we mentioned
this, you noticed in the plat
amendment section of this proposal,
you notice there's a disparity between the preliminary plat and the
final plat. We didn't We didn't copy
the preliminary plat language into the final plat language. It was on purpose,
because if we mention it in the preliminary plat section,
we're covered because the code already says we have to meet the preliminary
plat— final plat has to meet the preliminary plat requirements.
Okay. With that clarity, I'm open
for a motion. If there's no discussion, I'll make a motion. Go ahead. I move
that the city council approve item 12A, an ordinance of Eagle Mountain City,
Utah, amending the Eagle Mountain Municipal Code 16.20.040,
preliminary plats regarding street names.
Second. Okay, we have a motion by Councilmember Wood and a second by
Councilmember Whiting. We'll start the vote with Councilmember Clark. Yes.
Councilmember Wright. Yes. Councilmember Whiting. Yes. Councilmember Wood.
Yes. Councilmember Hewish. Yes. Okay. This is the same exact
thing, so we don't need a second presentation. It's just the final plat, the second
part. Make a motion also. I do have a public hearing first. Yes, sir.
I was trying to, so I don't think it'll take long, but if
there's no discussion, uh, at 11:57,
I'll open the public hearing and ask Lacey who's here.
Is there anyone here that doesn't— that has not had a chance to speak on
this item? Man, this is not as fun as a taxing when we get 2
hours. Okay. Uh, at 11:57, I will close
the public hearing and bring it back to Mr. Wood. I just want to make
sure clarity. Uh, Brandon, he basically went
through what the final plat section of that was. And if it's on the preliminary
plat, final plat language got to be the same. So that's what we're approving.
I move that the city council approve 12B.
Uh, an ordinance of Eagle Mountain, Utah, amending Eagle Mountain Municipal Code 16.25040,
final plots. Second.
Okay, we have a motion by Councilmember Wood, a second by Councilmember Whiting. We'll start
the vote with Councilmember Wright. Yes. Councilmember Whiting.
Yes. Councilmember Wood. Yes. Councilmember Hewish.
Yes. Councilmember Clark. Yes. That passes 5-0. Okay,
now we're back in order for the first time in the night. And we are
on 14A, uh, the Mid-Valley Community Reinvestment Project
Area. This is a resolution of the Eagle Mountain City approving the
interlocal cooperation agreement between the Redevelopment Agency and Eagle Mountain
City. This is something that we've worked on for quite
some time, over years. So, um,
this item— Evan's here to present the item. It's a single presentation
for 14A, 14B, and 14C. 14, um, maybe just
a brief synopsis and then take the questions as they come.
So we— I want to get this done and we're limited, so without
missing anything.
I'm gonna skip
ahead, um, and, uh,
We'll move on to most immediate things right
now. Um, so we're talking about Mid Valley
CRA, which this covers, um, the new retail project area,
the 53-acre project area, um, between Old
Airport Road, uh, and Mid Valley Road, which will be Lake Mountain, uh, corridor now
off of Pony Express Parkway. This would be a new
development with major acres. major anchors of Smith's Marketplace and
Lowe's with a number of other businesses. And I think that's an important detail
to keep in mind, is that the CRA is not targeting a specific business
to benefit that one business. It is a whole project area benefiting multiple businesses
where we're trying to use this CRA to help attract a
lot of highly desirable businesses as well, and also facilitate the improvements
that we need in that area in terms of infrastructure. We're anticipating
that construction would start immediately. Um, after approvals
tonight, uh, and that we would start seeing, um,
some stores open as early as spring in 2028.
Um, as mentioned in previous meetings,
a lot of the, uh, use of the CRA is geared towards infrastructure
improvements. It would be helping to push Old Airport Road and full 5 lanes,
um, east of Pony Express Parkway, uh, as well as Mid-Valley
or Lake Mountain Corridor, also widening Pony Express Parkway
and adding several deceleration lanes, turn pockets,
a new light, all sorts of different things. And this is— we
use in this CRA sales tax dollars, new sales tax dollars
that are generated from this project area to allocate
to help pay this so that this can happen. This goes above
and beyond what the project would otherwise provide.
Um, in tonight's meeting, we're covering a number
of different things that all pertain to the CRA, including the
project area plan and budget. You have interlocal agreements, you have a participation
agreement, and there's an amendment to the development agreement. Um,
some, just some nuances to call out in an interlocal agreement.
Um, it triggers as soon as the first business is
open. There is a cap, uh, in in play with this.
There's a couple of different buckets of dollars that are coming into this
as well from grant monies from Utah County and from
dollars that came as interest earned from a previous road bond.
And we did stipulate that in this project that it must
begin construction within 8 months of approval, although we do anticipate, as mentioned before,
that they will start immediately. Participation agreement
also covers a number of different provisions. There is a Uh, what's called a TIF
bond that is part of this process, and that's because sales tax dollars don't
start accruing until the buildings are actually starting to open up, and we need dollars
up front to help pay for those infrastructure projects.
And, uh, so we wanted to make sure there's clear parameters around how that
TIF bond is to be used, that we are only using the CRA to pay
off the TIF bond. That's it. It caps it there, and we're going to try
and be as aggressive as we can paying that off as quickly as possible.
Um, I want
to give you a little bit of history real quick as far as how we
got to where we are, and then what this is anticipated to generate. You may
recall originally we were talking about a CRA that would include
not just the city, but also the county, and also that we were talking
originally having a participation of 62% from the city.
Um, there was a 3rd-party market study done to validate
all the stuff that we've been expecting to come out of this project. That 3rd-party
study validated that the project will be very successful
within our community, um, assuming everything that we're putting into
it, um, works well. Um, that 3rd-party
study allowed us to renegotiate, bring that participation down to 55%,
and also relieve the county of any participation in that wholly.
So now it's just us. Um, we're also anticipating at that 55%,
We could come lower, but we wanted to keep that a little bit higher so
that we could pay it off faster. So that was kind of the theory behind
that. Some of the numbers you'll see in here, the anticipated revenues to the city
during the CRA project area. So this is while the sales
tax is being collected for those infrastructure projects.
We're still collecting as a city $1.2 to $1.4 more millions
of dollars for sales tax. The sales tax total over the
20 years, if it goes the 20 years, would be $22 million that we would
still be collecting. And then we are collecting affordable housing dollars off of this project
as well. $2.7 million over 20 years.
Again, if it goes the 20 years after the CRA is completed,
after that bond is paid off, we're expecting about $2.5 to $3 million per year
off of this one retail project. Um, there's some additional
benefits we expect and outcomes to come out of this and why this has been
so Uh, important for us is that it is largest— it would be the largest
retail center of the city. Um, that brings a lot of jobs.
It allows us to be a lot more attractive in our retail recruitment efforts and
bringing some of the highly desirable businesses, the restaurants, the clothing stores,
all sorts of different things that people are wanting to see here. Um, we get
more RAP tax funds out of it. Um, it helps push forward
infrastructure projects that we're wanting to see pushed forward and making sure they're not just
Starting, but they're also being built at full width from the beginning, rather than
having to do expansion projects down the road. Um, and so
on and so forth. Um, kind of talked
about this part already, so I'm gonna just go into this conclusion that, uh,
we've, we've spent a lot of time, as the mayor mentioned, on this.
Um, and we believe it's in a really good spot, and we think it's going
to be a very positive thing for our community to be championing
and supporting this going forward. So I'm happy to answer any questions
you might have about any of these things that we're going over tonight.
We've seen this a lot. These are basically all roads that we would
build anyway. It just allows us to finance it with sales tax dollars.
So any questions for Evan or for anyone else?
If not, this is not a public hearing, so we're ready
to rock and roll with either questions or motions,
starting with 14A. Mayor, I move that the City Council
adopt a resolution approving an interlocal cooperation agreement between the
Redevelopment Agency of Eagle Mountain City and Eagle Mountain City for the collection
and remittance of incremental property taxes collected from property tax within the Mid-Valley
Community Reinvestment Project area.
Second.
That, uh, it says property tax,
but isn't this sales tax?
Uh-oh. Is it in the
packet? It says— I just want to make sure because the motion, it should say
sales tax. That's not— so I just see that as a typo in
the agenda. I will amend my motion and, and strike,
uh, property taxes and replace it with sales tax. Thank you.
Thank you. That's important. I heard that and I was like, wait a minute.
And I'll second. Okay, we got a motion by Council Member Wright, a second by
Council Member Hewish. Um, we had Council
Member Clark? Yes. Council Member Wright? Yes. Council Member Whiting? Yes. Council Member
Wood? Yes. Council Member Hewish? Yes. Okay, this is,
uh, 14B. It's the exact same project. It's the next portion, uh,
approving the CRA participation agreement. So are there
any further questions on the agreement itself?
None. Motion?
No. I, I, I move, Mayor,
that the Eagle Mountain City Council approve item 14B.
Okay, as stated. Second. Second. Uh, so there's a motion by Councilman
Wright, a second by Councilman Whiting. We'll start with Councilman Wright? Yes. Councilmember Whiting?
Yes. Councilmember Wood? No. Councilmember Hughes? Yes.
And Councilmember Clark? Yes. Okay, that's 4-1, and that passes.
Um, 14C. Uh, Councilmember Wood,
we generally have an opportunity. Do you want to speak? Uh, yeah, I'm not in
favor of TIFs. I think we don't need to do them anymore.
Okay. Um, 14C is
an ordinance of Eagle Mountain adopting the community reinvestment, the Mid-Valley Community
Reinvestment Project area plan. So this is the plan,
um, same item. Now this one is important
that it is pending the approval of the RDA meeting that we're going to hold
after this meeting. So, uh, which is item 3A
in our next meeting. If there's any questions, if not,
I'll entertain a motion. Mayor, I move to approve item 14C,
contingent upon the approval by the By
the redevelopment agency. Second. Okay, we have
a motion by Councilmember Wright and, uh, second by Councilmember Clark. Is that okay?
Contingent rather than pending? Okay, same, just making sure. Um,
Councilmember Whiting? Yes.
Councilmember Wood? Yes. Councilmember Hewish? Yes.
Councilmember Clark? Yes. Councilmember Wright? Yes. Yes,
thank you. 5-0. Um, now the ordinance
of Eagle Mountain approving the 5th Amendment To the amended
and restated Overland Master Development Agreement.
Um, yeah, so this, uh, relates to the same project,
um, as this is in the Overland area. Um, so back
in March, the special city council meeting, the city council approved the development agreement
subsequent to that, and prior to any execution of the agreement,
or the 5th Amendment, I should say.
The developer wanted to make some changes to some of the language that are outlined
in the packet. And so that's, that's really
it. So we're making those— we're suggesting
those changes to you and seeking approval for that.
You're gonna let me run the gamut? Go for it. I'm just looking for questions.
I'm— yeah, I feel like— is everybody okay with that? Yeah, the changes.
Okay, um, um, Mayor, I move the Eagle Mountain City Council approve item
14B. Second. Okay, we have a motion
by Council Member Wright and a second by Council Member Clark. Uh,
Council Member Wood? No.
Council Member Hewish? Yes. Council Member Clark?
Yes. Council Member Wright? Yes. Uh, Council Member Whiting? Yes.
You want to say anything? Same reason?
No, this one's just— I don't think we should have taken off the ceiling for
that. I don't like having an open end in 5.3.
Okay. Um,
I, for sake of time, legislative priorities, I don't know if—
are we good going on? Okay, uh,
we'll catch up on that next time. Is there any other liaison reports or anything
that's time sensitive on that?
No. Um, unless— did we want to talk about
the Department of Workforce Services real quick? Maybe. Can you, can you just provide
the info on that? So the Department of Workforce Services
is coming and helping the city with a response to the Tyson
layoffs, and they're meeting, uh, Tuesday, Wednesday,
and Thursday from 1 to 5 starting next
week to provide job seekers Services,
and there's a couple job fairs and stuff like that. So check
out the information. The chamber's hosting that stuff.
Okay, anything else that's time sensitive in this one?
Good. I think I just want to add one other quick note just to
Councilmember Hewish's comment about the city council tightening their belt, maybe getting rid of that
$200 or whatever it is. My, my encouragement would
be for those that are in the position to do so,
to, to donate that to city causes. And I only bring
that up because we, we do have October 10th,
the, the race, the, the I Believe in You half
marathon that is raising money for our,
our volunteer police, the volunteer fire at Cedar
Fort, and also the Show Me a Sign that I the Foundation for Ben Lyon.
And I'm going to be, I'm going to be part of that, and I'm going
to be donating some money to that cause, um, to help, to help support
that. But that's an idea of how the city council can sort
of give back. Do you have to run to donate?
You don't have to run. There's, there's a 5K option,
5K, 10K, half marathon. You have to donate more if you
don't run.
Okay, Rich, I'm going to give you the chance to
not let Brett do it. We'll let him do it. Go.
Last motion. Motion to adjourn. Second. All right,
we have a motion by Council Member Wright and a second by Council Member
Whiting. All in favor? Aye. Aye. Any opposed? Hearing none,
we're adjourned next